[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
émission d'actualité parlementaire on
est ensemble jusqu'à 17h et au programme
dans une heure les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement c'est le temps fort de
votre après midi aux commentaires nous
aurons en lice bardot dans l'hémicycle
et pour les réactions alexandre poussard
dans la salle des conférences
à tout à l'heure le nucléaire est il
dans le viseur du gouvernement alors
qu'elisabeth bornes évoque un passage
possible 100% renouvelable et après le
séisme de lundi près de deux centrales
le pdg d'edf était auditionné ce matin
au sénat
on y revient dans un instant enfin après
l'immolation par le feu d'un étudiant la
semaine dernière plusieurs
manifestations contre la précarité été
organisée hier certaines ont dérapé
on va parler tout à l'heure de la
violence de ses mouvements mais aussi du
fond du problème
ces étudiants qui ne parviennent pas à
joindre les deux bouts et n'hésitez pas
à commenter cette émission avec le
hashtag qu âgées
et on va tout de suite rejoindre alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat bonjour
alice dans une heure maintenant vont
commencer les questions d'actualité
comment ça va se passer
alors une séance un peu particulière
aujourd'hui tam puisqu'elle va s'ouvrir
avec un hommage des sénateurs aux
victimes du 13 novembre quatre ans jour
pour jour après les attentats qui ont
frappé paris et sa banlieue
au programme ensuite ce sera la
précarité des étudiants notamment après
la tentative d'immolation d'un étudiant
lyonnais vendredi dernier alors il y
aura deux questions à gauche de
l'hémicycle
il y aura également deux questions sur
le séisme qui a touché à lundi la
commune du teil en ardèche
alors voilà donc un aperçu du programme
de ces questions d'actualité je vous
retrouve juste avant l'ouverture de la
séance
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications et on passe à présent au
premier débat de cette émission
le nucléaire est il encore l'avenir de
la france pas forcément pour elisabeth
bande qui appelle edf a envisagé un
scénario avec 100% d'énergies
renouvelables
qu'en pense le pdg de l'entreprise jean
bernard lévy il était auditionné ce
matin au sénat
résumé des échanges avec oodrive états
la france se prépare à construire de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires
affirmations catégoriques de jean
bernard lévy le patron d'edf
c'était il ya un mois dans la presse
d'après lui il faut construire six
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires d'ici 15
ans en france
coût total 46 milliards d'euros minimum
peut-être aurait-il dû utiliser le
conditionnel c'est en tout cas l'avis de
la ministre de l'ecologie recadrage sait
très bien qu'il est son point de vue que
je ne partage pas il se trouve que la
politique énergétique
c'est plutôt le gouvernement et en
particulier la ministre en charge de
l'énergie que je suis qui doit la
définir je la vis tu as intégré ce
scénario sur lequel travaille le
gouvernement 100% non renouvelable et y
compris je pense indispensable que edf
réfléchissent aussi à la façon dont qui
peut être un grand acteur dans un tel
scénario 100% renouvelable comprendre
sans le nucléaire
qui est pourtant l'adn d'edf oui mais
voilà le secteur connaît des déboires
avec la difficile mise en service de le
p r de flamanville prévu pour 2014
elle est reportée à 2022 et sa facture
explose 12,4 milliards d'euros pour
l'instant il n'empêche le patron d'edf a
plaidé une nouvelle fois en faveur du
nucléaire
ce matin devant les sénateurs nous
continuons de penser que le nucléaire
qui aimait pratiquement pas de co2 qui
est pilotable le nucléaire a toute sa
place à l'horizon 2050 dans le mix
français c'est la position d'edf et nous
pensons qu'il a toute sa place aux côtés
des énergies renouvelables puisque le
gouvernement le demande
edf va plancher sur un scénario 100%
renouvelable pour après 2035
rappelant tout de même que la france
part de très loin à titre indicatif
l'éolien c'est actuellement 5 % de notre
électricité et le solaire à peine 2% et
nous allons en revenir sur cette
audition avec quatre invités en plateau
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir charlotte
mijeon bonjour vous êtes porte-parole du
réseau sortir du nucléaire face avoue
françois lévêque bonjour vous êtes
professeur d'économie à mines paristech
et spécialiste du coût de la filière
nucléaire notamment également sur ce
plateau franck montaugé d'un venu
sénateurs socialistes gèrent vice
président de la commission des affaires
économiques vous étiez d'ailleurs ce
matin à l'audition de jean bernard lévy
et enfin sur ce plateau ladislas
poniatowski bonjour factor et l'air de
leur et vous êtes l'un des spécialistes
également de la question nucléaire ici
au sénat d'abord je vous propose un tour
de table on va faire le pour et le
contre du nucléaire ladislas poniatowski
un avantage et un inconvénient
j'ai toujours été pour et je m'en cache
pas et j'étais a toujours été un
défenseur de l'eau sans de filiale
nucléaire et ddf là-dessus même et une
raison qui veut l'indépendance
énergétique avant tout l'indépendance et
d'indépendance asiatique et un coût de
l'énergie qui jusqu'ici était à coup le
plus faible d'europe au profit des
entreprises et des particuliers en
france alors qu'on veniant quand même
passé le traitement des déchets radieux
de radioactifs mais on le gère pas si
mal que ça par rapport à d'autres pays
franck montaugé rapidement la question
est un peu binaire
ma réponse c'est une réalité le
nucléaire pour lui firent importante qui
a entre autre avantage de produire de
l'électricité décarbonée mais qui a
aussi des inconvénients c'est indéniable
notamment vigueur la question des
déchets à vous êtes plutôt d'accord
françois lévesque
moi je suis ni pour ni contre jeudi h et
un pointu eux non partisan et je pense
surtout qu'il faut dissocier le
nucléaire qui existe déjà et là je suis
pour prolonger l'exploitation des
centrales nucléaires d'edf à partir du
moment où évidemment elles sont
suffisamment sûre selon l'autorité
et si elles produisent du kilowattheure
moins cher et compétitif
en revanche le nouveau nucléaire c'est
que la question de construire une
nouvelle de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires c'est une question qui doit
être mise sur la table et notamment en
fonction des coûts relatifs de cette
technologie par rapport à d'autres
technologies
on va en parler charlette mission à ce
que vous reconnaissez au moins un
avantage au nucléaire puisque vous la
porte-parole de sortir du nucléaire
notre association je pense que là nous
focalise principalement sur ce qui pose
problème avec le nucléaire à savoir le
risque
d'abord le risque et si je peux juste
revenir sur certaines choses qui ont été
dites on parle d'indépendance
énergétique à ce que je sais toutes les
mines d'uranium françaises ont fermé
maintenant on s'approvisionne au niger
au kazakhstan donc considéré qu' on à
l'indépendance énergétique grâce au
nucléaire c'est quand même ça revient à
considérer que ces pays lhc chez nous et
avoir une attitude un peu
néocolonialistes donc ça pose problème
le 17 nov qui votre réponse le cheikh du
radio n'importe où à très bon prix il ya
aucun risque en la matière alors on va
discuter des objectifs qui ont été fixés
également par le gouvernement le
gouvernement s'est engagé à faire passer
la part du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique de 75 à 50% horizon 2035
franck montaugé est ce que vous y croyez
ou est-ce qu'on va encore repoussé la
date puisqu'il ya déjà eu des dates
repoussées
écoutez moi j'ai moi j'y crois je pense
que cet homme un engagement de leur
représentation nationale qui a été pris
finalement la deux occasions mais la loi
de transition énergétique ou le
l'échéance avait été fixé à 2025 est
donc passé dix ans plus tôt avec la loi
que nous venons de discuter
c'est un engagement extrêmement
important c'est celui aussi de l'état du
gouvernement et même des gouvernements
qui se sont succédés moi je moi j'y
crois il faut qu'on y arrive et qu'on
s'en donne surtout les moyens et c'est
toute la question et c'est toute la
complexité du sujet la décence je suis
beaucoup plus sceptique
j'y crois vraiment je pense que c'est
encore une date butoir qu'on va
repousser
et derrière ce problème de la date et de
l'engagement qui a été pris il ya le
problème de parcours le remplace et tout
le débat qui a lieu en ce moment et des
échanges à peu fermes entre madame
bornes et bien sûr les vies pour une
fois pour une fois je suis beaucoup plus
sévères à l'égard des df que j'ai
toujours soutenu je veux dire non c'est
un débat sur la construction de 6
nouveaux apn avec une addition qui est
pour le moment 2 46 milliards donc il
sera dépassé très largement laver avec
que cette entreprise n'est même pas
capable de faire démarrer flamanville
qui va coûter presque quatre fois plus
cher que le chiffre initial de trois
allemands ils ont plus tard que prévu
je leur en veux beaucoup parce que je
trouve que c'est catastrophique pour la
france pour l'image de la france pour
l'économie française comment voulez-vous
ensuite proposé d'aller vendre les
centrales à l'étranger
si vous n'êtes même pas capable de faire
démarrer votre propre centrale qui
d'après edf ne démarrera pas avant 2023
alors on lance un débat sur les six
nouveaux upr d'abord c'est pas à aider à
vous de décider si un gouvernement et à
nous il y aura un vote là dessus mais je
suis très sévère et j'en veux bien qu'il
faille aller jusqu'au bout de
flamanville on n'a pas le choix sinon ce
serait de l'argent public jeté par la
fenêtre mais je leur en veux beaucoup
on va parler a précisé l'entreprise
heures peut-être sur seulement d'aider
des responsabilités je pense que l'état
n'a aussi il ya une perte de savoir
faire un en fait en réalité qui explique
les déboires notamment de le perdre de
flamanville et ça c'est une
responsabilité collective parce qu'elle
tenait dans une filière comme celle là
il faut la soutenir
il faut l'accompagner y compris dans les
stratégies
de 22,21 l'étranger et ça n'a pas été
suffisamment fait on va parler de
flamanville mais d'abord quand même
revenir sur ce qu'a dit également
elisabeth bande elle dit réfléchir à la
possibilité du 100% renouvelable cela
dans une espèce enfin dans des échanges
un petit peu tendu avec jean bernard
lévy qu'est ce que vous pensez bien de
ces scénarios qui est désormais ouvert
françois lévesque
moi j'ai un point de vue d'économistes
donc j'ai un point de vue obtus ce qui
m'intéresse c'est l'art la compétitivité
et donc je vais regarder les coûts en
termes d'émissions de carbone le
nucléaire ou le renouvelable
il n'y a pas de différence puisque la
production d'électricité à partir donc
d'origine nucléaire ne produit pas de
gaz à effet de serre en revanche à ce
qu'il faut comparer c'est un coût
relatif 100% renouvela plus stockage
donc si aujourd'hui et depuis déjà de
très longues années le prix les coûts
par dont les coûts du solaire et
l'éolien ont considérablement diminué
mais ça ne suffit pas il faudrait aussi
que les coûts du stockage de
l'électricité diminue et si les coûts du
stockage de l'électricité plus le coût
de renouvelables et bien sont plus
compétitifs que le coût de construire de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires et bien
l'économie ce que je suis pour
considérera il faut peut-être faire plus
de stockage et de renouvelables et moins
de nucléaire voire plus du nucléaire si
cette filière ne parvient pas à devenir
compétitive en termes de coût de
production du nouveau nucléaire par
mégawattheure oui charlotte mijeon c'est
rassurant finalement ce 100 %
renouvelable qui pouvait paraître
utopique et fut un temps peut-être que
ça sera même rentable quand on voit le
dépassement renouvelables plus stockage
ça fait un moment qu'il est question du
100% renouvelable il y avait déjà une
étude de l'ademe à ce sujet là il ya
quelques années c'est plutôt rassurant
que le gouvernement envisage enfin
ouvertement 7 enfin vous demanderont de
risa a pris goût à la tante voilà mais
parce qu'il ya une véritable urgence à
prendre en compte cette question
il vient aussi une urgence en terme de
carbone mal à comprendre c'est il y à
une urgence à diminuer les émissions de
carbone dans quelles mesures faut-il s'y
prendre et pourquoi le nucléaire et
diminuer le nucléaire dès lors que la
diminution du nucléaire n'apporte rien à
la diminution des émissions des faits
titulaire ne produit pas sauf que ce
qu'on constate c'est que l'argent qui va
être engloutis dans le rafistolage des
centrales existantes ne servira pas à la
transition énergétique et ne servira pas
réduire nos émissions
donc par ailleurs la question c'est tout
simplement servir à réduire les
émissions à partir du moment où vous
n'êtes pas déjà à 100 % renouvelable en
2030 et bien poursuivre de cinq ans
l'exploitation des parcs centrale
nucléaire qui existe
ça permettra de diminuer la priorité si
je puis me permettre c'est d'abord de
regarder la question de la sûreté la
question des risques
je croyais que c'était le climat mais
eux aussi mais je dire la question s'est
vu dire si on a un accident nucléaire en
france j'espère qu'on pourra reparler de
ça et on parlera j'espère j'espère
surtout qu'on n'aura pas tort mais si je
puis me permettre
il ne faut surtout pas esquivé la
question de la sûreté et la actuellement
on fait comme si de rien n'était et je
suis désolé mais le scénario qui est sur
la table avec la ppe il aboutit à
prolonger la quelle mesure tout annuel
de l'énergie oui la programmation
pluriannuelle l'énergie la beauty a
prolongé la quasi-totalité des réacteurs
existants jusqu'à 50 ans voire au delà
donc ça pose mais si regardez les
calculs ont été faits c'est pas ce qui
fait du portage et les calculs ont été
faits déjà un gage de mannequin et de
prix de fermeture de deux sites
nucléaires 14 au total dont les deux de
fessenheim à des horizons
très très défini auquel aucun pouvoir ne
crois pas voilà mais je crois que je
connais voit que c'est effectivement une
étude l'option est 100% énergies
renouvelables qui mérite vraiment d'être
d'être mené d'être mené sérieusement l
affaire est extrêmement compliqué moi je
suis favorable à ce qu'on accompagne les
énergies renouvelables leur montée en
puissance mais on ne peut pas faire fi
de l'appareil industriel tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui en france ça ça ne me
paraît pas sérieux voilà il ya un sujet
elle ce sujet là si vous me permettez je
terminerai par ça c'est le prix que l'on
accorde à la tonne de carbone je pense
que tout ça est lié y compris par
rapport à la montée en puissance des
énergies renouvelables donc c'est un
aspect aussi du du sujet en ce que l'on
avait vu en 2019 commun combien il était
difficile de de mettre en place une taxe
carbone je dirais efficiente et je
terminerai par un point la construction
de moyens de production d'énergies
renouvelables ne va pas de soi partout
sur le territoire
on rencontre d'énormes difficultés dès
lors qu'on veut faire parfois de la
méthanisation parfois de l'éolienne
parfois du photovoltaïque
voilà il ya aussi ces difficultés là il
faut pas s'il faut pas se le cacher
elles sont pas du même ordre que les
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer par
rapport au nucléaire mais sur le lac
amène donc il faut accompagner tous à la
déclaration de l'étape est donc pour
vous n'est pas sérieux les noms les
passes sérieuse il y a quinze jours
encore madame bornes
la ministre de tutelle de l'énergie
d'une pierre se permettent encore de
rappeler que l'objectif était de réduire
la part du nucléaire à 50% d'ici 2035
mais à peine quinze jours après elle
nous fait la déclaration d'avant-hier
c'est à dire 100 % à bec court après
l'attendait si on avait un chef de
gouvernement il devrait la rappeler à
l'ordre
comme il a rappelé à l'ordre la semaine
dernière monsieur delevoye sur les
retraites c'est pas sérieux qu'un
ministre se permet de dire ça on ne peut
pas je connais me disent que parker ou
ne peut pas se permettre pour un
ministre macarel et que l'émission va
arrêter tout nucléaire
c'est comment est ce qu'on peut se
passer de ça dès que des mets plus là
la zone verte ce discours gentil c'est
gentil comme 10 clos mais c'est pas
sérieux
l'économie a besoin d'électricité à bon
prix on n'est pas 400 carbone sans
carbone est alors le nucléaire ne
produit pas de carbone annoncée ne
produit pas de carbone est important
c'est pour ça que j'étais ravie de ce
que vous avez dit l'auteur dépensons de
l'argent plutôt que les femmes 46
milliards qu'on aura du mal à trouver
pour 6 pers
pour prolonger la durée de vie de nos
centrales dans des conditions de
sécurité surveillé par l'asn
comme tous les états unis l'autorité la
durée de vie de leurs centrales à 50 et
60 ans on peut pour la majorité d'entre
elles
le comble je vous le rappelle c'est que
face au nahd qui doit fermer avaient eu
le droit de prolonger sa durée de vie de
10 ans on est tous les discours ont
chanté this is it existe et mensonger
c'est faux non mais écoutez fessenheim
n'a pas passé sa quatrième visite
décennale dressé sur ses fondements
d'alès venir sur des studios pour
raconter n'importe quoi et qui
fonctionne à l'amendé a été autorisé par
l'asn la ced et l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui contrôle tout et qui a
autorisé face au nahd a prolongé de dix
ans sa durée de vie fait sa quatrième
visite tous les usages qu on ferme
c'est une erreur économique personnelle
n'a pas vu ce serait bien sûr lucie
aussi dire que mon collègue à votre
égard ce que ma série mais tout propos
méritent d'être entendus et développer
moi simplement ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que cette option parce que
c'est une option en réalité du som %
énergies renouvelables elle doit être
investigués elle doit être étudiée et
personnellement je suis assez persuadé à
ce stade sans être un expert un
spécialiste que démonstration sera faite
qu'on ne peut pas comme ça fermez le
robinet du nucléaire voilà sauf sauf à
mettre l'économie de notre pays par
terre donc voilà c'est une difficulté à
laquelle on est tous confrontés chaque
mois là et donc il faut il faut il faut
il faut agir agir en conséquence et de
manière
au prix une réaction charles x passe à
notre avez vous vu la dette d'edf
avez vous vu la dette d'edf amusez-vous
bien et l'emmental 37 milliards d'hommes
et le nom le plus puisque ça oui
quant à lui dire oui mais justement mais
est ce qu'on peut se permettre de
continuer à soutenir a porté à bout de
bras une filière qui nous coûtent de
plus en plus cher et je le répète il ya
la question de la sûreté qui est
primordial je veux dire l'autorité de
sur l'institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire encore publié
dernièrement un avis dans lequel il
remet en question le fait que les cuves
des réacteurs d'une grande partie des
recteurs puisse aller comme ça jusqu'à
50 ans de fonctionnement comme le
prévoit et edf donc on ne peut pas
partir du principe qu'on pourra
prolonger comme ça tous les réacteurs
indéfiniment c'est pas facile vous avez
raison alors je le dis pour l'instar du
cds rudiments oui et bien sûr sont nos
pères à nos pairs avec de très nombreux
déboires on a commencé à en parler tout
à l'heure je voudrais que l'on se penche
et bien sûr le rapport qui a été remis
et le 28 octobre par jean martin folz
qui étrille le p r il a parlé d'une
estimation initiale
irréaliste d'une gouvernance de projet
inappropriée des études insuffisamment
avancé au lancement une perte de
compétences généralisées françois
lévêque comment est ce qu'on a pu en
arriver là
sur un projet industriel français si
important d'une part évidemment et ça
c'est l'argument d'edf mais il a une
validité
c'est pas parce qu'il vient de df qui ne
serait pas bon à savoir il ya eu des
pertes de compétences les pertes de
savoir faire et d'autre part autre
argument avancé d'autres il faut tenir
compte
il y a on a affaire un nouveau type de
réacteur et donc à un prototype a en
quelque sorte
il faut sans doute ajouter à mes yeux un
fait qui est que la france ne construit
pas a perdu un savoir faire sur les
grands projets en général c'est pas
simplement le nucléaire les anglais et
edf va construire une nouvelle centrale
nucléaire à nos pairs à inkhil brut on
peut avoir des craintes que
cette le chantier ne respecte pas son
budget et ne respecte pas son calendrier
pourquoi parce que la dernière le
dernier grand projet construit au
royaume uni c'est un stade olympique il
ya une différence entre conduire un
chantier avec des milliers de personnes
avec plein de savoir faire différent
avec des génies civilistes hors pair
donc les coréens le savent le faire les
chinois savent le faire les français ont
un peu perdu la main pour les grands
chantiers qui soient nucléaires ou
canular il faut peut-être rappeler que
le programme nucléaire français s'est
étalée sur une quinzaine d'années à
peine il a été réalisé en une période
très très très très réduite
effectivement après la question de
l'entretien des compétences y compris en
matière de gouvernance de grands projets
se pose donc voilà je pense que ce sujet
il faut vraiment le prendre au sérieux
que l'état et edf se donne les moyens de
retrouver cette compétence de
gouvernance de grands projets
industriels
charlotte mais je vais vous faire rire
les gens mais je voudrais juste qu'on
écoute ce matin jean bernard lévy parce
que lors de cette audition il a été
questionné sur le père de flamanville on
l'écouté fiancée de votre réaction
nous devons désormais démontrer la
possibilité de construire des opm à des
coûts raisonnables avec une meilleure
maîtrise industrielle
j'ai donc l'intention d'ici au mois de
décembre de présenter un plan d'action
pour retrouver le niveau de qualité
industrielle que nous aurions toujours
dû conserver et nous devons probablement
nous appuyer davantage aussi sur des
organismes de formation professionnelle
l'un des points souligné de façon très
forte par le rapport de jean martin folz
est par exemple la pénurie de soudeur
qualifié en france pénurie de soudeur
qualifié en france on a senti quand même
que jean-bernard la vie de ton est plus
tenter plutôt de défendre à son notaire
ce matin devant les sénateurs et là
alors qu'il avait été beaucoup plus
critique à l'égard est bien de ce projet
en disant que edf n'avait pas su
maintenir le niveau de qualité
industrielle au niveau exigé exigé par
l'industrie n'est clair ce les propos
qu'il a eu il ya quelques jours
j'arrête mais j'en mets et que vous
écoutez moi elle ce sur quoi je voudrais
revenir c'est que si autant de problèmes
sur ce réacteur
la question c
et aussi les malfaçons en série qui se
sont succédé que ce soit sur le béton
que ce soit sur la cuve que ce soit sur
les soudures avec des problèmes à tous
les niveaux à tous les niveaux que ce
soit en usine que ce soit pour la
surveillance des prestataires que ce
soit sur les contrôles sur le terrain
donc à partir de là à penser qu'on va
retrouver une qualité une compétence et
bien une perte de très très très loin et
il ya quand même un sujet très sérieux
par rapport à ça au delà de la capacité
de la filière à se ressaisir
c'est la sûreté d'un réacteur qui
auraient été produits dans de telles
conditions avec autant de malfaçons et
je suis sûr qu'on va finir par en
découvrir encore d'autres on n'en finit
pas de découvrir c'est quasiment tous
les six mois une nouvelle malfaçons sur
le chantier de l'opn donc ça ça pose
vraiment soucis à dessein ce matin je
suis triste je suis triste de cet échec
industriel de la construction de
flamanville ont commencé quatre ans
après flamanville la construction des
deux opère en chine qui en est un des
deux réacteurs est en marche et l'autre
va l'être d'ici d'ici quelques mois on
réussit mais c'est vrai qu'il en crise
beaucoup ils construisent énormément
quelles conséquences de la guerre m
c'est donc des tunnels
c'est un continent est un pays en pleine
activité économique et je dirais qu'ils
ont la main ils n'ont pas perdu la main
et c'est triste de voir à quel point on
est arrivé donc je reviens pas sur ce
que j'ai dit au début je veux un petit
peu à notre ce qui était notre fleuron
qu'était edf on va parler d'un dernier
sujet sujet qui est vraiment connecté à
l'actualité 1 c'est la sécurité la
sûreté des centrales nucléaires alors
qu'il y avait eu et bien ce séisme qui
s'est fait sentir prêt de deux centrales
lundi c'est important d'autant que sur
les 19 centrales françaises cinq sont en
zone sismique on va regarder une carte à
regarder il ya fessenheim dans le
haut-rhin bugey dans l'ain sont aussi
concernés tricastin dans la drôme cruas
enfin dont on a beaucoup parlé lundi et
saint-alban dans l'isère justement
alexandre pousse à vous êtes avec l'un
des sénateurs concernés vous êtes avec
guillaume gontard qui est sénateur
écologiste de l'isère s'est envolé
xandre et oui comme gontard quart
d'heure votre département l'isère il ya
une
centrale à risques la centrale de
saint-alban quel est concrètement le
risque de cette centrale le risque est
multiple déjà c'est une centrale qui
était pas très bien pas très bien cotés
en matière en matière de risques sur il
ya une dizaine d'années les choses se
sont se sont bien bien amélioré mais on
voit là avec le séisme qui a eu lieu et
c'est une centrale qui a été a été conçu
sur un risque sismique de 5,5
on voit que sur ce qui s'est passé si
l'épicentre avait été sous la centrale
de cruas j'ose pas imaginer ce qui
aurait pu scorer pu se passer
donc on voit bien qu'on a encore des des
choses à améliorer en matière en matière
de risques on a le rhône qui est pas
loin la question de l'eau on a vu aussi
la pollution liées justement
refroidissement refroidissement des
centrales récemment on voit aussi la
quantité d'eau qui est qui est
nécessaire aussi pour ce refroidissement
de ses centrales et donc des vraies
problématiques dans l'avenir avec le
réchauffement avec le réchauffement
climatique donc globalement on voit que
cette énergie nucléaire n'est absolument
pas une énergie sûre et qu'il faut y
réfléchir réfléchir à l'avenir que le
seul avantage de cette énergie c'était
son gré son coup et on voit bien que ce
n'est plus un avantage au contraire
c'est cette c'est une des énergies qui
devient l'énergie là la plus chère que
les français risquent de payer deux fois
à la fois à travers leurs factures
d'électricité mais aussi à travers leurs
impôts puisque on se dirige vers une
nationalisation
au passage on nationalise toujours ce
qui ce qui ne ne rapporte pas ne
rapporte pas d'argent et puis on va
privatiser ce qui ce qui est en rapport
donc pour vous la conséquence c'est que
par exemple ses centrales à risque du
rhône dans la vallée du rhône il faut
les fermer
je suis complètement réaliste on peut
pas les fermer du jour au lendemain donc
bien sûr qu'il faut travailler sur la
sécurité mais il faut aussi se poser des
questions sur l'avenir et sur notre
dépendance sur notre dépendance
énergétique jeu elisabeth borgne a fait
une annonce récente qui me paraît plus
qu intéressante puisqu'elle a répondu je
dirais sèchement au président d'edf en
lui disant qu'il fallait réellement
travailler sur du 100% renouvelable et
je pense que ça c'est important puisque
l'argent de la recherche qu'on met
actuellement sur le nucléaire il me
semble qu'il faut que très vite on le
dirige sur sur les les énergies
renouvelables donc avant cette
réorientation il faut
ray élever le niveau de sécurité de
cette bien sûr qu'il faudrait élever le
niveau de sécurité
on voit que pour remettre en conformité
pour relancer la trentaine de réacteurs
nucléaires
c'est 100 milliards d'euros sur dix ans
10 milliards par an donc on voit que
c'est des sommes colossales et donc je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse continuer dans
cette dans cette direction encore une
fois il faut être fait réaliste c'est
une je dirais une énergie du passé il
faut maintenant passer à l'avenir sur
des énergies renouvelables qui seront
moins coûteuse et bien sûr bénéfique
pour l'environnement
très bien donc la france n'a peut-être
pas les moyens de la sécurité de ses
centrales nucléaires
merci beaucoup du montana vous répondez
vite ça absolument les moyens de sa
sûreté nucléaire ça les vacances je
pense qu'il faut être chanceux déclaré
être chanceux d'être en france d'avoir
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire la plus
solide la plus compétente doté de la
plus grande autorité un doté de
ressources suffisantes et donc aux dans
le monde entier c'est l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire française et l'autorité
de sûreté américaine qui sont des
exemples
donc moi je me réjouis en tant que
citoyens de pouvoir faire confiance dans
une autorité je sais que je peux lui
faire confiance parce que elle est
indépendante et s'il faut fermer des
centrales pour des raisons de sûreté
elle autorise t elle le fera elle est
indépendante elle est compétente ce qui
n'est pas le cas
toujours ailleurs et donc moi ma crainte
sur les centrales nucléaires et sur des
risques du clair c'est les centrales en
ukraine où il ya des centrales nucléaire
de type tchernobyl c'est les centrales
au pakistan mais ne venait pas le faire
peur aux gens sur le risque nucléaire en
france alors qu'on a des gens
extrêmement sérieux extrêmement
compétents y compris au sein d'edf qui
assure la sûreté des centrales qui
existe à la demi-journée parfaire leur
aux gens je voudrais réagir quand même
sur ce que vous avez dit là sur
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui est
extrêmement puissante
l'autorité sur nucléaire est certes
indépendante
elle a certes des gens très compétents
mais moi ce que j'observe c'est la
réalité des faits c'est à dire que juste
après la tempête de 99
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire avait
demandé à m
afin de s'assurer que la digue du
tricastin tiendrait bien un séisme et il
a fallu des années et des années il a
fallu l'accident de fukushima il a fallu
d'énièmes relance pour qu'enfin en 2015
edf consentent à vérifier vraiment si
cette dictée aux séismes et enfin
réaliser des carottages quelques années
après et heureusement que ça a été levé
parce que ce n'est quand même pas très
loin du tricastin ou humour se fait
grandement de celle que ça a pris les
années et des années que ça a pris du
temps pour que l'asn impose sur
flamanville de refaire des soudures y
compris des sous du comment il ya les
habiletés sap
ça a pris quelques mois donc ce qui a pu
se passer en 1990
l'autorité de sûreté aussi bien
évidemment elle progresse et elle a
progressé par les pouvoirs qui lui ont
été notamment de sanctions qui lui ont
été dévolues mais je vous dise après
quand même énormément donné c'était en
1990 et a fait pas en 1990 après la
tempête de 80 ans après la tempête de 99
il y a une je ne sais combien de relance
de l'asn demi heure elle seule pour
demander à ce que la vulnérabilité aux
séismes de cette digue soit testé et il
a fallu des années et des années c'est
seulement en 2010 est que les travaux -
thé réalisons plus d'une quinzaine
d'années entre les travaux et la demande
vous explorez la tempête de 99 a
provoqué aucun risque mais c'est rare
mais là maintenant sur ie vous n'êtes
pas sérieuse la star est de 99 mètres il
a provoqué aucune menace dans aucune
sous trains arrêtés et on va rien sur
l'inondation de la tempête dormir de
choses sérieuses fukushima je pense que
les leçons de fukushima ont été bien
prise en compte par l'ensemble du monde
de nucléaire en france
et c'est vrai que c'est ensuite qu'on a
révélé mais le réservoir des risques oui
et que notamment le le le le sénateur
écologiste a commis une erreur
ahahah le critère à partir duquel on
doit réviser c'est pas le critère de
construction déconstruction de l'eau
centrales sont prêtes à répondre des
séismes beaucoup plus important que
celui qu'on a connu à montélimar ce qu
il a cité la le
5,5 at il dit c'est uniquement quand un
séisme
date à partir duquel l'asn qui a
effectivement un rôle important à jouer
peut se permettre de dire je veux une
enquête je veux que vérifier
je veux que vous stockez pied une
centrale et c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour cruas à la dessus de la demande à
la sncf à stopper crasse tricastin a
jugé que c'était pas pour le moment de
se faire mais demandera peut-être un
complément de requêtes
mais c'est pas le critère à partir
duquel on doit construire les grilles
nos centrales sont fait pour supporter
des séismes autrement plus important un
peu des petites tempêtes à je suis
désolé à venir on découvre fréquemment
des anomalies de non tenue au séisme sur
le parc nucléaire français c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
des anomalies qui sont dus à des
problèmes de conception qui n'avait pas
été observée dès le début ou qui sont
dus à des gens bien autorités de santé
ni où il est de détecter d'inspecter de
découvrir des anomalies et des anomalies
c'est aussi le job de des inspecteurs
d'edf et ils on découvre et donc ils
font leur job
évidemment qu'il ya des anomalies oui je
sais ce que je veux dire aussi c'est
qu'il ya des anomalies de non tenue au
séisme qui résulte du mauvais entretien
des équipements parce qu edf a fait le
choix de la rentabilité de privilégier
ceux dits produits plutôt que la
maintenance et ça ce sont les
travailleurs du nucléaire eux mêmes qui
nous en avertisse qui a manqué non plus
de maintenance préventive sur certains
équipements et quand par exemple vous
avez des stations de pompage dont les
tuyauteries sont tellement corrodé
qu'elle pourrait rompre en cas de séisme
ça a été observée vous trouverez ça sur
le site de l'asm ça concernait cru à ces
gens et bien là il ya quand même un
problème mais vous ne pouvez pas dire qu
edf prévoit tout le mot de la fin pour
franck montaugé center merci vous prenez
la parole
non je pense que vraiment il faut se
donner les moyens de réussir le passage
aux 52% que ça va ça va être déterminant
pour pau pour la suite et le contexte
général et énergétique français je pense
qu'il faut continuer à accompagner les
énergies
renouvelables ça pose de la question
entre autres la taxe carbone
il ne faut pas oublier les enjeux
sociaux de cette affaire-là edf ces deux
cents 200 mille personnes donc
directement ou indirectement et il faut
aussi tenir compte de la situation d'edf
et je me réjouis si vous me permettez
que le conseil constitutionnel ait pris
une position par rapport à l'article 62
de la loi énergie climat
il a paris il a permis que les
obligations de vente d'edf aux autres
acteurs du marché de l'énergie puissent
faire l'objet d'adaptations au niveau
des tarifs
voilà pour ne pas que edf finances à son
corps défendant
finalement le subventionné qui total qui
leclerc qui exercent et qui vainquit
vente de l'énergie et est en fait voilà
dans ce contexte là je pense qu'il n'est
absolument pas opportun de mettre en
oeuvre la le projet et recule encore là
il faut que edf reste intégré je suis
pas sûr je suis pas sûr que ce soit un
autre débat je pense qu'il ya aussi
entre ce projet et la problématique qui
nous coûtaient de ce projet merci
beaucoup pour cette synthèse merci à
tous les cadres d'avoir participé à ce
débat on va passer au deuxième thème de
cette émission le malaise et la
précarité étudiante ce sont des sujets
qui vont d'ailleurs faire l'objet de
plusieurs questions au gouvernement tout
à l'heure dans l'hémicycle vous voyez
que les gens commencent à arriver nous
sommes seulement à une demi heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
dans la salle des conférences qui jouxte
l'hémicycle après l'immolation par le
feu d'un étudiant la semaine dernière
plusieurs manifestations contre la
précarité est organisée hier certaines
ont dérapé récit de jérôme rabier des
manifestations dans toute la france et à
paris hier
une colère qui déborde devant le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
sous le poids des manifestants les
grilles cède les sens pendant quelques
instants les slogans résonné sous les
fenêtres de la ministre frédéric vidal
des organisations syndicales étudiantes
avaient appelé à des rassemblements dans
toute la france pour dénoncer la
précarité étudiante après l'immolation
par le feu d'un étudiant lyonnais
vendredi sur les lieux du drame
un rassemblement s'est tenu et quelques
mots de la lettre laissée par l'étudiant
ont été lus par des membres de son
syndicat
malgré ces mots de l'étudiant qui a
choisi de réaliser ce geste devant le
crous organismes qui avaient cessé de
lui verser sa bourse universitaire pour
le gouvernement il ne faut pas sûr
interpréter cet acte je pense pas qu'on
puisse exclure un acte politique
on comprend bien que des revendications
il ya des difficultés ce que je trouve
dangereux c'est que dans notre
démocratie
certains puisque hull certains militants
politiques se servent de cet événement
le récupère des mots que dénoncent
certains sénateurs qui parle d'un déni
du gouvernement voit ça montre bien tout
le décalage qui a entre ce gouvernement
et ce que vit la population au quotidien
grande misère et estudiantine qui dure
qui dure depuis longtemps et aujourd'hui
elles provoquent des drames personnels
qui sont qui sont terribles les
sénateurs qui compte demander des
réponses au gouvernement lors des
questions d'actualité mais surtout des
mesures pour lutter contre la précarité
étudiante et on va parler de ce sujet un
brûlant de la précarité étudiante avec
deux invités sur ce plateau laure darcos
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice l air de
l'essonne membre de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation également sur
ce plateau jérôme durain bonjour
sénateur socialiste de saône et loire
tout d'abord que vous inspire et bien
l'ampleur la violence du mouvement de
contestation qui lie à 8 hier
dégradations dans les facs françois
hollande qui n'a pas pu faire sa
conférence hier à lille l'éruption
également dans le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur lors darcos
écoutez d'abord j'oserais dire que je me
mets à la place des parents de ce jeune
homme c'est un drame épouvantable et en
arriver là à ce s'immoler par le feu je
pense qu'en effet on doit se poser des
questions et je pense que de toute façon
les autorités et le gouvernement et nous
mêmes parlementaires ne pourront pas
passer à côté non var
en effet sur la précarité après j'ai
peut-être vous êtes vous choqué mais en
même temps ça m'est insupportable et de
la récupération politique à ce point ça
ne devrait pas échapper que les
élections étudiantes sont 25 26 et 27
novembre prochain et que cet acte est
récupéré par une frange quand même
extrêmement virulente des étudiants et
au moment où on sent une atmosphère
quand même extrêmement tendue partout
que ce soit avec la grève du 5 qui
s'annonce et et d'autres occasions
nettes est aussi un acte politique
c'était un étudiant syndiqués de
solidaires fin qui l'a revendiquée aussi
comme un acteur politique oui mais moi
je vois plutôt surtout un acte désespéré
faire j'espère qu'en effet il ne s'est
pas sacrifier que pour ça ou alors sinon
ça veut dire que définitivement nous
avons manqué entièrement en tout cas
notre éducation
mais je voudrais vraiment dire que a
notamment aux étudiants qui vont se
faire manipuler active dans les jours
qui viennent avec les âges et qui se
propage partout dans les facs
attention attention à ne pas à faire la
différence entre cet acte qui montrent
en effet une précarité importantes qui
va falloir résoudre et une récupération
politique d'une autre ampleur un mot
d'abord sur est bien le mouvement cette
violence et puis récupération politique
dit laure darcos
jérôme durain je crois effectivement
tous sont tous marqués par par le fai
qui a provoqué ces réactions la
situation désespérée de deux garçons qui
qui choisi de s'immoler pour porter une
détresse après chacun la qualifiera une
détresse ça c'est insupportable et je
pense qu'une fois une partie de la
jeunesse qui qui est une partie des
étudiants que s'il ya une telle
résonance c'est quand même marque ans ça
veut dire qu'il ya un fait social il ya
un fait générateur qui est une situation
individuelle
et puis qui rencontre un fait social il
importe de précarité on va y revenir et
on peut pas isoler la jeunesse du reste
de la société
cette société française d'aujourd'hui
elle porte en elle une colère une forme
de violence on l'a vu
gilet jaune il ya un an ça dure on le
voit dans beaucoup d'expression on a un
débat dont on sort à peine qui a été
assez dur sur les communautés dans ce
pays la jeunesse prend le relais il ya
quelque chose qui est un petit peu
cassée dans la concorde républicaine et
je crois que notre première
responsabilité c'est dire qu'en
démocratie c'est pas en cassant qu'on
fait aboutir des revendications c'est en
essayant de se parler et porter les
sujets au fond la violence n'est pas une
solution là dessus vous êtes tous les
deux d'accord on va en venir
effectivement la question de la
précarité étudiante est d'abord louderai
vous faire entendre deux témoignages
nous nous étions rendu il ya quelques
semaines à la fac de rennes
nous avions interrogé des étudiants en
situation de précarité et qui se
rendaient dans une épicerie solidaire
pour se nourrir et coûté tellement
demandé à mes parents parce qu'ils ont
du mal déjà ils ont du mal a déjà eu
parfois je vende un peu les deux bouts
du coup si en plus leur demander de
l'aide ça serait difficile vraiment pour
eux du coup bah je pense que s'il y
avait pas de crise très grave suite je
serai obligé de
en fait interrompre les études et le
travail il ya vraiment des gens pour qui
ça certain défend on a des échos en
disant nous on ouvre à 18 heures les
gens disent c'est la première fois que
je mange de la journée quoi forcément on
ne peut pas étudier correctement le vin
très vite comme ça quoi premier repas de
la journée après 18h laure darcos c'est
quand même très chaud quand on voit mal
comment réussir des études dans de
telles conditions
oui pierre vraiment je ne sais pas
pourquoi on en est arrivé là
si on reprend ce jeune homme il avait
redoublé trois fois c'est la troisième
fois qu'il passait sa deuxième année
oui comment est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu
dans l'encadrement de cette faculté
quelqu'un qui lui disent peut-être que
ce n'est pas forcément ta voix il faut
que tu fasses autre chose il aurait
paraît-il refuser un logement que le
cruise lui avait proposé et surtout de
continuer à avoir des aides spécifiques
en fait après les bourses puisque
évidemment au bout d'un moment les
bourses ne sont plus attribués aussi
appelé redoublement et c'est sur les
jobs pour étudiants c'est vrai que on en
a souvent parlé même au sein la
commission des affaires culturelles
ouvrir par exemple les bibliothèques les
dimanches pour que ça soit les étudiants
qui puisse les surveiller et et gagner
de l'argent
on a l'impression qu'en effet notre
société n'essaye pas de permettre alors
je dis pas que c'est la panacée mais moi
je les fais de faire des salons
d'hôtesses les week-ends pour me payer
mes études et parra et j'habitais plus
chez mes parents et je pense qu
honnêtement on n'adapte pas cette
société à nos jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent en même temps travailler en
même temps pour certains faire défaire
des job parce qu'il ne peut pas faire
autrement
certains ont des jobs mais ne s'en
sortent pas pour autant et puis surtout
et puis surtout les logements sont
extrêmement chères aujourd'hui on sait
très bien que certains n'osent pas aller
dans certaines villes dans certaines
académies alors que les filières serait
peut-être beaucoup plus intéressante
pour eux par manque de moyens parce que
les parents n'ont pas les moyens de leur
payer un studio ou une chambre une
chambre étudiante est d'ailleurs très
bien regarder ces chiffres qui ont été
sortis par l'unef
en août 2000
19 sur la hausse du coût de la vie
étudiante et bien ça a été plus 2,83
pour ça en 2019 c'est quand même
beaucoup plus élevée que l'inflation est
ce que c'est normal que le coût de la
vie des étudiants augmente plus vite que
pour le reste de la population jérôme
durain non non c'est un sujet qui est
devant nous cette précarité étudiante
elle est insupportable
elle n'est pas isolée il ya 20% des
français qui font leurs courses à un
euro près les étudiants c'est leur
enfant dans les facultés dans les
universités la renforce en plus c'est
l'éclaté c'est quand même l'ascenseur
social qui est qui est en panne et la
détresse le cri de colère qui s'est
exprimée dans ce pays l'année dernière
et qui continue de deux manières sourde
de se faire entendre
il dit ça et les étudiants ce sont les
enfants des gilet jaune d'une certaine
manière pas que mais c'est les classes
moyennes c'est les gens dont les revenus
sont très très passé et ce qui se
manifeste dans la société française
c'est une forme de colère et de
sentiment que certains s'en sortent et
sont aspirés vers le haut alors qu'une
grande partie de la société qui qui
plongent donc il ya un sujet de service
public
ça se passe mal dans l'hôpital public ça
se passe mal à l'université il ya un
sujet évidemment de pouvoir d'achat
il ya un sujet d'accompagnement des
étudiants cette perspective est
peut-être que un des messages que
qu'exprime la jeunesse
et les étudiants et les manifestations
spontanées ou pas con qu'on observe
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est quelles sont
vos perspectives quels sont nos
perspectives comment on s'insère comment
en vie et effectivement c'est pas normal
que des étudiants ne puissent ni
travailler ni étudié et en être
finalement réduit à au désespoir alors
par quoi ça ce que vous jugez les
réponses du gouvernement à la hauteur
dans ce contexte tout à l'heure et bien
la porte parole du gouvernement si bête
ndiaye a fait valoir et bien que le
gouvernement avait fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
hausses des frais de scolarité qui elle
avait supprimé par le régime étudiant
sécurité sociale etc qui n'avait pas été
absent de cette question qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
non je honnêtement ça serait très malade
et de ma part de dire que en effet ce
gouvernement n'a pas n'a pas essayé de
faire des gestes des gestes importants
mais comme vous dites le décalage en
fait avec le niveau de vie et c'est
tellement c'est tellement accentué que
je pense que de toute façon nos
étudiants ne s'y retrouvent pas ce n'est
pas suffisant c'est pas suffisant
et quand on étudie le budget chaque
année notamment l'enseignement supérieur
on ne parle même pas des conditions de
travail dans des bâtiments totalement
insalubre
les blues les gouvernements et j'allais
dire les gouvernements successifs là
dessus je mets très honnêtement on se
met tous dans le même temps depuis 20
ans il travaille dans des conditions
épouvantables
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens chaque
année d'avoir un budget sanctuariser
pour réaménager les bâtiments et essayer
de faire en sorte qu'ils travaillent
dans de bonnes conditions
donc je pense que je suis plutôt une
femme brune partisans de parcours super
participe d'ailleurs à essayer de gagner
quelques bourses encourager les jeunes
justement à pouvoir aller dans des
endroits où ça soit peut-être plus
facile pour eux de vivre enfin et de et
de pouvoir se loger mais en effet en
tout cas ce geste absolument dramatique
montre qu'il ya encore beaucoup à faire
et que c'est à mon avis responsabilité
de tous il ya beaucoup à faire
je pense que vous allez être plus sévère
à l'égard du gouvernement jérôme durain
je sais pas si c'est intéressant que je
ne sois en tout cas je veux dire que ce
qui est dramatique c'est que le
quinquennat précédent n'a pas été avare
de mesures va il y avait 35 % de délai
le d'étudiants boursiers à l'issue du
mais vous avez entendu que les étudiants
ne les entendent pas quand il est tout à
fait hier hollande à sa fille c'est bien
ça
et bien si c'est que c'est que ce qui a
été fait n'a pas été vu c'était sans
doute pas suffisant il faut il faut en
tirer le constable puisque c'est la
réalité
mais il ya des choses qui ont été faites
et les choses qui ont été faites il cet
effort sur les bourses notamment pour
les étudiants des classes moyennes ya eu
des allocations nouvelle pour ceux qui
étaient qui avait besoin d'une autonomie
particulière on a indexé les bourses sur
l'inflation
un dixième mois de bourse sauf que ça ne
suffit pas moi ce que je crains dans la
période c'est que on soient tous
renvoyés dos à dos et qui espèce de
fracture générationnelle
on voit bien que les communautés dans ce
pays enfin il ya une espèce
d'affirmation du fai domino terre on est
chacun différent de tous les autres et
on veut le faire savoir et on veut s'en
prendre à tous les autres donc il faut
pas qu'on perde nos jeunes nos étudiants
et que et finalement s'érige une
barrière entre une partie de la société
les autres il ya un phénomène qui existe
en ce moment qui est ok boomer attention
à ce qu'on n'est pas cette césure parce
que on doit se parler on doit écouter
ces jeunes leur donner des perspectives
sans doute des moyens il faut faire plus
tous edwards le mot de la fin
dans l'alcool je pense qu'ils doivent
aussi suis entièrement d'accord est ce
que vous avez dit et je pense qu'en même
temps il en va aussi de notre démocratie
que les diversités restent des lieux
ouverts au dialogue
je dois dire qu'il ya eu françois
hollande hier c'est vrai que moi même
j'étais bouleversée il ya eu
s'il ya un magazine ce qui il ya
quelques semaines je sais qu également
un rabbin n'a pas pu aller faire un
colloque également dans une autre phase
l'université de reste un lieu de débat
sané c'est un lieu de débat et je pense
que les étudiants ont tout à gagner à
essayer de continuer à être un vraiment
un lieu de dialogue
c'est notre génération montante et
j'espère que en effet eux mêmes vont
être moins vigilant là dessus bien merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette discussion on poursuit
sur le même sujet avec vous ou alexandre
pissas puisque vous êtes avec jacques
grosperrin sénateurs l'est républicain
il était le rapporteur de la dernière
loi sur l'orientation et la réussite des
étudiants
et oui jacques grosperrin vous étiez le
rapporteur de la fameuse loi parcours
sup
le gouvernement a fait la sélection à
l'université mais ce qu'il n'a pas
oublié la question sociale le niveau de
vie des étudiants
c'est évident et je crois que le
tragique événement qui est arrivé à lyon
2 le montrent il fallait sortir d'apb le
scandale apb puis maintenant ce cette
horreur je pense vraiment très fort à ce
jeune homme et à sa famille montrent que
véritablement il fallait aussi
accompagné réfléchir sur la vie
d'étudiant
on se rend compte à ce jour que
l'ascenseur social ne fonctionne plus on
se rend compte à ce jour qu'il ya
beaucoup d'étudiants qui justement sont
entre ceux qui n'ont pas la possibilité
de faire des études et ceux qui ont la
chance avec des parents qui peuvent les
aider
il ya une précarité qui est certaine qui
est trop important je crois qu un pays
civilisé comme nul autre ne peut pas
accepter cela donc vous comprenez cette
colère des étudiants qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui parfois dans la violence
ouais je ne l'excusé pas mais je la
comprends moi j'ai fait ma thèse à lyon
2 j'ai vu ce qu'il en était je crois que
c'est un étudiant qui vient de
saint-etienne il ya coût du logement qui
est très important sur yon comme dans
d'autres grandes villes
l université actuellement est le
réceptacle réceptacle pardon de ceux qui
justement n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent et
sont en situation vraiment très
difficile il faut absolument que le
gouvernement il faut que le premier
ministre il faut que le président de la
république prenne en compte et regarde
véritablement ce qui se passe dans une
université
donc concrètement vous demander de
l'argent sur la table des moyens
nouveaux pour le les étudiants un grand
plan un grand plan sur l'université un
grand plan sur le logement en gros plan
sur la condition étudiante
lorsqu'on voit qu'il ya des associations
d'étudiants qui se met en place pour
permettre à ces jeunes justement de
pouvoir manger normalement parce qu'il y
en a qui ne mangent pas normalement il a
qui se chauffent pas y en a qui y
habitent même dans leur voiture dans
leur voiture j'en ai vu j'en connais
donc il faut que l'état il faut que le
gouvernement réfléchisse et fasse un
grand plan alors je ne sais pas si c'est
un grenelle de l'énergie cité mais en
tout cas il faut véritablement réfléchir
et tout de suite répondre pas simplement
avec une augmentation à la marge de
débourser je crois que c'est parce cela
c'est réfléchir sur les seuils et c'est
réfléchir sur ce qu'on veut ce que la
france un grand pays veut pour ces
étudiants donc pour l'instant le
gouvernement ne prend pas le dossier à
la hauteur le gouvernement pour
l'instant je crois qu'il faut qu'il
fasse attention parce qu'au delà de ce
tragique accident
il ya une vraie une vraie volonté des
étudiants pour dire stop
stopar ce qui se passe top à notre
précarité nous voulons y veulent être
entendus ils veulent comment vos données
puissent faire des études
c'est quand même la france de demain je
crois qu'il faut absolument que le
gouvernement réfléchisse et fasse des
propositions plus forte par rapport à ça
très bien merci beaucoup aux jeunes
européens d'avoir réagi
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction alors que nous sommes
à une dizaine de minutes du début des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tout à l'heure on a d'ailleurs vu
arriver le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner mais aussi jean paul
delevoye haut-commissaire au retraité
jeu le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau pour parler des grands hommes
qui ont marqué cette séance jean xavier
arnaud vous est conseillé à tilder
agence de communication politique et on
va tout d'abord par les vingt-sept
question du malaise étudiants
cette contestation étudiante qui prend
de l'ampleur après bien cette immolation
la semaine dernière d'un étudiant à lyon
en cet automne social c'est un nouveau
front qui s'ouvre face au gouvernement
selon vous alors c'est un nouveau front
mais qui n'est pas qu'on ne voit pas
apparaître pour la première fois depuis
le début du quinquennat
je rappelle que film que le quinquennat
a commencé avec le sujet de parcours sup
c'est différent mais qui est également
un sujet qui touche à l'université aux
étudiants et surtout sur le thème de la
précarité
on avait également eu dans l'est dans
les premiers mois du mandat des manuels
macron la question des apl
j'avais créé énormément d'émotion au
sein de la classe politique mais
également de la communauté étudiante et
qui déjà laissé les ses vents laissé
entrevoir un malaise sur ce sujet de la
qualité de vie et du niveau de vie des
étudiants dans le pays vous dites
nouveau front en effet nouveaux fronts
on sait très bien et tous les
gouvernements le savent que là la
tension au sein de la communauté
étudiante est un est un danger politique
majeure c'est à fortiori un danger
politique quand ce gouvernement
s'apprête à faire face le 5 décembre à
une grève massive
quand on voit dans la presse et dans
l'est dans le pays
le malaise au sein du monde de la santé
de en particulier s'ajoutent à ça
le mât les étudiants c'est vrai qu'on a
le sentiment en ce en cette mi mi
novembre que tous les ingrédients se
réunissent petit à petit pour une femme
est tout à fait explosive et vous verrez
on va devoir trouver les solutions pour
déminer au moins certains de ses
courriels pénicaud qui arrivait
également salle des conférences la
ministre du travail
c'est une séquence aussi qui a été
marquée par la violence est-ce que
depuis la crise des légers les jaunes et
la violence n'est pas devenu un mode de
revendication la plongeant exister ou
bien peut-être que ça a été encore
accrue par les mouvements de l'année
dernière ça a existé il ya plusieurs
décennies
est-ce que depuis depuis justement un
stand d'années on avait l'habitude d'une
telle violence dans les revendications
diverses et variées au sein du pays non
c'est en effet une habitude qu'on avait
qu on avait perdu on est bienvenue la
séquence des des émeutes en banlieues en
2005 mais sur un sujet tout à fait
différent là on est sur les
revendications pour les jeunes et pour
les jeunes qui sont à la fois sociales
économiques pour les étudiants se sont
également ce type de revendications et
en effet que ce soit
soit les jets jaune mais que ce soit
également la la la conférence de
françois hollande hier qui a dû être
annulé justement en raison de la tension
sur le site
a lille on est en effet face à
l'expression de d'opinion beaucoup plus
violente est beaucoup plus dense dans un
climat de tension bien plus fort que ce
nous on avait l'habitude au cours de
cours des décennies
on va également parlé ensemble de la
question des commémorations du 13
novembre puisqu'il devrait y avoir
d'ailleurs un hommage au début de cette
séance mais tout de suite on va
rejoindre la salle des conférences du
sénat
car alexandre vous êtes avec nicole
belloubet la garde des sceaux
oui nicole belloubet quatre ans après
ces attentats du 13 novembre qui ont
frappé la france le peuple français est
encore touchée par ce souvenir du
terrorisme très touché par le souvenir
de ces attentats cela crée à la fois une
fraternité entre tous ceux qui ont vécu
un tel drame
et en même temps une volonté renouvelée
de tout faire pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas et c'est un peu ce que
nous avons ressenti ce matin avec
christophe castaner et laurent nunez à
la fois dans les visages de celles et de
ceux qui ont été les victimes directes
ou indirectes de ces attentats qu'ils ne
deviennent familiers familier de
connaissance de reconnaissance de
douleur partagée mais je vous dis aussi
cela vraiment entre notre volonté de
tout faire pour ça ne se reproduise pas
alors 80 après la menace terroriste est
toujours présente sous une autre forme
witt que l'état fait assez pour gérer
cette menace nous faisons vraiment tout
ce qui est en notre possible à la fois
pour traiter les personnes qui sont des
terroristes ou qui sont en
radicalisation en voie de radicalisation
et qui sont sur notre territoire
et puis vous le savez pour faire en
sorte que les personnes qui sont partis
combattre en syrie ou en irak soit jugé
sur place ou si elle rentre que parce
qu'elles sont judiciariser nous les
incarcérer lyon pour les traiter ensuite
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
ministre de votre réaction avant d'aller
pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre effectivement
nous sommes quatre ans jour pour jour
après l'attentât du bataclan 131 morts
des centaines de blessés et c'est
toujours une journée de commémoration
importante
on constate tout de même qu'elle est
moins présente dans les médias c'est
moins traités médiatiquement ça commence
à citer alors c'est moins traités oui
mais néanmoins ça reste un événement
qu'elle était présent ce matin les
manuels macron twittait vous souvenez
tous où vous étiez quand c'est arrivé et
si l'émotion demeure malgré tout sur cet
événement c'est justement parce que ce
drame appartient à la catégorie est
finalement très réduite de ces moments
où tous nous savions nous étiez où nous
étions pardon est est ce que nous
faisions donc même si de manière assez
naturelle
au bout de quatre ans évidemment la
couverture médiatique n'est pas la même
ça reste un moment pour le pays qui est
générateur d'une émotion extrêmement
forte qui demeure en plus un souvenir
qui est entretenu parce que il ya eu
d'autres attentats depuis ce nom avec
notamment et bien dernière en date à
celui de la préfecture de police de
paris avec bien cette menace toujours
présente et qui en plus évolué dans sa
forme
c'est évidemment également cesser ces
commémorations à chaque fois une
occasion pour pour le pays et pour le
gouvernement en particulier de rappeler
à la fois son intransigeance face au
terrorisme
mais également ce qu'il fait face au
terrorisme j'imagine d'ailleurs 105 en
difficulté que la au cours des questions
il y aura une interpellation du ministre
de l'intérieur pour lui demander à
l'occasion de cet anniversaire
où en est la france en terme de
d'action et contre la lutte également ce
qu'il fait pour les victimes c'est un
moment important aussi pour ses victimes
et d'ailleurs est bien le président de
l'association des victimes du terrorisme
disait ce matin que et bien la france
est plutôt au rendez vous pour le
traitement de ses victimes
oui on voit bien
d'ailleurs à chaque à chacune de ces
commémorations dans sa quatrième
aujourd'hui que le l'état que ce soit
sous françois hollande où ces manuels
macron a réussi à trouver une ligne de
fonctionnement avec les victimes ce qui
est toujours un sujet à la fois
émotionnelle est sensible mais une ligne
tant humaines que dans l'est que dans
les mesures qui est saluée par les
victimes parce que jacky reste celui de
l'unité nationale exact exactement
et c'est vrai qu'on constate réellement
que sur ce point le national n'est pas
rompu que à aucun moment on voit émerger
de la part des victimes
un reproche quant à la manière dont
seraient vous sera traité le sujet il
faut donc reconnaître que chez les
gouvernants successifs il y a eu cette
capacité à traiter le sujet en
adéquation avec les attentes des
victimes merci beaucoup aux gens que
xavier arnaud tout de suite on va
rejoindre la salle des conférences
alexandre vous êtes avec la sénatrice
dominique estrosi sassone qui elle même
a connu de près d'autres attentats oui
dominique estrosi sassone vous êtes élu
de la ville de nice qui a été aussi
frappé par l'attentât de 2016
vous êtes touché personnellement
aujourd'hui par ces commémorations du 13
novembre
je suis touché comme l'ensemble des
français bien évidemment je suis aussi
la niçoise qui pleure aussi 86 victimes
pour l'attentât du 14 juillet est
aujourd'hui bien évidemment comme tous
les français nous pensons très fort à
toutes les victimes et les victimes de
l'attentât de paris bien évidemment aux
centaines de blessés à vie aux familles
meurtries
il faut absolument continuer ce combat
face à l'islam radical qui gangrène
notre pays qui remet en cause nos
libertés notre mode de vie qui remet en
cause tout simplement ce que nous sommes
il y à une guerre a livré et cette
guerre malheureusement elle n'est pas
terminée
justement vous parlez des victimes la
ville de nice à la fin du mois novembre
va organiser le congrès international
des victimes du terrorisme
est ce que l'état fait assez en france
pour accompagner ces victimes ces
dernières années l'état a pris
conscience de la nécessité de
d'accompagner des victimes et leurs
familles
mais je pense que l'on peut faire encore
mieux et c'est la raison pour laquelle
ce congrès dans une ville qui
malheureusement a été meurtri par le
terrorisme et par cette barbarie doit
pouvoir apporter des solutions des
solutions sur le plan psychologique sur
le plan des indemnisations qu'ils ne
sont pas
complètement à la hauteur de ce que les
familles peuvent attendre même si
malheureusement ça ne réparera jamais la
mort d'un proche
et bien évidemment il faut continuer
aussi à développer des outils qui
permettent de mieux lutter contre le
terrorisme et contre l'islam radical
alors l'état islamique a été vaincu en
tout cas territorialement mais la menace
terroriste est toujours présent comment
on fait maintenant pour lutter contre
cette menace alors qu'on a déjà fait
beaucoup de lois
je pense que d'abord il faut prendre
conscience véritablement que nous sommes
en guerre et face à une guerre il faut
un budget de guerre il faut également
que l'état restaure son autorité et pour
cela il faut que l'état véritablement
non seulement bien évidemment soit plus
ferme et soit moins naïf mais aussi
qu'il y ait un véritable réarmement
moral et culturel de nos esprits très
bien merci beaucoup dominique estrosi
sassone et on va tout de suite allé dans
l'hémicycle du sénat avec vous alice
bardot pour le programme des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
alors les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont s'ouvrir avec un
hommage des sénateurs aux victimes du 13
novembre
quatre ans jour pour jour après les
attentats qui ont touché paris et sa
banlieue au programme ensuite il y aura
notamment la précarité des étudiants
avec deux questions sur les bancs de la
gauche
une du sénateur communiste pierre
ouzoulias c'est une autre de la
socialiste maryvonne blondin alors la
nuit a été agitée je le rappelle avec
vers 23 heures
des manifestants qui ont forcé les
grilles du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur
alors la porte parole du gouvernement
comme le secrétaire d'état à l'intérieur
laurent nunes s ou condamné ces
violences même si ce dernier a dit
comprendre l'émotion légitime donc après
la tentative d'immolation d'un jeune
étudiant lyonnais vendredi dernier
alors la cloche a sonné tout de suite le
début des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a t'il en séance je n'en vois point
il est donc adoptée sous les réserves
usage
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues il y a quatre ans le 13
novembre 2015 en plusieurs points de
parier à des terrasses de restaurants et
dans la salle de concert du bataclan
ainsi qu'aux abords du stade de france à
saint-denis était perpétré les attaques
terroristes qui ont fait 130 morts et
350 blessés
nous devons garder en mémoire cette
journée si douloureuse pour notre pays
et nous a renforcés dans notre
détermination à rester résolus et unis
face à la menace terroriste est à
défendre plus que jamais les valeurs de
la république que nous avons en partage
le président david assouline va nous
représenter aux cérémonies
commémoratives qui vont se dérouler
aujourd'hui à paris en ce jour
anniversaire de pensées vont même si le
temps semblait passé vers les victimes
de ces attentats leurs familles et leurs
proches en leur souvenir en leur hommage
je vous invite à observer un court
moment de recueillement
je vous remercie
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et est retransmise sur
public sénat et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect du temps
les respect des uns et des autres et la
parole et à notre collègue mathieu
darnaud pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et vous me permettrez d'y associer mon
collègue de l'ardèche jacques genest
lundi 11 novembre à 11h52 un séisme de
magnitude 5,4 a frappé le département de
l'ardèche
plus généralement la vallée du rhône et
nombre de communes et singulièrement la
commune du teil
nous adressons à se testant toutes nos
pensées et notre soutien à l'ensemble
des personnes qui ont été blessées ou
qui ont connu des dégâts assez
importants
le bilan de ce séisme est aussi lourd
qu'inhabituel dans l'hexagone en effet
environ 300 bâtiments endommagés
une trentaine détruit des établissements
scolaires fermés et certains de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore aujourd'hui
hébergée dans l'urgence dans certains
gymnase de la commune à cette heure
monsieur le premier ministre les
ardéchoises et les ardéchois et j'ai
associé aussi certains collègues drômois
attendent des réponses de la part de
l'état s'agissant tout d'abord des
établissements aidés centrale nucléaire
de cruas et du tricastin
l'institut de la radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire a indiqué ne pas avoir
constaté de dégâts visibles sur les
installations mais continue ses
investigations pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
avez à cette heure des informations
complémentaires
ma seconde question porte sur les
mesures d'urgence et sur la solidarité
nationale que nous appelons de nos voeux
confirmez-vous la prise rapide d'un
décret de catastrophe naturelle et en
attendant le processus d'expertisé et
d'indemnisation des assurances quels
sont les moyens financiers d'urgence que
l'état entend mettre en oeuvre pour
venir en aide aux populations touchées
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur willy de
l'intérieur monsieur christophe castaner
vous avez la parole monsieur lui
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'arnaud j'étais
hier soir à montélimar dans le hameau de
la rouvière et aussi dans la commune du
teil ce que j'ai constaté en particulier
dans le hameau de la rouvière comme dans
la commune du teil était bien au delà
des premières indications qui était
remonté en matière de dégâts sur les
logements au moment où je vous parle je
pense que le chiffre de 800 maisons
directement impactés concernés qui font
l'objet de fissures plus ou moins
importantes sur la seule commune du teil
et la réalité que nous sommes en train
de constater dès hier nous avons procédé
au relogement dans lieu d avant-hier
nous aurons procédé au relogement dans
l'urgence de près de 300 personnes dans
trois sites différents
depuis hier nous travaillons à ce que ce
relogement soit la fois réduits dans le
volume des personnes qui doivent être
relogées par une inspection minutieuse
par les services de pompiers qui ont été
renforcés depuis ce matin par huit
équipes de la direction générale de la
gestion des crises et des catastrophes
naturelles du ministère de l'intérieur
pour qu'elle puisse réhabiliter les
logements après la levée des doutes et
pour les autres nous sommes en train de
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse dès ce
soir dormir dans des conditions plus
satisfaisantes que celles qui ont été
proposées malgré l'accueil de qualité de
très nombreux bénévoles que je veux
saluer dans des gymnases de la commune
du teil il nous faut maintenant regarder
l'avenir réparer l'urgence vous avez
évoqué les écoles publiques et privées
dans la commune du teil vous avez évoqué
les équipements publics vous pourriez
nous pourrions évoquer
les deux églises qui aujourd'hui sont
aussi menacés et l'une d'elles en bord
de la route nationale 112 avec de vrais
risques donc il nous faut nous regarde
et il nous faut nous mobiliser regarder
l'avenir concernant l'urgence et la
catastrophe naturelle avec elisabeth
bornes nous avons fait le choix de faire
en sorte que la commission puisse se
réunir dès la semaine prochaine
et concernant l'ensemble des dispositifs
d'urgence que nous allons mobiliser sous
l'autorité de la ministre en charge des
collectivités locales est en lien avec
olivier dussopt optent pour le ministère
de l'économie finance ou faire en sorte
de répondre présent comme l'a fait le
département dans l'immédiateté et comme
je crois le fera cet après midi le
conseil régional et le président de la
région se rendra cet après midi dans la
commune du teil je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant aux produits dans jean marie
bockel pour le groupe de l'union
centriste la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci le seul président madame la
ministre des armées
ma question porte sur la déclaration du
président de la république affirmant que
l'otan est en état de mort cérébrale si
nul ne conteste sérieusement que le
temps n'est pas bien aujourd'hui
faut-il affirmé d'emblée qu'elle ne s'en
remettra pas qu'il faille une
refondation de la défense européenne et
donc de l'alliance atlantique face à de
nouvelles menaces dans un monde qui a
bien changé depuis la guerre froide
c'est certain les événements récents au
moyen orient l'attitude agressive de la
turquie membre de l'otan
les menaces de désengagement des états
unis les revirements intempestive du
président trump sont la marque d'une
crise profonde
pour autant le coup de gueule justifier
à bien des égards du président de la
république suscite inquiétudes et
interrogations chez nos partenaires
européens de l'otan l'allemagne le
royaume uni les anciens pays du bloc
communiste en général et les pays baltes
particulièrement jusqu'à la commission
européenne or créer un nouveau rapport
de force européens en matière de défense
passe aussi par eux nos partenaires
européens et pour le moment il n'existe
pas ou si peu trop peu même le
nécessaire dialogue avec la russie ne
sera fructueux dans sa 200 sur un
ensemble européen fort quelle
signification
donner à la phrase du président de la
république que madame la ministre celle
d'une petite phrase qui alimentent les
médias mais ne fait en rien évoluer la
situation réelle de l'otan ou est ce au
contraire une offensive diplomatique en
profondeur en vue de réveiller nos
alliés européens
face à l'urgence d'un renouvellement
nécessaire merci la parole pour vous
répondre
madame la ministre des armées à la
florence parly monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur lorsque le
président de la république a évoqué la
mort cérébrale de l'otan cela ne veut
pas dire la mort de l'otan mais cela
veut simplement dire que nul que nul ne
peut ignorer la crise que traverse
l'organisation certes sur un plan
strictement militaire les choses
fonctionnent l'otan est un outil robuste
qui permet de planifier de standardiser
et d'inter opéré mais cela ne doit pas
cacher l'essentiel
il y est en effet un doute sérieux sur
la garantie de sécurité américaine et
partant sur l'article 5
il ya ensuite un questionnement profond
sur la solide et sur la solidarité
pardon alliés quand les turcs attaque ce
précisément qui luttent contre des ch
et il ya enfin vous l'avez dit une
insuffisance criante des efforts de
défense des européens
là où même les européens devraient
constituer leur propre pilier au sein de
l'alliance
donc on ne peut pas se satisfaire de
cette situation
la volonté du président de la république
aujourd'hui c'est d'alerté à la veille
du sommet de londres
l'otan est en effet la pierre angulaire
de la sécurité de la défense européenne
mais elle doit s'adapter profondément le
président s'en est d'ailleurs entretenu
avec le président des états unis avec
lesquels des convergences existent et
ils ont convenu
de se revoir avant le sommet de londres
monsieur le sénateur l'otan a déjà connu
un certain nombre de crises et il ne
faut pas son apitoyer au contraire il
est sain pour une organisation de se
repenser ce que nous proposons c'est
donc de lancer avec les alliés une vraie
réflexion stratégique sur l'avenir de
l'alliance et sur la force de nos
engagements en son sein nous ferons donc
prochainement des suggestions précises à
cet effet monsieur bockel le risque
lorsque l'on tape fort
sans plan alternatif est partagé c'est
toujours celui du coup d'épée dans l'eau
comme le dit le sage pierre vimont
ambassadeur de france emmanuel macron à
100 du temps sur la méthode car ils
aiguisent la critique habituelle sur
l'arrogance française mais il a raison
sur le fond tout le système européen
autant comme union européenne est à bout
de souffle et doit se repenser
stratégiquement on a du pain sur la
planche
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue bernard buigues pour le groupe
de la république en marche vers la
parole pour deux minutes
merci président monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique et énergétique
ce lundi un tremblement de terre a
secoué le sud notre pays vers midi
autour de montélimar le séisme a fait
quatre blessés et a provoqué
d'importants dégâts sur la commune du
teil en ardèche maisons églises
établissements publics sont fissurés
plus de personnes 500 personnes ont été
évacuées et sont dans l'attenté d'une
éventuelle réplique plus important
tremblement de terre enregistrés en
france depuis 16 ans avec une intensité
de 5 4 sur l'échelle de richter
cette secousse inédite pose des
questions sur la sécurité civile si
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a précisé
qu aucun dommage n'avait été relevé sur
le site de cruas et du tricastin
le préfet de la drôme hugues moutouh a
néanmoins annoncé l'arrêt des réacteurs
de la centrale de cruas dans la soirée
de lundi
hier un séisme de magnitude de 3,1 sur
l'échelle de richter a également été
enregistrée à strasbourg
et des f a fait savoir que la secousse
n'avait pas été ressentie sur la
centrale de fessenheim
si la france compte 58 réacteurs
nucléaires en activité répartis sur 19
sites
cinq sites sont situés sur des zones
sismiques dont quatre dans la vallée du
rhône
madame la ministre dans ce contexte
pouvez vous rassurer nos concitoyens sur
le niveau de protection des centrales
nucléaires face à de tels risques
sismiques pour vous répondre la parole
de calvinistes de la transition
écologique et solidaire madame bord vous
avez la parole
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur lui comme
l'a souligné christophe castaner le
gouvernement apporte tout son soutien à
nos concitoyens victimes d'un
tremblement de terre qui a touché
l'ardèche et au delà la vallée du rhône
lundi dernier et je voudrais à mon tour
salué l'intervention des forces de
secours et des services de l'état pour
venir en aide aux sinistrés
alors concernant les installations
nucléaires la vigilance est bien sûr
total toutes les procédures de suivi et
de contrôle ont été mis en oeuvre dès la
survenue du séisme
c'est l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
autorité indépendante qui supervise les
contrôles qui sont mis en oeuvre par les
opérateurs est là et ça n'a pu nous
confirmer qu aucun dommage n'a été
constaté sur les centrale de cruas et de
tricastin et c'est donc en application
du principe de précaution qu' edf a
arrêté les trois réacteurs qui sont qui
étaient en activité sur le site de cruas
des vibrations ayant été ressenties sur
le site de cruas aucune eau qu aucun à
aucune mesure n'a été effectuée par
contre sur la centrale de tricastin et
c'est bien la sn qui déterminera les
conditions de remise en service de ces
réacteurs probablement en fin de semaine
je vous précise s'agissant de fessenheim
qui effectivement aucune secousse n'a
été ressentie sur le site de fessenheim
de façon générale le risque sismique est
naturellement pris en compte dans la
conception des centrales nucléaires en
fonction de l'historique des séismes
observés dans la région
depuis l'accident de fukushima l'asn a
demandé aux exploitants de procéder à
des évaluations de sûreté
complémentaires
ces dispositions sont mises en oeuvre en
trois phases la première à d'ores et
déjà été mises en oeuvre
la seconde le sera d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021 et la troisième sera mise
en oeuvre en fonction des visites
périodiques qui sont réalisés sur les
centrales
merci monsieur bruit voulez vous la
parole et vatan notre collègue françoise
laborde pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole sur collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur la france peut
s'enorgueillir d'avoir fait des lumières
la source son pacte républicain contre
tous les obscurantismes et les
fanatismes
c'est l'honneur de notre république de
rassembler nos concitoyens dans ce
qu'ils ont de commun
par delà leurs origines et leurs
croyances pour la très grande majorité
d'entre nous ici je ne peux hélas pas
dire tous cette conception civique de la
nation au repos sur la laïcité
une laïcité à laquelle on ne peut
accoler aucun adjectif une laïcité
fandor la concorde de la société en
dépassant les identités particulières
qui ne résume pas à un individu une
laïcité facilitant l'édification d'un
monde commun aux hommes sur la base de
leur égalité et de leur liberté de
conscience assurée par la mise à
distance de tous les groupes de pression
comme l'écrit henri pena ruiz la
manifestation du 10 novembre a
malheureusement montré que la voie de
l'apaisement et est encore longue
nous y avons entendu ceux qui prônent la
division le clivage de la société le
repli sur des identités a signé comme si
le déterminisme social était une
fatalité
nous y avons lu des slogans qualifiant
de liberticide les lois de la république
et nous y avons vu les symboles d'une
époque tragique de notre histoire
détourner d'une façon indigne
provocatrice mais assumé faisant écho
aux insultes publiques à l'encontre de
certains sénateurs qualifiés de nazis il
ya quelques jours
or mes chers collègues les symboles ont
un sens que nous n'oublions pas et leur
instrumentalisation par certains nourrit
les amalgames monsieur le ministre mon
groupe porte
laïcité avec force et conviction au nom
de l'universalisme et de légal respect
dû aux croyants comme aux non croyants
la laïcité ce n'est pas simplement
permettre à des coins communauté de
cohabiter en se tolérant
non c'est bien plus que cela elle est la
condition de la fraternité républicaine
en ce triste jour anniversaire des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 alors que
les crispations identitaires progressent
il est urgent pour rassembler et apaisée
d'agir dans ces conditions comment votre
gouvernement compte-t-il défendre notre
laïcité
je vous remercie merci
pour vous répondre
la parole
est à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice faveur d' je connais votre
combat je connais votre implication
je sais aussi que c'est ce combat et
cette implication qui marque votre
groupe
mais je sais aussi combien le sénat est
attaché à cette valeur fondatrice est
fondamental qu'est la laïcité
vous l'avez dit dimanche une
manifestation est organisée par ceux qui
prétendent lutter contre je cite
l'islamophobie
évidemment je respecte nous respectons
ce droit fondamental de manifester mais
notre ligne est claire
manifester c'est un droit qui doit
respecter toutes les valeurs de la
république et celle de la laïcité fait
partie de ces valeurs de la république
nous devons évidemment grâce à la
laïcité protège et le choix religieux de
chacune et de chacun mais ne jamais
accepter de mélanger religion et
radicalité ne jamais accepter de
mélanger l'islam dans ce qu'ils portent
de fait religieux dans la culture qu'il
représente et l'islamisme comme une
organisation politique qui veut son
construire contre les valeurs de la
république contre ce que nous sommes
contre nos identités contre ses
principes fondamentaux tels que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
le fait que certains manifestants soient
venus dimanche avec justement des
revendications qui vont contre ces
valeurs qui doit faire notre commun
notre vivre ensemble et donc la défense
de nos valeurs est totalement scandaleux
le fait que ce soit construit sur un
appel un appel qui dénonce pêle-mêle des
lois liberticides le silence complice
des institutions étatiques chargées de
lutter contre le racisme les délations
abusif jusqu'au plus haut niveau de
l'état contre des musulmans dont le seul
tort serait l'appartenance réelle ou
supposée à une religion ou encore les
dispositifs de surveillance de masse qui
conduisent à une criminalisation pure et
simple de la pratique religieuse se
rendent au fond complice des menaces qui
pèsent sur la république et nous serons
madame la sénatrice totalement engagée à
vos côtés aux côtés des sénateurs pour
faire en sorte que cette laïcité qui
n'est pas ni provocatrice ni au fond
rejeté ne soit pas non plus naïveté et
nous devons au contraire faire en sorte
que pour chaque valeur qui serait mise
en cause par ceux qui aujourd'hui au nom
de la religion
considère qu'il y aurait un intérêt
supérieur à ce qui nous rassemble nous
puissions tous ensemble qu'on battre
pied à pied pour que la république soit
partout chez elle merci monsieur mener
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
pierre ouzoulias ce pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes il avait la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues plus d'un
étudiant sur deux ne mangent pas tous
les jours à sa fin près d'un étudiant
sur deux à renoncer à se soigner par
manque d'argent il ne l'ya que 175 mille
places en résidences étudiantes pour 700
mille étudiants boursiers et le loyer
représente plus de 70% du budget moyen
des étudiants plus d'un étudiant sur
deux est obligé de travailler pour
étudier et subsister ils occupent les
emplois les plus précaires les plus
harassant et les moins rémunérés ainsi
ils composent près de 60 % de la
main-d'oeuvre des plates formes de
prestations
à tout cela s'ajoutent des conditions
d'enseignement indigne et un sous
encadrement pédagogique chronique
la grande majorité de la population
estudiantine est en souffrance et
l'aggravation de sa situation
d'existence conduit à la désespérance à
des drames humains à des gestes
désespérés dont celui d'anna ce qui sont
autant de cris de détresse que vous ne
pouvez ignorer les conséquences de ce
mal-être endémiques sont catastrophiques
pour notre pays de moins en moins
d'étudiants poursuivre un cursus complet
le nombre de doctorants baisse chaque
année et la fuite des cerveaux et
maintenant manifeste à cette crise
majeure
vous répondez par une baisse de moyens
alloués à l'enseignement supérieur la
dépense par étudiant atteint aujourd'hui
son plus bas niveau depuis 2008 est
votre projet de loi de finances ne
portent pas l'ambition d' arrêter cette
chute à la jeunesse qui souhaitent
s'investir en la connaissance la culture
et les oeuvres de la pensée vous
renvoyer
message détestable qu'elle ne serait
qu'une charge qu'un fardeau improductifs
qu'il faudrait continûment alléger merci
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
monsieur gabriel attal
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ouzoulias ce vous abordez une
réalité une dure réalité qui est celle
de la précarité étudiante de la misère
étudiantes parfois une réalité qui a été
remise en lumière à l'occasion de la
tragique immolation d'un jeune vendredi
à lyon et c'est évidemment vers lui vers
ses proches vers la communauté étudiante
et universitaires de lyon que nos
pensées se tournent aujourd'hui frédéric
vidal était présente dès samedi dernier
à lyon pour échanger avec eux c'est une
réalité c'est une réalité que nous avons
choisi de prendre à bras le corps depuis
deux ans maintenant une réalité
d'ailleurs que beaucoup des
gouvernements qui se sont succédé depuis
plusieurs années ont cherché à laquelle
ils ont cherché à répondre nous avons
ainsi supprimer la cotisation sécurité
sociale qui étaient payés par les
étudiants à chaque rentrée c'est 217
euros qui étaient payés par les
étudiants auparavant à la rentrée cette
cotisation a été supprimé nous avons
annoncé il ya deux mois maintenant une
augmentation des bourses de 46 millions
d'euros des bourses qui sont désormais
payés à date le 5 du mois et qui sont
même payé par anticipation en début
d'année pour les étudiants qui auraient
constituer leur dossier
ces progrès on ne peut pas les nier ils
sont là ils sont concrets ils sont
tangibles
évidemment qu'il reste des situations
difficiles évidemment qu'il faut
poursuivre évidemment qu'il faut aussi
faire mieux connaître les dispositifs
qui existent quasiment 50 dispositif des
aides qui existent aujourd'hui à
l'université et notamment des aides pour
les situations d'urgence parce que
parfois la pré gala précarité s'ajoute
la précarité quand il ya une rupture
quand il ya un moment difficile des
aides d'urgence existent et l' enquête
qui est actuellement meunier a mené à
lyon vise à comprendre si l'université
si le crous était informé de la
situation très difficile que vivent et
ce jeune et comment expliquer qu'il
n'ait pas pu lui être proposé ces
dispositifs
il faut poursuivre c'est aussi le sens
du revenu universel d'activité de cette
concertation autour du revenu univers
d'activité qui doit nous amener à
repenser une partie de l'accompagnement
social des jeunes nous y sommes résolus
et nous allons poursuivre la parole et
batman d'après collègues marival blandin
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
avait la parole va chers collègues
merci monsieur le président bien je vais
poursuivre dans la même veine que mon
collègue au soleil à ce monsieur le
secrétaire d'état la précarité du elle
tue aussi notre projet républicain pour
la jeunesse en particulier celle qui est
issu des familles les moins aisées et
qui aspire à un progrès social par
l'éducation
l'état ne parvient pas à enrayer les
déterminismes sociaux
il s'agit de garantir à chaque étudiant
les conditions de vie nécessaires à sa
réussite
le logement l'alimentation la santé les
transports les livres qui lui sont
nécessaires
or la précarité étudiante ne cesse
d'augmenter
20% des étudiants vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté est plus dans tiers d'entre
eux travaillent en plus de leurs études
leur accès à la santé empathie on le lui
dit tout à l'heure les enquêtes
annuelles de la fage et de l'unef conclu
à une hausse du coût de la vie étudiante
de près de 3% en 2010 9 vous allez me
répondre que le montant des bourses a
été revalorisé et que vous crédit sont
en hausse pour 2020 mais cela n'est pas
suffisant lorsque dans le même temps les
frais de vie courante ne cesse de
croître que le prix du ticket de resto u
et la contribution à la vie étudiante
augmente et que vous prenez des mesures
incompréhensible comme la baisse des
appels et de l'allocation logement
social
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
allez-vous proposer une refonte des
aides qui leur sont destinés comment
allez vous accélérer la construction des
logements étudiants dont madame la
ministre a elle-même jugée
le nombre insuffisant nous avons besoin
de réponses concrètes pour redonner
espoir à notre jeunesse pour vous
répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre l'éducation nationale
de la jeunesse monsieur le ministre
madame la sénatrice je veux commencer
par dire que la question de la
démocratisation de la réussite à l'école
et dans l'enseignement supérieur que
vous avez évoqué c'est ce qui guide
notre politique c'est le sens de notre
action à l'école avec le dédoublement
des classes avec l'aide aux devoirs avec
les moyens qui sont mis pour les
quartiers qui sont aujourd'hui les plus
difficiles et la démocratisation de la
réussite à l'université elle passe aussi
par la question de la condition de vie
des étudiants et c'est le sens de notre
action depuis maintenant deux ans pour
répondre à certains points que vous avez
abordé non le coût de la rentrée
universitaire n'a pas augmenté cette
année les estimations même montré qu'il
était plus faible que les années
précédentes
s'agissant du ticket sur leur pour les
restaurants universitaires nous avons
donné une perspective à quatre ans pour
faire baisser le coût du panier de base
sur les restaurants universitaires
il y à des chantiers à continuer à
explorer à travailler c'est ce que nous
faisons avec les organisations
étudiantes encore une fois dans le cadre
de cette concertation sur le revenu
universel d'activités auxquelles
participent les organisations étudiantes
évidemment il faut continuer à avancer
avec eux sur la question du logement
vous avez évoqué avec l'engagement du
président de la république de 60000
construction de logements pour les
étudiants
nous progressons progressivement nous
créons des logements pour les étudiants
il faut poursuivre il faut mettre tous
ces sujets sur la table
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
le premier ministre m'a demandé de
recevoir au plus vite les organisations
étudiantes et ce cycle de rendez vous
démarrera dès demain matin
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
eux encore une fois dans le cadre de
cette concertation et nous continuons à
avancer pour garantir que les conditions
de vie des étudiants s'améliore dans les
années qui viennent
en prenant des actions très concrètes
comme celle que nous avons engagées
depuis maintenant deux ans la blonde
juste rappeler que la complémentaire
santé maintenant des plus obligatoire
depuis la la baisse de la sécurité
sociale étudiante et elle coûte 313
euros pour un étudiant qui veut se
prévenir s'assurer sur la complémentaire
santé avant la sécurité sociale coûté
merci la parole et à notre collègue à la
marque pour vous avez pendant vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
j'associe à ma question mon collègue de
l'aveyron jean claude luche et l ancien
premier ministre socialiste avait
proposé la suppression des départements
le projet n'a heureusement pas été
suivies d'effet les départements
démontre chaque jour ils sont essentiels
qui jouent un rôle déterminant de
proximité à l'heure des très grandes
deux régions il accompagne les communes
dans leurs projets mais ils sont aussi à
leurs côtés lorsqu'elle rencontre des
difficultés
la solidarité territoriale unis les
départements aux communes ici pour un
dernier commerce ou une salle
d'activités là pour une construction
d'une école par exemple que ce soit les
routes les lycées où le social le
tourisme le sport la culture les
départements font beaucoup pour nos
territoires
si nous souhaitons qu'il continue dans
cette voie de proximité il faut
sécuriser leurs ressources des coûts
nouveaux comme la gestion des mineurs
non accompagnés grimpe en flèche
5 millions par exemple d'euros
aujourd'hui pour l'aveyron
le projet de loi prévoit de remplacer
les ressources départementales tirés de
la taxe foncière sur le bâti par la
location d'une fraction de la tva les
départements vont ainsi perdre un
nouveau levier fiscal la tva elle est
une recette variable dont dans son
produit à la hausse comme à la baisse
car elle dépend de la consommation
or pour assumer leurs diverses
compétences et par exemple les aides aux
communes dont j'ai déjà parlé
les départements ne peuvent se permettre
de voir leurs recettes diminuer en
raison d'une baisse de consommation
que comptez-vous faire madame la
ministre pour que les ressources des
départements ne soit pas soumise aux
aléas de la consommation
envisagez-vous un mécanisme qui
empêcherait toute diminution de ces
ressources d'une année sur l'autre en
cas de récession économique
on va répondre la parole est à mme la
ministre la cohésion des territoires des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales de king madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur à la marque et
monsieur le sénateur luche qui était
associé à cette question au delà de la
réforme très importante que vous
connaissez bien sûr de la suppression de
la th qui est une baisse d'impôts sans
précédent pour nos concitoyens de 18
milliards d'euros nous nous sommes en
effet assuré pour les collectivités
locales des conséquences bien sûr c'est
à dire qu'elle soit compensée par des
ressources fiscales qui soit à la fois
pérenne et dynamique et cela je le
précise tout en améliorant la lisibilité
pour nos concitoyens du prélèvement de
l'impôt pour les départements vous avez
raison cette compensation prend la forme
d'une fraction de tva nationales et je
dis bien fraction et non pas un montant
c'est à dire que ça assure bien sûr la
progression et l'autonomie financière
car c'est tout l'averse d'une dotation
le système sera par ailleurs plus
équitable et sa j'insiste beaucoup
là-dessus parce que vous soyez riche ou
pauvre et quelle que soit la dynamique
foncière
chaque département vers a progressé de
la même manière cette ressource
chaque année je répète bien que les
départements soit riche ou pauvre
c'est une assurance bien sûr pour les
plus démunis des départements cette
réforme n'a donc pas susciter ou
aggraver la question du niveau de
ressources de certains départements et
le gouvernement est néanmoins conscient
de la nécessaire péréquation attendu par
les collectivités
deux mesures ont été votés en loi de
finances à l'assemblée nationale
le premier mesure un renforcement de la
péréquation horizontale qui reprend
l'accord trouvé cet été par l'adf entre
membres de l'association des
départements de france
et par ailleurs l'attribution d'une
fraction supplémentaire de tva de 250
millions d'euros de manière perret coûts
et par le gouvernement je voudrais
terminer en vous disant par ailleurs que
cette dynamique de la tva restera
entièrement aux mains des départements
et notamment avec une clause de
sauvegarde qui permettra une aide
d'urgence aux départements qui
pourraient être avoir des crises graves
et l'exemple qu'on vient de vivre par
exemple dans l'ardèche ou dans la drôme
monsieur barque oui merci madame la
ministre mais ma question était était
très technique
en cas de récession le produit attendu
au niveau de la tva va baisser
au niveau de l'état et je ne voudrais
pas que ce qui sera alloué au
département baisse aussi donc ce qui
convient d'enclencher c'est un mécanisme
qui permettra en n en est un est de ne
pas avoir moins
quant à eux moins jeunes voilà telle
était ma question de pouvoir continuer à
aider à aider par exemple nos communes
la parole de notre collègue arnaud bazin
pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
l'état vient de retirer son soutien au
projet europa city le condamnant après
dix ans de co-construction entre
l'établissement public d'état plaine de
france et immochan avec le soutien de
l'ensemble des collectivités locales
chacun connaît l'importance et la
spécificité de ce projet de
développement dans un des territoires
les plus défavorisés de la république et
nous avait d'ailleurs semblé comprendre
après le rejet du plan borloo pour les
banlieues par le président de la
république que les villes socialement en
difficulté étaient priés de chercher
leur salut dans le développement
économique et l'emploi
en l'occurrence 3 milliards d'euros
d'investissements privés et plus de dix
mille emplois à la clé madame bornes
après avoir allégué dans les motifs de
cette décision
le souci de ne pas bétonner davantage
assurée dans le même temps de la volonté
du gouvernement d'urbaniser quand même
le triangle de gonesse et d'y construire
la gare de la ligne 17
comprenne qui pourra considérant qu'une
grande partie des ressources nécessaires
à l'aménagement de la zac était apportée
par le projet europa city
considérant l'impécuniosité de l'état je
souhaite que vous nous disiez monsieur
le premier ministre
à quel niveau de participation vous
engager l'état dans le projet de
substitution dans lequel vous nous
demandez de croire et comment vous
entendez dégager les fonds nécessaires
quand la dette publique tangente les
sons % du pipe et qu'elle s'est alourdi
de 190 milliards d'euros dans les trois
années de votre gouvernement
on répondre la parole et à la ministre
la transition écologique et solidaire
madame board
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bazin le gouvernement est bien
conscient des difficultés de l'est du
val-d'oise et je mesure donc la
déception des élus engagés dans ce
territoire suite à la décision de mettre
fin au projet repas city mais ce projet
n'est pas la bonne réponse ou n'était
pas la bonne réponse au défi de ce
territoire et il n'est pas cohérent avec
notre ambition en matière de transition
écologique
pour réussir cette transition il nous
faut faire des choix parfois difficiles
mais cohérent et le projet europa city
relève d'un modèle aujourd'hui dépassée
qui ne répond plus aux aspirations de
nos concitoyens avec des centres
commerciaux toujours plus grand à la
périphérie de nos villes qui renforce la
dépendance à la voiture
et de fait ce projet aurait conduit à
une aggravation de la congestion
routière dans un secteur qui connaît
déjà des difficultés avec notamment dix
mille places de parkings prévus dans le
projet puis il aurait également conduit
à artificialisés 80 hectares de terres
agricoles dans le cadre d'un étalement
urbain dont nous ne voulons plus
pour autant nous ne laisserons pas
tomber le territoire ce projet avait
suscité beaucoup d'attentes mais je suis
convaincu que le territoire mérite mieux
et c'est le sens du travail que nous
voulons mener avec les élus avec le
monde économique étant entendu que la
desserte par la ligne 17 ne sera pas
remise en cause et donc c'est la mission
qui est confiée à monsieur rol-tanguy et
je ne doute pas que vous serez force de
proposition pour construire un projet à
la hauteur des attentes des valdoisiens
en tout cas je le redis l'état ne
laissera pas tomber
ce territoire monsieur lazhar merci
monsieur le président il y aurait
beaucoup à dire sur les aspects
écologiques de cette décision puisque il
faut quand même se souvenir que la
proposition de repas city c'était la
neutralité carbone en 2027 et que le
caricaturer en le réduisant à un simple
centre commercial n'a aucun rapport avec
la réalité mais ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est qu'après cette décision la
parole de l'état est totalement
dévalorisés dans ces territoires
inflammable en essayant de faire
miroiter un projet alternatif dont notre
état n'a pas les moyens je n'ai pas
entendu de réponse aux deux questions
que j'ai posées
vous porterez la très lourde
responsabilité d'aggraver cette totale
perte de confiance et vous devrez en
assumer les conséquences
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue laurence rossignol
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
si monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie il y
a un an pour apaiser la colère des gilet
jaune
le président de la république avait
convoqué les banques et avait lui même
annoncé que désormais les frais pour
incidents blanche bancaire serait
plafonnée à 25 euros par mois pour les
personnes en difficulté 7 3 millions de
personnes environ étaient concernés
potentiellement concernés et le présent
de la république avait même je cite dit
que c'était ainsi que 500 à 600 millions
d'euros seraient redistribuées en
direction des français
il se trouve que il ya quelques jours
l'union nationale des associations
familiales unaf
avec 60 millions de consommateurs ce ne
sont pas des officines malveillantes et
anti gouvernementales ont publié une
enquête dans laquelle il révèle que sur
100 personnes potentiellement
accessibles à ce nouveau droit
72 d'entre elle se l'était vu refuser et
que sur les trois millions et demi de
français qui pourraient en bénéficier 90
% n'en avait jamais entendu parler en
tout cas pas par leur banque
donc en conclusion vous vous êtes fait
rouler par les banques
rouler dans la farine c'est pas si grave
ça peut arriver à tout le monde
mais aujourd'hui il vous faut tenir les
engagements pris il ya un an et je
voudrais savoir si vous êtes prêts dans
le projet de loi de finances à soutenir
ou proposer un amendement qui
garantirait par la loi le plafonnement
des pénalités pour incidents bancaires
pour les populations défavorisées
pour vous répondre la parole et mobilise
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
bruno le maire monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice rossignol il ya des
engagements quand tu es pris par les
banques auprès du président de la
république auprès des ministres des
finances
ils doivent être tenu ses engagements
ils sont clairs il y à une offre
spécifique dont vous avez parlé qui
permet aux clients les plus fragiles un
d'avoir accès à un ensemble service
kerr de base pour 3 euros par mois puis
nous nous sommes aperçus que au delà de
cette offre de services de base
elle pouvait y avoir des frais
d'incident bancaire qui atteignait
plusieurs centaines d'euros par an et
donc qui était insupportable pour ses
populations
la première engagement qui a été pris
c'est de plafonner dans le cadre de
cette offre spécifique
l'ensemble des frais d'incident bancaire
à 20 euros par mois
200 euros par an ce premier engagement
doit être tenu il ya un deuxième
engagement qui doit être retenue c'est
d'augmenter le nombre de clients qui
sont bénéficiaires de cet autre
spécifique
aujourd'hui ils sont 350 milles c'est la
clientèle la plus fragile mais vous avez
raison
trop souvent cette offre spécifique
n'est pas connu par ces populations qui
sont les plus fragiles qui ne savent
même pas qu'elles existent
ce deuxième engagement doivent également
être tenu
il y en a un troisième vous l'avez
mentionné c'est pour des publics
fragiles mais qui n'ont pas
nécessairement besoin de l'offre
spécifique mais qui ont des revenus
modestes de ne pas être accablé par des
frais nation banque est trop élevé et là
aussi l'engagement des banques était
extrêmement claire 25 euros de frais
d'incidents bancaire au maximum pour ces
populations fragiles
c'est le troisième engagement qui a été
pris par les banques
la cpr a fait un premier bilan qui
montrent que les choses sont en cours
c'est une vision un peu différente de
celle de l'unaf
mais je le reconnais bien volontiers
nous n'y sommes pas encore je
rassemblerai la fédération bancaire
française d'ici quelques semaines nous
ferons un point sur la base des chiffres
qui ne seront donnés par le cpr et par
l'observatoire d'inclusion bancaire qui
est placée auprès de la banque de france
et je peux vous le garantir madame
rossignol nous veillerons à ce que ces
engagements soient respectés
ils ont été pris par les banques ils
devront être respectées et s'ils ne le
sont pas eh bien nous mettrons toutes
les autres solutions sur la table soit
été convenue avec les banques et ne
seront pas prises par surprise dans ce
cas
monsieur le ministre vous avez passé les
trois quarts de votre temps de parole à
nous rappeler les engagements qui ont
été pris l'année dernière que j'avais
moi même rappeler et qui n'ont pas été
tenues
c'est dommage d'avoir gaspillé votre
temps comme ça ce que je vous demandais
c'était est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
soutenir ou déposer un amendement de
façon à ce qu'on ne rouvre pas une
nouvelle année de discussions avec les
banques et pour faire le même constat
dans un an donc au projet loi de
finances
nous déposerons un amendement j'espère
que le gouvernement sensible aux
engagements qu'il a pris
ayant confiance en lui même est dans le
parlement davantage que dans les banques
soutiendra cet amendement merci la
parole est à notre collègue nicole
duranton pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
des comités et associations de pêcheurs
normands m'ont saisi pour me faire part
de leur vive inquiétude concernant le
carnage de la pêche industrielle
je me fais ici leur porte parole depuis
le mois d'octobre deux chalutiers g en
battant pavillon lituanien et allemands
sont arrivés sur les côtes normandes
sous le vent colère et inquiétude chez
nos pêcheurs locaux du tréport à
cherbourg ses usines flottantes
pratiquer une pêche de masse à une
échelle industrielle
ils sont dans leur droit au vu des
articles 32 à 39 du traité de rome qui
prévoit effectivement que tous les états
membres puissent jeter leurs filets dans
ses eaux
en vertu de la politique commune de
pêche cependant les systèmes
d'aspiration de ces chalutiers
monstrueux vie de la mère de 250 tonnes
de poissons en une seule journée soit le
tiers de la pêche d'un chalutier
normands en un an
ne laissant que des miettes aux artisans
pêcheurs normands qui s'astreignent à
une gestion raisonnée en petites unités
madame la ministre c'est sans doute un
avant goût de la pêche poste briques
site
ces navires sont en train de détruire
temps l'économie locale liée à la pêche
que les écosystèmes maritimes
or l'objectif de l'europe bleus est
aussi de préserver la biodiversité
marine et de prévenir les conflits entre
états membres
en tant que parlementaire de la seconde
régions de pêche européenne c'est ce
paradoxe qui me conduit à vous demander
d'agir vous siéger dans les instances de
l'union européenne qui peut modifier la
politique commune de pêche
que comptez vous faire pour arrêter ce
massacre il faut des règles strictes
pour éviter que cette catastrophe et des
conséquences irréversibles pour notre
pêche artisanale
merci répond de la parole à la
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
madame monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vous m'interpeller dans un
moment extrêmement sensible nous savons
celui de la pêche et celui du breakbeat
deux événements de sujets qui se
rencontrent et vous l'avez rappelé qui
inquiète sur notre littoral
parce que nous manquons de visibilité
alors la politique commune de pêche
c'est d'abord vous l'avez rappelé non
pas seulement une politique qui vient de
bruxelles on n'impose pas on ne
contraint pas on cherche bien à garantir
à chacun un accès aux eaux de l'ensemble
de la communauté européenne ce qui est
une source de ressources également pour
nos pêcheurs français qui vont
aujourd'hui pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques et nous nous mobilisons
avec dit guillaume avec michel barnier
avec l'ensemble des acteurs pour que ce
droit soit conservée dans le futur la
pêche est aussi des règles du jeu
communes et une garantie de concurrence
loyale et nous sommes actuellement en
train de consulter par rapport à la
négociation de fin d'année qui arrivent
sur les côtes a consulté les
représentants du secteur nous fonder sur
des avis scientifiques robuste pour que
cette négociation pour l'année 2020 soit
une ré une négociation réaliste nous
voulons aussi faire évoluer à plus long
terme la politique commune des pêches
nous pensons côté français qu'il est
utile de mettre en place de véritables
quotas pluriannuel pour apporter à tous
les artisans pêcheurs de la
prévisibilité sur ce qu'ils pourront
pêcher
nous voyons aujourd'hui que certains
stocks sont sur une bonne tendance le
bar l'aiglefin la sole d'autres sont sur
une tendance plus difficile le merlan en
mer celtique aussi le cabillaud et donc
nous sommes très vigilants parce que
nous voyons bien que c'est en préservant
les stocks que nous pourrons amener nos
pêcheurs à avoir des ressources durables
pour pouvoir voir des activités sur
plusieurs années
face au brésil effectivement les
incertitudes sont grandes et vous
connaissez la mobilisation et du
gouvernement et de la commission
européenne à ne pas faire de ce sujet un
enjeu de rapport de force mais bien un
enjeu où nous sommes mobilisés pour que
les droits actuels puissent perdurer
et rappelons que 70% du poisson pêché
dans les eaux britanniques et transformé
en france et donc nous avons là aussi
moyen de pouvoir peser pour conclure et
bien en décembre les négociations sur
les quotas pourront se faire parce que
le brésil aura lieu au maintenant au
plus tôt en janvier dans des conditions
bien meilleures conclusions craindre
merci madame duranton j'entends bien
votre réponse madame la ministre mais
les mots doivent se traduire en actes
votre opposition doit être ferme et
combative pour sauver nos pêcheurs en
portant des actions claires et efficaces
auprès des instances européennes
au delà des ressources maritimes il
s'agit là de 2600 emplois de pêcheurs
normands avec autant de familles qui
sont derrière et qui sont directement
menacés il y va il y va donc de votre
responsabilité vont conclure madame la
ministre c'est un appel au secours que
les pêcheurs vous lance merci la parole
et notre collègue catherine fournier
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues je reviens sur
le même sujet que celui de la pêche
industrielle
abordé par ma collègue nicole durand ton
intervention à laquelle je m'associe
complètement et que j'approuve
totalement alors aux côtes normandes j'y
ajoute la côte d'opale est le premier
port de pêche français qu'est
boulogne-sur-mer
nous ne pouvons pas nous contenter d'une
réponse comme celle que vous nous avez
fait madame la ministre chargé des
affaires européennes
j'aurais aimé avoir la position
environnementale de madame la ministre
de la transition écologique et de et
solidaire en effet la politique des
quotas est d'abord dicté par la
préservation des espèces de la
biodiversité et du gaspillage
je me tourne donc vers vous madame la
ministre
un bateau comme le margie rice qui
naviguait en mer du nord manche
courant octobre est un ogre des mers un
ogre de la pêche c'est le synonyme même
d'un désastre à la fois économiques mais
aussi écologiques
il a une capacité de pêche en un jour
équivalent à la production annuelle de
cinq fileyeur classique boulonnais
aucune pondération une opération spot
deux seules semaines on a tout pillé
détruit une partie des fonds marins de
la flore de la faune et on s'en va
ailleurs que les sto au laborieux
artisans pêcheurs qui triment tout au
long de l'année et qui lui réguler de
fait sa production cette pêche
industrielle au large de nos côtes
françaises est une menace pour la
ressource halieutique
elle engendre de graves conséquences sur
les écosystèmes marins ainsi que sur la
sécurité et la qualité alimentaire
face à ce désastre écologique comptez
vous madame la ministre agir auprès de
la commission européenne
et de quelle manière la concurrence
libre et non faussée fait partie
intégrante de la constitution européenne
merci madame amélie de montchanin
secrétaire d'état en charge des affaires
européennes avait la parole
merci à nouveau monsieur le président
madame sénatrice nous sommes là bien sûr
un sujet qui montre l'importance de
travailler de manière interministériel
il y un sujet européen
il vient sujet de pêche et lien sujets
écologiques alors je voulais vous
apporter ici des éléments précis sur
l'activité de ce bateau le marché risque
il ya effectivement exercer des
activités en manche dans les eaux
communautaires de la zone exclusive
économique britannique
en l'espèce il pêcha du chinchard
espèces pour laquelle il dépose d'un
quota de 2150 tonnes le centre national
de surveillance des pêches a été
mobilisé par didier guillaume par son
ministère une veille sur les activités a
été menée lors notamment sa présence au
large des côtes françaises
et il apparaît que le navire n'a pas
pêché dans les zones françaises
puisqu'il n'ya seulement transité mais
vous avez raison la présence de tels
chalutiers et bien constater chaque
année
elle est constitutive de l'activité
saisonnière de cette flottille elles
reposent sur le droit communautaire de
pêcher dans les eaux des uns et des
autres et donc c'est pour cela j'en
reviens au point à ma réponse précédente
la politique des quotas doit être très
fermes elle doit elle reposait sur des
destinations scientifique pour que nous
puissions garder des stocks de manière
durable et nous pensons au niveau
français qu'il est important d'avoir des
quotas pluriannuel pour justement
pouvoir réguler dans le temps des
activités qui pose on l'a vu question
nous sommes très mobilisés pour avoir
une vigilance extrême sur le fait que
les règles soient respectées que les
quotas soient respectés et que tous les
acteurs qui pêchent dans le même bassin
et bien soit soumis aux mêmes contrôles
et à la même vigilance
ces navires usines sont légaux il nous
faut maintenant nous assurer qu'il
respecte l'intégralité des règles et
vous pouvez compter sur la mobilisation
de l'ensemble du gouvernement d
administration dit guillaume et moi même
je remercie et la parole est maintenant
notre collègue corinne imbert pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse est au ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
ce n'est un secret pour personne les
deux grands perdants du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron sont les retraités et
les familles et je veux parler
aujourd'hui de notre politique familiale
s'il ya bien un domaine dans lequel la
france excellait en comparaison avec ses
voisins européens c'est celui de la
natalité
et pourtant depuis plusieurs années
cette tendance est en train de
s'inverser
alors bien sûr il existe des réalités
sociologiques et des évolutions des
schémas de vie qui expliquent en partie
ce phénomène mais ces réalités
n'explique pas tout
cette baisse continue de la natalité est
également à mettre en lien avec la
dégradation de mode notre modèle de
politique familiale
deux exemples amena ministre depuis
plusieurs mois bon nombre de familles
attendent le versement du complément de
libre choix de mode de garde
double peine puisque elles sont
également victimes de prélèvement de
cotisations indues
deuxième exemple pour la deuxième année
consécutive et à l'heure où le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale est en discussion dans cet
hémicycle les prestations familiales
seront sous indexer ces événements et
ses choix est profondément sur l'
équilibre financier des familles
alors je le dis avec gravité cette
tendance est assez inédite depuis la
naissance de notre politique familiale
ma question est simple et concise madame
la ministre le gouvernement entend qu
ils délibérément affaiblir la politique
familiale française pour vous répondre
la parole et à madame la ministre des
solidarités de la chanteuse agnès buzyn
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice corinne imbert
les familles sont clairement accompagné
par ce gouvernement
je rappelle que la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion 2018-2022 de
la branche famille prévoit un effort
significatif pour renforcer le
développement de l'accueil des jeunes
enfants et des services à la famille et
qu'un travail important est engagée
autour de la parentalité avec la
commission des mille jours qui est
animée par adrien taquet le plfss pour
2020 prévoit une mesure très attendue
par les familles monoparentales avec la
création d'un service public de
versement des pensions alimentaires
les prestations familiales continueront
d'augmenter vous le savez au 1er avril
2020 elles augmenteront de 0 3% comme
l'ensemble des prestations sociales en
matière de pouvoir d'achat nous avons
choisi d'aider les familles
monoparentales nous et nous les aidons à
récupérer leurs pensions alimentaires
qui représentent parfois 20 % du revenu
familial et vous savez que ce sont les
familles les plus pauvres aujourd'hui en
parallèle pour assurer une meilleure
conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
nous nous engageons à créer de nouvelles
offres d'accueil du jeune enfant
améliorer son accessibilité avec
notamment comme priorité la création de
30000 places de crèches mi lé relais
assistants maternels supplémentaires
nous avons augmenté le montant de du
complément de libre choix de mode de
garde pour les familles monoparentales
et vous parlez d'un bug informatique qui
est en train d'être réparé pour les
quelques familles impactés nous avons
également amélioré l'accessibilité aux
crèches pour les familles avec un enfant
en situation de handicap
nous avons un plan de formation des six
cent mille professionnels de la petite
enfance
enfin l'article 49 du plfss qui va être
votée permet d'assurer une information
exacte
steve et en temps réel sur l'offre
d'accueil près de chez soi pour toutes
les familles vous le voyez madame la
sénatrice nous travaillons à mieux
accompagner les familles dans la
totalité de leurs besoins
nous sommes engagés auprès d'elle auprès
de toutes les familles je vous remercie
madame amer merci monsieur le président
merci madame la ministre pour pouvoir
réponse mais vous venez de reconnaître
que les prestations familiales ne seront
réévaluées que de 0 3% bien en dessous
de 10 1% que notre famille politique
défend il faut pas oublier que devant
les baisses des dotations aux
collectivités
il ya eu des augmentations des
transports scolaires il ya eu des
augmentations des frais de cantine et
des accueils périscolaires dépenses
auxquels les familles doivent faire face
j'entends également que l'on veut
augmenter la redevance audiovisuelle
pour les familles avec enfants
donc je ne pense pas que ce soit des
bons signaux envers les familles
certains attendent le tournant social du
quinquennat nous nous attendons non
seulement le tournant de la fermeté mais
nous attendons surtout le tournant de la
justice et de la considération pour les
familles merci monsieur poulet la parole
m lepreau collègue andré gattolin pour
le groupe la république en marche
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre
hier la commission européenne après plus
de six mois d'enquêté approfondie a
transmis aux autorités du cambodge
un rapport préliminaire en vertu duquel
sans réponses rapides et appropriées de
son gouvernement
le cambodge pourrait voir le système de
préférences commerciales dit tout sauf
les armes dont ils bénéficient
suspendu en février prochain ces
procédures de la commission constitue
une première dans le cadre de ce
mécanisme d' aide au développement et
nous tenons ici à le saluer
elle s'effectue en raison de violations
réitéré des engagements pris par le pays
en matière de respect des droits humains
et des droits des travailleurs par le
régime de monsieur hauts-de-seine au
pouvoir depuis plus de 34 ans deux ans
après la dissolution du principal parti
d'opposition et suite aux élections de
juillet de l'an passé élections
amplement contestée par la communauté
internationale le régime en place
connaît une inquiétante dérive
autoritaire qui contrevient au processus
de démocratisation auquel il avait
pourtant souscrit lors des accords de
paris en 1991 après la chute du régime
khmer rouge
sous la pression les autorités
cambodgiennes ont avant-hier lever la
résidence surveillée d'un des leaders de
l'opposition
monsieur kem sokha tandis que monsieur
ce un brin six présidents en exil du
parti du sauvetage nationale du cambodge
a été reçue hier et ce matin même avec
beaucoup de bienveillance par les
autorités de la malaisie et de
l'indonésie
le ma question monsieur le ministre est
donc simple au delà de l'initiative
juste de la commission européenne n'est
ce pas pour la france le moment opportun
de jouer un rôle actif pour tenter de
ramener le cambodge dans leur voie de la
démocratisation en conformité avec les
engagements de notre pays qui je le
rappelle président avec l'un des aînés
zee en 1991 la signature des accords de
paris je vous remercie
quand vont répondre la parole est à
jean-baptiste lemoyne secrétaire était
en produisent de l'europe des affaires
étrangères il avait la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur andré gattolin je
connais votre attachement à la défense
des libertés de la démocratie au
cambodge et votre constance sur ce sujet
là comme vous nous sommes préoccupés par
la situation et les élections
législatives de 2010 8 vous le rappeliez
se sont déroulées dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas bonnes avec un parti
d'opposition le parti du salut national
qui avait été dissous avec son leader
qui avait été mis en prison et donc face
à cela très clairement nous ne pouvons
pas rester inerte avec les européens
nous avons donc déclenché et bien cette
enquête qui va nous permettre de prendre
un certain nombre de décisions de lever
des préférences commerciales parce que
l'europe ce n'est pas seulement un
marché l'europe ce sont des valeurs et
qui veut et bien exportée en europe doit
aussi se conformer aux droits sociaux
aux droits des travailleurs aux valeurs
démocratiques fondamentales et je me
réjouis que ce langage de fermeté et
produit quelques premiers résultats
puisque eh bien monsieur kem sokha a
connu un assouplissement de ses
conditions de détention il est désormais
libre de circuler sur le territoire sous
contrôle judiciaire
c'était un geste
nécessaire il n'est pas suffisant très
clairement nous attendons du
gouvernement cambodgien qu'ils puissent
initier un véritable dialogue pour
reprendre un chemin qui soient crédibles
vers et bien un régime démocratique et
faute de quoi si nous ne voyons pas de
progrès et bien en février nous serons
amenés à le constater et à suspendre un
certain nombre de préférences
commerciales là encore nous demeurons
vigilants face à cette situation je vous
le confirme
merci messieurs miner la parole et à
notre collègue joëlle garriaud-maylam
pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
en état de mort cérébrale ces mots pour
le moins provocateur voire insultants du
président de la république au sujet de
l'otan nous ont fait énormément de mal
sur la scène internationale exception
faite bien sûr de la russie ces mots
n'ont fait que conforter l'image
d'arrogance et de déconnexion dont nous
souffrons hélas encore trop souvent à
l'étranger
certes le silence retentissant des
occidentaux face à l'intervention turque
est une honte mais celle ci n'est pas le
fait de l'otan ni de l'onu du res qui ne
sont que l'émanation de gouvernements
nationaux
il est facile mais dangereux et le break
site nous l'a prouvé de désigner les
institutions supranationales comme bouc
émissaire de nos manque de courage
politique et ce n'est guère constructif
pour l'avenir de la sécurité mondiale je
voudrais également rappeler que le temps
à 70 ans et avec 29 états membres et
l'alliance la plus réussie de l'histoire
du monde
beaucoup de pays font d'énormes efforts
pour la rejoindre qu'elle a car elle a
su garantir la paix pendant ses 70 ans
sur le territoire des états membres
certes l'évolution de la situation
géopolitique avec la montée en puissance
de nouveaux acteurs et le des gants des
engagements
etats unis doivent pousser l'europe à
repenser sa stratégie sécurité et allait
enfin vers cette défense européenne
structuré autonome que nous appelons de
nos voeux depuis des années mais à
l'heure où le break site
affaiblis les dynamics européenne de
coopération en matière de sécurité
défense où rares sont les pays européens
ont accepté de consacrer 2% de leur pib
à leur défense et où par contre russie
chine turquie arabie saoudite ont
augmenté leur budget de défense de 30%
en moyenne ces dernières années aux
progressions plus important de ne pas
érodé l'an fait de l'otan dont le
royaume uni et est encore production
monsieur le premier ministre love la
france ne devrait-elle pas se
positionner en fer de lance de cette
réforme pour pouvoir avec empathie et
bienveillance construire cette europe
qu'on peut défense au lieu du taux de la
mère de mettre au pilori le temps répond
la parole est à madame la ministre est
armé
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice
le président de la république a
récemment évoqué les nombreux défis
auxquels l'organisation pour le traité
de l'atlantique nord est confronté il a
employé en effet des mots très forts
mais qui sont à la hauteur de la crise
de sens au cas de cette organisation est
confronté en tombe on ou bien alors que
nous allons célébrer le 70e anniversaire
de l'otan il ne s'agit ni de nier ces
succès ni de contester sa crédibilité
militaire il s'agit plutôt de pointer
les obstacles politiques que nous devons
surmonter pour répondre aux défis de
notre sécurité
ces obstacles ont été mis vous l'avez
ratée en lumière de façon dramatique par
les événements récents qui ont été qui
sont survenus dans le nord-est syrien et
ses obstacles
j'en vois trois le premier c'est
l'incertitude qui concerne la politique
américaine
le second c'est l'attitude de la turquie
qui met en jeu la cohésion des alliés
avec des actions qui portent atteinte à
nos intérêts de sécurité et enfin vous
l'avez dit aussi l'insuffisance de
l'effort de défense des européens alors
que les américains eux-mêmes des exhorte
à partager un fardeau qu'ils ne veulent
plus assumer seul
si certains de nos alliés ont tendance à
minimiser voire à nier ses défis et ses
difficultés
la france entend porter une voie
exigeante et lucide
afin de surmonter cette crise dans
l'intérêt de l'alliance et de l'europe
lors du sommet de londres la france
plaidera pour le lancement d'une
véritable réflexion sur l'avenir de
l'alliance l'otan doit constituer une
alliance solidaires et responsables dans
laquelle chaque membre en particulier
les européens contribuent de manière
crédible à l'effort de défense
la france ne souhaite donc pas fragilisé
l'organisation car l'alliance est et
demeure un élément clé de la sécurité
européenne
il n'y aura pas de défense européenne
sans autant et réciproquement
pour vous répondre pardon la parole est
maintenant notre collègue olivier
jacquin pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre le nord
lorrain est voisin du luxembourg
c'est une chance pour les 105 milles
frontaliers qui travaillent chaque jour
cependant je souhaite vous interpeller
sur une injustice notables et j'y
associe mon collègue jean marc
todeschini
vous connaissez merci de le saluer vous
connaissez les conditions fiscales du
grand duché puisqu'une convention au
demeurant insuffisante vient d'être
actualisé ce pays développe une
politique économique offensive et
accueille avec des entreprises avec des
impôts et des cotisations très faible
c'est en partie pour ces raisons que des
entreprises françaises s'y installent
mais ils assèchent de ce fait les
ressources de nos collectivités qui
doivent parallèlement répondre aux
demandes légitimes de service des
frontaliers ce sans parler des
difficultés de recrutement en france ou
encore des problèmes de transport la
france dispose d'accords bilatéraux avec
la belgique l'allemagne et la suisse par
exemple cette dernière reverse 1 cian
aux collectivités un pourcentage des
salaires bruts hors la france n'a pas
d'accords de ce type avec le luxembourg
le grand duché reçoit l'intégralité des
impôts sur le revenu mais ne reversent
presqu'aucune compensions au territoire
de résidence des travailleurs lors de la
36e session du congrès des pouvoirs
locaux du conseil de l'europe qui s'est
tenu à strasbourg il ya dix jours l'afer
a été enfin clairement mis sur la table
une résolution pour une répartition
équitable de l'impôt dans les zones
transfrontalières a été adopté à une
très large majorité
or le premier ministre luxembourgeois
vient de déclarer qu'il n'envisageait
pas de signer un tel chaque monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement va-t-il suivre
les recommandations du conseil de
l'europe
allons nous enfin nous doter d'une
véritable politique financé
d'accompagnement économique et social de
tous
au territoire transfrontalier vous
répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état auprès des visites l'action des
contributions vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jacques 1 g j'ai pris
connaissance et je sais l'engagement
qu'est le vote pour rétablir une forme
d'égalité et notamment l'égalité fiscale
entre luxembourg et la france pour les
différents sujets que vous avez évoquées
vous avez aussi évoqué le chiffre
important de 105000 le travailleur
français frontaliers qui quotidiennement
travail au luxembourg
vous avez évoqué plusieurs accords
fiscaux avec la belgique avec la suisse
ou l'allemagne et il faut préciser vous
l'avez fait qu'à l'exception de l'accord
avec le canton de genève
ces accords une particularité dans le
sens oui le contreviennent aux standards
internationaux
les standards internationaux précise que
ce sont les états dans lesquels
travaillent telle ou telle personne qui
perçoivent l'impôt avec les pays que je
viens de citer la france perçoit l'impôt
sur les travailleurs frontaliers et
indemnise à due concurrence les états
dans lesquels ils travaillent
nous n'avons pas ce type d'accord avec
le luxembourg et c'est au coeur des
discussions vous avez évoqué nous avons
essayé de trouver d'autres solutions
notamment des solutions de financement
partagé des infrastructures et des
programmes de développement économique
le 20 mars 2018 un séminaire
intergouvernemental ses tenues s'est
traduit par l'adoption d'un protocole
d'accord ce proto de protocole d'accord
il faut le souligner a été ratifié par
une loi le 29 octobre dernier ce qui
nous permettra aussi d'avoir plus de
force dans son application
ce protocole prévoit le financement
d'infrastructures transport dans le nord
le rhin à hauteur de 240 millions
d'euros dont 120 millions financés par
luxembourg et nous veillons un point en
particulier c'est que ce protocole ne
vise pas à financer une opération parmi
d'autres comme ç'avait été le cas
précédemment avec la ligne à grande
vitesse mais bien un ensemble
d'aménagements structure on y compris du
ferroviaire pour aménager plus de
manière plus plus utile plus efficace le
nord le rhin nous ajoutons à ce
protocole concernant le financement d'un
programme d'infrastructures la volonté
d'une véritable coopération économique
il y a quelques jours amélie dimanche
alain secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes ainsi que jacqueline
gourault eu l'occasion d'ouvrir ces
discussions pour un protocole de
coopération avec l'appui de l'agencé
nationale des territoires
nous voulons que sur le financement des
infrastructures et sur le développement
économique
le partenariat soit là pour établir
l'égalité que vous attendez à voir une
coopération qui soit au bon niveau entre
la france et luxembourg
non non vous n'avez pas le rock et la
règle ses cinq secondes c'est la même
règle pour tout le monde la parole est
maintenant madame claudine kaufmann pour
un sénateur n'appartenant à aucun groupe
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé au delà des
clivages politiques partisans
nous nous accordons tous sur le droit
pour nos compatriotes a bénéficié d'un
régime de retraite juste et équitable
offrant à chacun la perspective d'une
vie digne
au terme de nombreuses années de labeur
si le candidat macron s'était engagé à
réformer les régimes de retraite tout en
préservant le futur niveau de vie des
personnes concernées
force est de constater que le président
qu'il est devenu a promptement oublier
cette promesse en effet sous couvert
d'une prétendue équité vous proposez que
désormais chaque euro cotisé offre les
mêmes droits et que toute période
travaillait même minime soit prise en
compte la réforme que vous défendez si
elle était adopté ferait ainsi
abstraction pour le calcul des pensions
des 25 meilleures années pour le privé
et des six derniers mois pour le public
il ne s'agit là que d'un nivellement par
le bas dont l'unique dessein est de
réduire drastiquement le niveau de
toutes les pensions vous feignez
d'ignorer en effet que tout au long
d'une vie professionnelle de plus de
quatre décennies s'enchaînent les
faibles mines rémunération les périodes
favorables les emplois précaires et
parfois aussi le chômage votre réforme
naboo dire la beauty rac à précariser
davantage les français les plus modestes
qui parvenu au soir de leur vie subiront
encore les affres de la pauvreté
de surcroît votre projet de réforme fait
totalement abstraction de la pénibilité
de certains emplois
en effet les salariés concernés ne
bénéficieront d'aucune compensation
votre vision de l'équité pour le moins
singulier
et cette réforme des retraites méprisant
la justice sociale porte toujours en
elle une inconnue la valeur du point
comment et sur quelle base allez vous
déterminez cette dernière et commencera
telles garanties contre toute baisse
je vous remercie vous réponds faire
parole et co commissaire aux retraites
délégué auprès de la ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur de le
voir dans la parole monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
avez raison de vous adresser
la ministre des solidarités car sous son
autorité le président de la république a
voulu que le projet de réforme des
retraites soit sue le site de la
solidarité
je vous remercie d'apporter votre
soutien
un régime équitable avec les mêmes
règles pour tous et qui a pour but de
corriger les inégalités du système
actuel sur l'autorité du premier
ministre nous proposons de faire en
sorte que dans un système de
redistribution validé par le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui fait que
le passage des 25 années à la totalité
de la carrière fait une redistribution
au profit des retraites des 40 % des
retraités les plus faibles c'est-à-dire
celles et ceux qui sont en dessous de
1200 à 1300 euros
nous avons aussi intégré la volonté les
françaises et des français de réduire
l'écart des pensions entre les hommes et
les femmes au profit des femmes qui est
actuellement de 40 % les propositions
que le formule ont fait que nous allons
réduire de 10 à 20 % c'est-à-dire la
moitié cet écart
nous avons aussi reçu le soutien de nos
concitoyens pour faire en sorte que dès
le premier enfant dès le premier enfant
il y est une majoration des pensions qui
fait que le nombre de femmes qui vont
bénéficier de cela va passer de 3
millions à 8 millions
nous avons aussi fait en sorte que le
système qui accompagne par point les
interruptions d'activité mais parcours
précaire ce que vous évoquez sont plus
favorables et que nous allons dans le
coefficient dans le rapport que j'ai
remis au président et au premier
ministre
il y as tu une réduction du coefficient
gini c'est à dire l'écart de pauvreté et
vous voyez bien que notre préoccupation
y compris pour la fonction publique
il confirme que la référence des six
derniers mois qui a été mise en place
alors qu'il n'y avait pas de prime
nous voulons faire un système plus juste
plus équitable plus transparent qui
correspond à nécessité de renforcer la
cohésion de la nation conclure merci
nous en avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité les prochaines auront lieu
mercredi 20 novembre à 15 heures je vais
suspendre la séance merci monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres et
nous reprendrons à 16h35 pour la suite
de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2020 la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin des questions au
gouvernement alors le secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale gabriel attal a été interpellé
à deux reprises par la gauche de
l'hémicycle sur la précarité des
étudiants
le sénateur communiste pierre ou julias
a dénoncé une baisse des moyens
financiers face à ce qu'il estime être
une crise majeure alors pour rappel
vendredi dernier un étudiant lyonnais 7
immolé la précarité
tu as donc rappelé l la sénatrice
socialiste maryvonne blondin qui
considère que les moyens financiers
accordés par l'état aux étudiants ne
sont pas suffisants surtout quand
d'autres viennent les plombé comme la
baisse des apl alors les échanges avec
le ministre on était beaucoup moins
tendue qu'à l'assemblée hier gabriel à
daha tall pardon s'est dit conscient
d'une réalité que l'état à je cite pris
à bras le corps et il a insisté sur un
chantier en cours le revenu à le revenu
universel d'activité qui fait
actuellement l'objet d'une concertation
le gouvernement a également été
interpellé par deux sénateurs sur le
séisme qui a touché l lundi la commune
du teil en ardèche
hier christophe castaner s'est rendu sur
place
écoutez ce qu'il a constaté
ce que j'ai constaté en particulier dans
le hameau de la rouvière comme dans la
commune du teil était bien au delà des
premières indications qui était remonté
en matière de dégâts sur les logements
au moment où je vous parle je pense que
le chiffre de 800 maisons directement
impactés concernés qui font l'objet de
fissures plus ou moins importantes sur
la seule commune du teil et la réalité
que nous sommes en train de constater un
bilan des dégâts à la hausse donc mais
aussi le risque d'un incident nucléaire
qui inquiète les sénateurs le ministre
de la ministre de la transition
écologique
elisabeth bornent à assurer je cite de
la vigilance totale du gouvernement et a
rappelé que tous les contrôles avaient
été mises en oeuvre concernant la
centrale de cruas situé à quelques
kilomètres de la commune du teil donc où
a eu lieu le séisme
voilà pour les temps forts de ces
questions d'actualité tout de suite le
débriefing avec vous tam et vos invités
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications et vous l'avez dit
effectivement cette séance a été marquée
un sûr c'est par ces deux questions
autour et bien du séisme qui s'est tenue
lundi et qui a eu aucun impact et des
soulevé des inquiétudes notamment sur
les questions du nucléaire on en a parlé
au début de cette émission vous l'avez
dit aussi il a été question de la
contestation étudiante tout à l'heure
j'ai xavier arnaud vous êtes toujours
avec nous que penser et bien de la
réponse du gouvernement le gouvernement
qui cherche à dire qu'il est à la
hauteur de la crise qui fait valoir et
bien sa lutte contre la pauvreté des
étudiants et ils pourvoient la hauteur
ce que je trouve intéressant déjà en
termes de en termes de communication
c'est le choix de la personne qui répond
que ce soit hier ou aujourd'hui il ya un
gouvernement
évidemment un premier ministre il ya un
gouvernement une ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur on est sur une
question
qui touche aux étudiants et c'est le
secrétaire d'état pour donner les titres
des déserts les autres le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse donc
gabriela talent qui répond donc une
volonté de la part du gouvernement de
faire de gabriella talent le visage et
la voix du gouvernement sur tous les
sujets liés à la jeunesse
c'est un c'est un choix en soit c'est
une forme déjà je trouve de promotion
politique pour gagner à la table qui se
retrouve donc à porter la parole du
coccyx gouvernementale sur un sujet à
mon avis majeur et potentiellement
extrêmement crisogène mais c'est
étonnant de donner la parole à à
frédéric vidal sur ces sujets on
pourrait objectivement attendre que ce
soit frédéric vidal voir le premier
ministre sur ce genre de sujet qui
prennent la parole je pense que le fait
que ce ne soit pas le pré ministre est
assez logique à ce stade puisque on sait
qu'on arrive dans une séquence en terme
de crise qui va être à la fois à la fois
protéiforme et potentiellement assez
violente donc je pense que le président
de la république et le p le prêt
ministres sont un petit peu en réserve
de la république si si j'ose dire sur le
plan la communication en revanche c'est
vrai que j'aurais légitimement attendu
que ce soit frédéric vidal qui s'exprime
sur le sujet d'événements en lien avec
l'université donc avec son son
portefeuille ministériel
c'est visible en capital qui sera en
charge de en charge de 2,2 de défendre
là le gouvernement sur ce dossier
c'est à profit le jeune c'est un profil
qui qui travaillent sur les sujets en
lien avec la jeunesse pas théoriquement
sur l'université sur les étudiants c'est
aujourd'hui a ajouté à son à son champ
d'action oui à gabriel attal qui est
d'ailleurs revenu sur le fait que le
gouvernement réfléchissait au revenu
universel d'activité bon ce n'est qu'une
réflexion ce n'est pas vraiment une
annonce à ce que ça peut suffire à faire
taire la grogne étudiante sans doute pas
le sujet est encore jeune tant pour les
médias les étudiants que pour le
gouvernement qui j'imagine est en train
de plancher sur des solutions et des
réponses
à cette crise comme on dit tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important pour eux d'endiguer la crise
avant qu'elle ne prenne de l'ampleur et
qu'on arrive sur ce fameux risque de
convergence des luttes à la date que
tout va bien en tête du 5 décembre
en revanche oui je sais si si la réponse
que le gouvernement entend entend donner
est uniquement celle ci je ne pense pas
que ce sera de nature à calmer le
mouvement étudiant je rappelle tout de
même que on a maintenant des choses
assez violente que ce soit ce qui s'est
passé au ministère où ce qui s'est passé
à lille en marge d'une conférence
hollande qui n'a d'ailleurs pas eu lieu
je ne pense pas que ce genre de
d'annonce suffira à calmer la colère des
étudiants
parce que c'est une contestation envers
le gouvernement en place ou beaucoup
plus large
quand on voit justement et bien que hier
les étudiants ont empêché la tenue de
cette conférence de françois hollande
aux cris de notamment hollande assassin
on a un sentiment qu'il ya le rejet
d'une politique qui n'a pas été à la
hauteur pour la jeunesse et pour les
étudiants mais cela depuis déjà un an
c'est peut-être la chance du
gouvernement dans cette affaire la
chance du gouvernement c'est qu'il
semblerait que la perception des
étudiants soit que le sujet du pouvoir
d'achat des étudiants et la précarité
des étudiants soit un sujet qui remonte
bien au delà du cardinal emmanuel macron
donc aujourd'hui certain milieu de
macron fait partie des personnalités
critiquer mais il n'est pas le
responsable unique ce n'est pas sa
politique uniquement qui est pointé du
doigt
donc charge maintenant au gouvernement
de trouver des réponses
mais ce qui est certain c'est que quand
on écoute un petit peu ce qui ce qui se
dit dans les manifestations quand on
regarde les pancartes et slogans
grosso modo on est sur des reproches qui
débute à nicolas sarkozy se poursuivre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui qui inclut
évidemment donc françois hollande mais
on ne peut pas dire que ce soit l'action
emmanuel macron et uniquement l'action
dame une dernière macron qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui sanctionné par ses
manifestations
et finalement c'est qu'encore une fois
peut-être la chance du président la
république et du gouvernement que de ne
pas être l'unique cible de la
contestation
charge à eux de retourner les choses
gabriella thales et bêtes ne dirai plus
tôt dans l'après midi ont fait valoir m
mesures du gouvernement en faveur de la
pauvreté étudiante 5,7 milliards d aides
aux étudiants la suppression du régime
étudiant de sécurité sociale le fait
qu'il n'y pas eu de hausse de frais de
scolarité plus 46 millions d'euros à
10,6 bête ndiaye sur les bourses mais
finalement c'est plus 1,1 pour cent ça
représente à peu près l'inflation est ce
que est ce que c'est suffisant parce
qu'en même temps vous l'avez dit ce
gouvernement il est aussi associé et
bien à la baisse des apl d'une forme de
péché originel est ce que ça rattrape
finalement on entend beaucoup ce qu ont
fermé parce qu'on gagne le tempo pendant
sept péchés originels et à mon avis est
à mon avis très juste l'injustice étant
à côté de ça qu'en effet il serait tout
à fait faux de dire que le bis que le
gouvernement n'a pas de bilan ce sujet
ce péché originel justement sur les apl
année gouvernement à agir et il vient
bien et bien justement on va écouter à
gabriel attal qui tient actuellement un
point presse salle des conférences du
sénat
tout de suite on écoute donc le
sécrétaire d'état gabriela talent de ce
jeune et moi c'est lui qui est encore
entre la vie et la mort à ses proches à
la communauté universitaire et aux
étudiants qui sont ses camarades à à
lyon que je pense aujourd'hui à une
émotion suite à ce drame et suit aussi
conditions de précarité très fort ce que
cet étudiant visait qui est née à la
suite de cet acte il faut l'entendre
évidemment nous la partageons ça fait
deux ans maintenant que nous travaillons
sur cette question des conditions de vie
des étudiants avec des mesures très
fortes qui ont été prises je pense à la
suppression de la cotisation sécurité
sociale c'était 217 euros que devait
payer les étudiants à chaque rentrée
cette cotisation a été supprimée en 2018
je pense à 46 millions d'euros
d'augmentation des bourses qui ont été
annoncés il ya maintenant deux mois je
pense à des mesures sur la construction
de logements qui sont en cours ces
mesures sont fortes on sait qu'il reste
des étudiants qui sont dans la
difficulté qui sont dans la précarité et
l'enjeu pour nous c'est évidemment de
continuer à avancer d'apporter une
réponse structurante
il ya une perspective qui est le
chantier sur le revenu universel
d'activité chantier qui a été lancé par
le président de la république
précisément pour répondre aux enjeux de
précarité de pauvreté dans le pays et il
a été décidé de mettre en place un
collège dédié à la question des jeunes
dans ce revenu universel d'activités
aussi pour nous permettre d'interroger
la manière dont sont accompagnés les
jeunes aujourd'hui les organisations
étudiantes font partie de ce collège
on échange régulièrement avec elle et
dans le cadre du mouvement qui est
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs universités
dans le cadre de la mobilisation qui a
été engagé le premier ministre m'a
demandé de recevoir au plus vite les
organisations étudiants faire un point
avec elle pour échanger avec elles pour
avancer avec elle et donc à partir de
demain matin je les recevrai donc le
gouvernement n'a pas de responsabilité
dans cette précarité étudiante depuis
deux ans le gouvernement il agit depuis
deux ans pour répondre à cette situation
de précarité
d'ailleurs les gouvernements qui se sont
succédé ont toujours cherché à prendre
ce sujet à bras le corps parce que c'est
une réalité dans notre pays et une
précarité étudiante ya une misère
étudiante vous avez des étudiants
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont obligés de
travailler pour financer leurs études
vous avez des boursiers qui n'y arrivent
pas et le sens de nos mesures
depuis deux ans vise à répondre à cet
enjeu là j'entends parfaitement qu' on
puisse considérer que ça n'est pas
suffisant qu'il faille faire
davantage et encore une fois ce chantier
sur le revenu universel d'activité doit
permettre d'apporter une réponse
structurante que ce soit dans le cadre
du revenu universel d'activité ou dans
le cadre d'adaptation de nos dispositifs
si on vous écoute les étudiants est
aujourd'hui ont des raisons légitimes
moi j'entends parfaitement à la fois
l'émotion suscitée par ce qui s'est
passé à lyon vendredi dernier et
j'entends parfaitement et pour me
déplacer beaucoup sur le terrain
échanger avec les jeunes j'entends
parfaitement aussi les difficultés dans
lesquelles vivent beaucoup de jeunes
aujourd'hui ce que je cherche à dire
c'est que l'ensemble des mesures que
nous avons prises depuis deux ans vise à
répondre à cet enjeu là et c'est un
enjeu on continue à défendre sur lequel
on continue à travailler notamment
s'agissant du logement
on sait que c'est moi j'ai absolument
fondamental c'est 60 70 % du budget des
étudiants continuent à avancer sur ce
volet-là une fois que nous ferons avec
les organisations étudiantes nous
permettra aussi de faire un point sur
l'ensemble de ces rencontres demain
concrètement
vous voulez quoi leur répéter ce qui est
déjà fait parce que la revendication on
les connaît les enfants pas
régulièrement dans qu'est ce qui peut
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre de nouveau
l'enjeu c'est de faire un point d'étape
sur les chantiers qui ont été engagées
avec elle
et encore une fois sur le chantier qui
est en cours du revenu universel
d'activité est globalement de l'ensemble
de l'accompagnement déjà dans ce cadre
là on va avancer c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis en place un collège dédié à la
question de l'accompagnement social des
jeunes c'est important les ententes de
voir comment est-ce qu'elle envisage ce
chantier là les propositions qui sont
les leurs un dynamique d'ecoute
d'ouverture qui est la nôtre aura
régulièrement les organisations
étudiantes j'étais avec la présidente de
l'unef ya quelques semaines présidente
de la fage
évidemment c'est dans cette logique
d'ouverture et dialogues qu'on avance
concernant les violences lors de ces
manifestations est ce que la liberté
d'expression dans les universités est en
danger aujourd'hui c'était moi je fais
bien à la part des choses il ya un
malaise une émotion qui a été suscitée
par ce qui s'est passé à lyon puis à des
violences et je lance d'ailleurs qu'on
avait vu se multiplier avant même cette
situation je pense à la conférence de
sylviane agacinski je pense à la
conférence sur la radicalisation qui
avait dû être annulée à cause de ces
violences
nous nous condamnons les violences peut
pas accepter qu'il y ait des violences
encore une fois mais y avoir des
revendications peut y avoir des
mobilisations c'est totalement légitime
et c'est ça la démocratie
mais on ne peut pas accepter les
violences et évidemment on les condamne
très fortement
des manifestations étudiantes de la
colère des étudiants avec les grèves du
5 décembre prochain vous avez des
organisations étudiantes très politisé à
l'extrême gauche qui appelait déjà à une
convergence à une mobilisation le 5
décembre depuis plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois
ma conviction c'est que les étudiants
dans leur grande majorité ils attendent
qu'on avance on avance évidemment sur la
question de leurs conditions de vie sur
la place de l'enseignement supérieur
dans notre pays c'est ça qui guide
aujourd'hui notre action merci
voilà donc pour ce point presse qu'a
tenus le secrétaire d'état gabriela
talent jean clavier arnaud on a entendu
les éléments de langage du gouvernement
il entend l'émotion c'est un
gouvernement à l'ecoute en même temps il
condamne les violences
et demain il va donc faire un point
d'étape avec les organisations
étudiantes
il va donc bien entendre de plus près
leurs revendications au delà du travail
qu'il annonce sur le sujet moi encore
une fois ce que je suis ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est le rôle que son
prendre gabriela talent dans ce
gouvernement
quand on voit qu'il ya ce point presse
on voit sur l'écran écrit secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
l'impression que ça donne surtout quand
on voit les sujets qui l'a traité quand
on voit ce qu'ils traitent aujourd'hui
et l'amiens ac il est très amer des
portes qu'à parole du gouvernement c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est le jeune
chef bancaire ça évidemment qu'un sujet
mais il ya aussi un ministre de la
jeunesse et ça c'est gabriel à talant
tout casser je trouve dans son
expression et dans sa manière de se
saisir de ces sujets l'impression que
donne que qu'il donne aujourd'hui encore
ce qu'on pressent alors jean xavier on
va passer à tout autre chose puisque
aujourd'hui également et bien est décédé
raymond poulidor ans et est l'éternel
second du tour de france mais qui
restera néanmoins dans la postérité et
donc alexandre plus ça justement pour
revenir et bien sûr cette disparition
vous êtes avec la ministre des sports
roxana maracineanu elle est à votre
micro et bien pour rendre hommage à ce
grand champion du cyclisme
mais oui roxana maracineanu votre
réaction à cette disparition de raymond
poulidor poupou légende du cyclisme
français
votre réaction en tant que ministre des
sports écoutez on est très tristes de
cette disparition et et nous adressons
nos condoléances à gisèle son épouse ses
enfants ses petits-enfants bien sûr
raymond poulidor était un symbole de ce
sport tellement aimé par les français le
cyclisme il ya
près de deux millions de personnes qui
font du vélo en france il ya aussi ce
tour de france dont il était le symbole
parmi d'autres grands coureurs mais qui
qui qui donne une unité à la france
chaque été
qui rassemble tout autant de pratiquants
que d'amateurs de ce spectacle sportif
du tour de france devant les télévisions
et je pense qu'il ya toute une
génération qui est très triste
aujourd'hui de cette disparition alors
raymond poulidor était aussi aimé par
les français car c'est un peu l'éternel
second c'était son surnom les valeurs
qu'il représente est est ce que c'est un
exemple aujourd'hui pour les jeunes
cyclistes français c'est vrai qu'il a
été rarement vainqueur mais toujours
plein de d'humanité toujours un exemple
de persévérance d'humilité dans la
performance est quelque part c'est
peut-être lui aussi qui réconcilie les
français avec cette notion d'élitisme
porté par le sport en france et c'est
pour ça aussi que il était le sportif
français par excellence et il a fini par
incarner le sport français justement
dans cette manière de mettre en avant un
peu plus le chemin vers la performance
que le résultat en lui-même est ce qu'on
peut avoir aujourd'hui dans le cyclisme
français un nouveau poulidor on a
l'impression quand même que l'image du
cyclisme est un peu écornée on a vu le
dernier tour de france renaître un peu
des duels entre français avec bardet
avec pino qui étaient là nos deux
français qui ont nous ont tenu en
haleine pendant tout un mois donc on
voit que ce tour de france qui a fait
naître quand même l'information sportive
en france et même l'information tout
court puisque les français ont regardé
les journaux télévisés grâce au tour de
france et bien voir naître aujourd'hui
une adversité franco française qui donne
du pep's à 7 à cette compétition qui
maintenant a été exportée dans nombre de
pays mais qui reste quand même une
spécificité française et qui montre
l'amour des français pour le cyclisme et
pour le sport très bien merci beaucoup
roxana maracineanu pour votre réaction
c'est à vous tous merci beaucoup
alexandre pour cet hommage à un grand
champion a ainsi sur ce plateau on dit
qu'il faut pas seulement retenir qu'il a
été second il a aussi gagné des courses
alors on va qu'on commençait le débrief
de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement avec trois invités qui nous
ont rejoints nathalie goulet bonjour je
sénateurs us
de l'ordre merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous également sur ce plateau
rachid tu es mal sénateur ps du
val-d'oise et également avec nous
françois grosdidier sénateurs et l'air
de la moselle et nous allons tout
d'abord revenir sur et bien ce point
presque vient de tenir à l'instant
gabriela talent ça a été aussi deux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tout à l'heure sur la précarité
étudiante françois grosdidier ce que
vous avez jugé la réponse du
gouvernement à la hauteur donc demain il
va gagner at elle va faire un point
d'étape avec des organisations
étudiantes le gouvernement fait valoir
bien la politique qu'il a menée depuis
deux ans et se dit à l'écouté entendre
les difficultés des étudiants
oui à la hauteur non ils pouvaient pas
forcément elle est instantanément
on a un immense problème effectivement
avec des entrées en masse dans les
universités et on a des vagues yachts
seront posées la droite et la gauche sur
l'absence totale de sélection à l'entrée
de l'université avec des étudiants qui
sont nombreux à être acceptés mais qui
sont globalement très mal traités et qui
assure avec de grandes difficultés
parfois leur survie pendant leur année
universitaire et avec une difficulté
compliquée encore par la nécessité de
travailler à côté de trouver de l'argent
donc on a tous un système qui à
reprendre qui s'en posent en peut-être
même des questions tabous c'est pas en
quelques jours que ça peut se faire
mais aujourd'hui la condition des
étudiants est très difficile dans notre
pays dans un contexte dire la limite de
l'explosion sociale en permanence
équipements on a eu des premiers
débordements on risque d'en avoir
d'autres qui ne règleront rien mais qui
sont à craindre
justement sur ces débordements rachid tu
es mal il y a eu notamment hier françois
hollande qui n'a pas pu tenir sa
conférence inquiète est prévue à
l'université de lille il y a eu aussi et
bien le
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
qui a été envahi par des étudiants tout
cela c'est quand même un climat de
violence un climat un peu compliqué
insurrectionnelle il ya deux choses
c'est d'abord sur au moins j'ai une
pensée pour la famille les proches du
jeune qui comme s'est immolé il faut
imaginer ce que ça veut dire
la première violence a été celle là et
c'était ce cri d'alarmé
l'info faut imaginer ce que ça veut dire
pour ce jeune là et donc pour ses
proches dire ensuite qu'effectivement la
précarité du monde étudiant c'est un
débat qui est long chaque vraiment
essayé d'apporter des solutions que ce
qui est clair c'est que deux sous
gréement là manifestement les réponses
ne signe le compte n'y est pas quand on
sait que 70 % du budget étudiant c'est
sur le logement
bien que c'est là d'abord et avant tout
que doit porter l'urgence et il n'y a
pas dans ce pays de politique à ce
niveau là que ce soit d'ailleurs le bâti
en général et sur les étudiants donc ça
c'est chose donc c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut avoir des réponses des loyers dans
les villes universitaires l'encadrement
du gouvernement mais moi je suis pour
l'encadrement on l'a votée mais je
rappelle que par exemple le ministre
annonce pour le sm eu un peu plus d'un
milliard d'euros service national
universel de boue de sur la table je
pense que peut-être qu'il faut voir les
priorités différemment et peut-être que
ce 1 milliard d'euros par an peut-être
me pour la question d'étudiants ensuite
sur votre question pour ya un climat
effectivement vous et on pourrait
ajouter dans votre liste madame agapes
agacinski qui n'a pas pu tenir sa sa
conférence monsieur sifaoui également et
c'est parce que de quelques universitas
qui est depuis deux ans si vous avez
dans ce pays une volonté du pouvoir de
ne plus du tout parler avec les corps
intermédiaires
donc ce qu'on disait depuis le début a
abandonné mais quand intermédiaires ont
un rôle à jouer dans la démocratie
parfois de cadres et que c'est quand
vous n'avez plus cela est vraiment ce
sentiment
une société fragmentée fracturée et que
la violence n'est que le seul recours
pour être entendus et je terminerai sur
la jeunesse il je rappelle que par
exemple sur l'assurance chômage qui
rentrent en application depuis le 1er
novembre
la question de l'entrée dans le monde de
l'emploi pour la jeunesse puisque
maintenant c'est plus quatre mois pour
avoir droit à une allocation
chômage mais six mois sur les 26 mois
sur les 24 mois pardon ce qui va être là
ils se disent en étant étudiant c'est
difficile et violents pour ce pour se
loger pour se nourrir mais quand je vais
chercher le boulot si je ne trouve pas
ça va être également violent
nathalie goulet un mot sur cette
violence époux effectivement le fait que
j'ai eu tous ces problèmes dans
l'université le entre bien la conférence
de sylviane agacinski mohamed sifaoui et
puis désormais françois lang est ce que
tu déjà pour vous ce sont des situations
que d'un sursis feu oui il a il a une
voix qui a lui-même il a indiqué lui
même qui l'avait pas tout à fait dit la
vérité mais ça c'est pas grave non mais
il ya une intolérance manifeste on voit
bien que est rachetée mais la raison je
dire a priori la violence n'est plus que
la seule solution mais ça ça émane aussi
eu des réseaux sociaux ça émane d'une
société complètement écorché saemann de
gens qui s'écoute absolument page et
vous pouvez pas avoir un débat rationnel
je vous parle pas de l'islam vers le bas
on parlera de la va vous pouvez pas
avoir un discours rationnel donc comment
voulez vous que les gens s'expriment
si déjà ce qu'il montre l'exemple n'ont
pas de respect les uns pour les autres
en tout cas il ya un dialogue qui est
amorcée avec les organisations
étudiantes puisque demain elles vont
rencontrer le secrétaire d'état qu'en
pense maryvonne blondin l'état votre
micro alexandre poussard est-ce que et
bien ça c'est tout de même une porte
ouverte par le gouvernement à un début
de dialogue qui est amorcé oui maryvonne
blondin
il ya un début de dialogue entre le
gouvernement et les assurent les
associations étudiantes pardon c'est une
bonne nouvelle selon vassili à un début
c'est déjà ça il faut déjà dialoguer
discuter échanger connaître les
positions des uns et des autres et
essayer d'apporter des solutions surtout
vous avez interrogé le ministre gabriela
talent durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité
dans sa réponse on a quand même
l'impression que le gouvernement va
continuer sa politique
la bossa c'est un peu ça il n'a rien dit
nous faut il persiste à redire ce qui a
été mise en place
moi je crois qu'il est important que
véritablement cette discussion cet
échange avec
avec les associations et autres puissent
aboutir à une refonte globale de des
aides qui sont apportées parce qu'il y
en a mais elles ne sont pas suffisantes
et quand on regarde un peu le parcours
de l'étudiant est quand même conditionné
à la catégorie sociale de ses parents et
on s'en aperçoit de plus en plus parce
que si l'étudiant veut poursuivre des
études à paris le coût du logement à
paris est totalement différent de celui
de la bretagne dont je suis originaire
et l'accompagnement est beaucoup plus
difficile pour lui et il doit évidemment
payer en plus sa mobilité ces transports
alors il faut refondre ses aides pour
les étudiants mais ce qu'il faut aussi
mettre plus d'argent sur la table avec
des moyens supplémentaires
normalement il faut dresser dans le
budget justement qu'on devrait retrouver
la traduction de ces mesures qui doivent
être à la hauteur de la demande mais
aussi je crois qu'il ya d'autres choses
que de le financement il serait
important d'accompagner d'accompagner
les étudiants et je peux donner un
exemple de ce qui se passe à l'ubo de
brest
il y à un accompagnement à l'accueil des
étudiants lors de leur toute première
année et c'est pas un accompagnement
d'une de trois heures d'une demi journée
c'est un accompagnement qui se fait tout
au long du trimestre tout au long de
l'année avec des ateliers de formation
qui leur permettent de bien choisir leur
orientation et c'est une compagne mans
de lutte contre l'échec et ça c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant et qui
peut-être ne demande pas plus d'argent à
bien l'accompagnement des étudiants une
partie de la solution merci beaucoup
maryvonne blondin d'avoir répondu à la
question
merci alexandre pour cette nouvelle
réaction va passer un deuxième thème qui
a marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement ce deuxième
thème est bien c est la manifestation
contre l'islamophobie qui s'est tenue
dimanche christophe castaner a été
interrogé sur ce sujet on écoute tout de
suite c'est bien sa réponse dans
l'hémicycle fait que ce soit construit
sur un appel un appel qui dénonce
pêle-mêle des lois liberticides le
silence complice des institutions
étatiques chargées de lutter contre le
racisme les délations abusif jusqu'au
plus haut niveau de l'état contre des
musulmans dont le seul tort serait
l'appartenance réelle ou supposée à une
religion ou encore les dispositifs de
surveillance de masse qui conduisent à
une criminalisation pure et simple de la
pratique religieuse se rendent au fond
complice des menaces qui pèsent sur la
république et nous serons madame la
sénatrice totalement engagée à vos côtés
aux côtés des sénateurs pour faire en
sorte que cette laïcité qui n'est pas ni
provocatrice ni au fond rejeté ne soit
pas non plus naïveté et nous devons au
contraire faire en sorte que pour chaque
valeur qui serait mise en cause par ceux
qui aujourd'hui au nom de la religion
considère qu'il y aurait un intérêt
supérieur à ce qui nous rassemble nous
puissions tous ensemble qu'on battre
pied à pied pour que la république soit
partout chez elle merci monsieur le
minervois là pour cette réponse du
ministre de l'intérieur tout à l'heure
il était interrogé par françoise laborde
sur la question de la laïcité et surtout
autour de cette manifestation qui s'est
tenue dimanche une manifestation qui a
été marqué par une image françois
grosdidier une image qui a choqué celle
de manifestants et notamment une petite
fille
arborant une étoile jaune à côté
d'ailleurs de la sénatrice esther
benbassa c'est un symbole c'est un
parallèle qui pour vous choquant chez
qui est scandaleux même coûté au départ
la manifestation n'aurait pu tout s'y
retrouver si ç'avait été une
manifestation contre l'islamophobie
après l'attaqué de la mosquée de bayonne
comme on a manifesté les uns et les
autres contre l'antisémitisme
après des agressions de l'ère moderne
bien sûr ça aurait salon est due à
serait que nationale quand on appelle à
manifester contre les lois de la
république
kaka quand quand on veut faire croire
que la république française traite
aujourd'hui les musulmans comme l'état
français a traité les juifs en les
arrêtant
les amener dans des camps de
concentration c'est juste un amalgame
insupportable et qui dessert les
musulmans et qui ne permet pas de
combattre l'islamophobie qui existent
que je ne nie pas et qui est président
est une phobie
c'est à dire même pas une idéologie
construite comme un sémitisme mais une
phobie c'est une peur irrationnelle et
bien sûr qu'elles existent parce que le
terrorisme veut faire peur il parvient à
faire ça et donc c'est ce qu'il faut
combattre comme il faut combattre
l'amalgamé entre terroristes islamistes
et musulmans mais je reste vraiment là
les organisateurs ont tout fait pour
qu'on amalgame tout et qu'on mélange
tout et en insultant la république
française nathalie goulet effectivement
il y avait d'abord et bien l'intitulé de
cette manifestation et puis il ya eu
l'organisation qui a créé la polémique
dès sa conception avec notamment des
proches des frères musulmans dans
l'organisation donc c'était une
manifestation déjà fait d'amalgamés déjà
très compliquée mais l'amalgamme c'est
le lot de tous ces sujets vous vous
rendez bien compte que à partir du
moment où le texte de la pétition était
déjà quand même assez orienté alors que
le sujet le mérite
bon alors on n'est pas d'accord sur
l'islamophobie c'est pas le bon nom
c'est pas le bon mot c'est pas le bon
moment mais il ya quand même un problème
avec les musulmans en france
discrimination il ya des problèmes
oui mosquée attaquée et c'est donc c'est
un sujet sur lequel tous les
républicains doivent se retrouver car
l'islam a toute sa place dans la
république certains à la manifestation
avait été sincère la laque à la conduite
et tout le monde part du même principe
on a d'ailleurs eu cette mission
d'information au sénat avec mon collègue
andré reichardt ya deux ans et on rien
n'a été fait depuis donc notre rapport
est toujours d'actualité
une publicité au passage c'est quand
même religion de s'adapter à l'état et
pas le contraire une fois qu'on est
parti là dessus l'état doit protéger
l'ensemble des citoyens quelle que soit
leur confession donc oui effectivement
il ya eu des débordements et c'est
regrettable
un rachété mal le parti socialiste
finale finalement a décidé de ne pas
participer à cette manifestation
contrairement à un certain nombre bien
d'élus qui ont hésité qui ont
rétropédaler dans l'aride est dit
et effectivement c'est parce qu'il y
avait le but initial et finalement le
déroulement on vous dit s'il n'a pas
finalement non non mais finalement le
parent soliste à considérer qu'ils
n'avaient pas participé à cette mutation
du fait de l'appel et du contenu de
l'appel
c'est des choses soient claires il ya
deux choses il fait attention à ne pas
tout mélanger je crois que dans la
discussion qu'on a eue lors des cages et
c'est dommage qu'ils appellent ce mot là
je pense qu'à une première chose qu'il
faut dire et je pense que c'est aux plus
hautes autorités de l'état de lui dire
c'est que la république doit protéger
tous ses concitoyens et que doit
dénoncer quand il ya des actes anti
musulmans et il y en a eu il ya des
paroles et donc je pense que nos
concitoyens musulmans où qu'ils se
déclarent comme etc chacun fait comme le
souhait d'inclure française je pense
attendre cette panne
cette parole forte et ce mouvement et je
pense que les partis républicains
devraient c'est une proposition devrait
avoir amendé un an de rassemblement pour
dire effectivement qu'on ne peut
accepter entre pays des discriminations
des actes vous fêtez la reguera
d'ailleurs non moi j'ai pas souhaité
lawrence et j'ai dit je sois bien clair
j'ai dit il serait bien je lance un
appel aux partis politiques aux
associations pour qui et cela parce que
si c'est effectivement une manifestion
républicaine qui dit la république
protège l'ensemble sonne et en l'espèce
dans le cas présent face à des actes
anti-musulmans je pensais pas là une
manifestion parce que dans la gestion et
je viens à celle de dimanche
moi je n'y c'était ni génie j'ai décidé
la peine et je me suis rendu mais il ya
des gens avec qui vous connaissent et
qui vous parle il ya des gens qui sont
rendus à cette manifestation
parce qu'il considère qu'il ya ce
sentiment là et ils sont de fait
manipuler où ils tombent entre les
grives et de gens qu'ils organisent donc
si nous ne voulons pas nous laisser la
ruche laisser aux aux citoyens ce
sentiment dire nous ce qu'ils ont fait
cette appellation sommes les seuls à
pouvoir vous protéger il faut que ce
soit de la république française qu'ils
le fassent don voilà sont deux africains
d'être aligné donc moi je conserve
encore une fois il est important de
rappeler la laïcité en france tout a été
réglé les citer mais les apportons aussi
dire très clairement il y à des actes
anti-musulmans la clique doit dois dire
que ce n'est pas acceptable et doit
prendre les mesures en l'espèce je crois
que ses deux jambes sur lequel nous
devons marcher on fait tout de suite
un petit détour par la salle des
conférences alexandre poussin vous êtes
avec françoise laborde car c'est elle
qui a tout à l'heure interpellé le
ministre de l'intérieur
oui françoise laborde justement est-ce
que vous pensez que la classe politique
les responsables politiques font assez
aujourd'hui pour dénoncer les actes anti
musulmans
alors est ce qu'ils font assez je pense
que oui si les actes anti musulmans
il ya des plaintes qui sont déposées et
c'est je crois qu'il y à un certain
nombre de chose faite aujourd'hui
je suppose que vous faites référence à
ce qui s'est passé récemment donc la
manifestation est ce que la classe
politique doit accompagner ce genre de
manifestation je n'en suis pas sûr
ce qu'on appelle
l'islamophobie pour moi est un terme que
l'on emploie essentiellement pour
l'islam est ce que vous avez déjà
entendu parler de christianophobie ou de
choses comme ça donc
l'islam est une religion comme les
autres on croit ou on ne croit pas c'est
un droit que l'on a encore en république
en france et cette islamophobie ce terme
qui est monté en épingle depuis
plusieurs années qui a une définition
bien sûr islamophobie on peut le
comprendre mais je trouve qu'il est
utilisé un petit peu à tort et à travers
je ne remets pas en question s'il y a
des personnes musulmanes qui sont
malmenés je comprends et je les défends
alors pourquoi remettre
finalement un peu en doute ce terme
d'islamophobie alors que là c'était
parti d'un attentat sur la mosquée de
bayonne alors que par exemple quand il
ya un attentat sur la communauté juive
on ne remet pas du tout en doute le
terme d' antisémitisme alors l'appel a
été un peu différent vous avez vu comme
moi un certain nombre d'appels qui
étaient très divers qui faisait un
amalgame ce qu'il faut appeler les
choses par rapport à des lois soit 10
ans liberticide 1 celle de 2004 à
l'école celle de 2010 sur l'interdiction
d'avoir le visage couvert dans l'espace
public et ça a été des choses qui ont
été remises en question bien sûr
récemment il y a eu le texte sur les
sorties scolaires et je crois que ça a
remis et quand vous faites tout cela
dans une seule manifestation et en dix
ans finalement on a le droit ou voilà
oui bien sûr quand tu as le droit aux
voiles
à cet endroit comme tu as le droit à la
kippa comme talent dans la croix mais il
faut être très attentif à ce qu'on
l'appelle quand on appelle à une
manifestation et 6 mai pour moi mais là
c'est en tant que françoise laborde
c'était à ses limites très bien merci
beaucoup françoise laborde pour votre
réponse
merci beaucoup alexandrins derniers mois
jean de fabiano sur ce thème comment
imaginer qu'on a pu arriver avec un
sujet tel que la stigmatisation des
musulmans la haine anti musulmans à une
manifestation aussi à polémiquer à une
telle à une telle polémique finalement
comme vous dites on ou non pas d'une
d'une manifestation contre
l'islamophobie pour arriver finalement à
une manifestation contre les fautes de
l'état renversé envers les musulmans
ce qui est évidemment une logique
extrêmement différente et a fortiori
quand on voit les mots et surtout les
images qui ressortent de cette
manifestation et ce qui est terrible
c'est que à n'en pas douter au dimanche
il y avait énormément de gens qui
étaient là pour manifester contre
l'islamophobie
oui car dans leur personne personne ne
le retiendra plus personne aujourd'hui
ni sur ce plateau ni à l'assemblée ne
parle réellement il le sujet n'est plus
réellement l'islam bruit on en parle
mais le supplément par la zone aurifère
sur le plateau le sur le sujet le sujet
aujourd'hui je suis désolé et plus la
nation d'une manifestation qui a
dégénéré que l'islamophobie et devait
normalement aujourd'hui on parle de quoi
non nous parler de nous vous en parlez
là vous avez ici avec nous on a bien
parlé des actes anti-musulmans qu'on
doit condamner et on a fait les 2 2 et 3
la voilà tous les trois d'une enquête la
question qui se posera c'est
effectivement à ce que ça sera audible
sa part présenté est ce que ce sera
meilleur voilà bon voilà en tout cas
pour ce sujet on va passer à un
troisième thème qui a marqué cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement notamment le début de cette
gouvernement ne pouvons pas oublier que
nous sommes quatre ans jour pour jour
après l'attentât du bataclan écoutez et
bien ce qu'on a dit à gérard larcher en
ouverture de cette séance
nous devons garder en mémoire cette
journée si douloureuse pour d'autres
pays et nous a renforcés dans notre
détermination à rester résolus et unis
face à la menace terroriste est à
défendre plus que jamais les valeurs de
la république que nous avons en partage
en ce jour anniversaire de pensées vont
même si le temps semblait passé vers les
victimes de ces attentats leurs familles
et leurs proches en leur souvenir en
leur hommage
je vous invite à observer un court
moment de recueillement
ne pas oublier même si c'était il y a 4
eur ht mal on imagine que vous n'oubliez
pas vous qui étiez et bien au stade de
france le 13 novembre 2015 et à quelques
mètres d'un terroriste qui s'est fait
exploser oui c'est est ce qu'on appelle
une victime directe
effectivement j'ai je me suis retrouvé à
terre donc après ce qu'il était à
quelques mètres de moi
il est passé piette un peu plus loin moi
je n'oublie pas effectivement de fait
pour être une victime mais je ne lis pas
effectivement c'était ceux qui ont eu
beaucoup moins de chance que moi qui ont
perdu la vie ou qui ont une vie
totalement différente aujourd'hui donc
oui c'est un souvenir chaque 13 décembre
et moi ça me renforce dans ma conviction
profonde qui est qu'aujourd'hui la cité
française des fractures et et je crois
quand on est haut responsable politique
il faut veiller toujours à essayer de
olaroz coudre ne jamais laisser comme ça
c'est de cette violence cette fracture
aller plus loin donc eu et je trouvais
ça bien et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs j'ai
remercié le président larcher
voilà parce que c'était bien que nous
démarrions aujourd'hui je crois qu'il
faut l'avoir en tête et en n'oubliant
pas jouera il faut le dire les trois
lieux
le stade de france
moi j'étais où ça démarre et les
terrasses et le bataclan on a
aujourd'hui trop souvent l'impression
que sur le bataclan encore une fois
c'est pas une concurrence je dis juste
que pour les pour les victimes pour leur
famille il faut se rappeler de ces trois
lieux des terrasses du bataclan du stade
de france et surtout dire que encore une
fois il fort coup la cité française
remettre du lien
il faut être totalement déterminés face
à ces de ceux qui ont souhaité en fait
abattre autres pays et notre mode de vie
notre système voilà il faut être très
résolus à combattre tout forme
d'attentât y en l'espèce dynamisme qui a
donné ces campagnes nathalie goulet
l'émotion est vive
il faut dire aussi qu'elle est alimentée
par un risque terroriste qui est
toujours présent la menace terroriste
reste maximale a déclaré ce matin
laurent nunez notamment oui je suis pas
tellement surprise et puis vous savez
les sujets s'enchaînent mais si vous
croyez que le type de manifestation
comme celle de dimanche que des débats
incessants sur le voile que le climat
général de violence ne sert pas les
propos du terrorisme vous trompez pas ce
que tout ça alimente aussi l'islam
radical et on peut dire plusieurs choses
là-dessus la première d'abord rendre
hommage aux victimes bien sûr de rendre
hommage aux efforts énormes de l'état
des forces de sécurité et de police et
l'armée et des progrès vous savez qu
entre charlie et le bataclan eux sous la
houlette de bernard cazeneuve
nous avons dépensé plus d'un milliard
d'euros pourrait équiper nos troupes nos
forces et prendre des mesures à venir il
ya eu des progrès spectaculaires de fait
sous françois hollande c'était les
circonstances et bernard cazeneuve
il faut le dire et le répéter il reste
des trous dans la raquette il faudra
qu'on en parle mais les problèmes sur le
financement
il ya aussi les primes sur les
associations et sur la formation des
ministres du culte pour lesquels nous
n'avons toujours pas avancé c'est là
dessus maintenant qu'il faut avancer on
pense d'ailleurs à l'épuisement un des
forces de police un sujet sur lequel
vous aviez travaillé françois grosdidier
ce rythme ce ce risque terroriste il est
aussi alimentée par bien le retour des
djihadistes et de leur enfant en france
à ce que ça c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
alors que notre maman et ben erdogan a
dit qu'il ne voulait plus être l'autre
elle pour d'esch et il veut rentrer
c'est un vrai risque est alors
effectivement d'abord à mon tour je dire
qu'on se souvient et c'était un moment
d'émotion encore cet après midi au sénat
deuxièmement que l'état à travers les
forces de sécurité intérieure les armes
et tous les rouages de l'état se sont
pleinement mobilisés mais qu'on est
encore loin du compte
d'abord il n'y a pas les moyens soient
claires on est sur le débat budgétaire
la nation ne consacre pas encore aux
missions régaliennes et sur celle des
moyens nécessaires
on n'y est pas encore ensuite vous posez
la question du retour
c'est très difficile parce qu'on a un
état de droit et on est en guerre sans
l'être c'est-à-dire que si on était en
guerre contre un ennemi même quand on a
des ressortissants d'un pays avec lequel
on est en guerre en temps de guerre je
suis désolé même si non on n'a rien à
reprocher pénalement
eh bien ils ne sont plus en liberté
pendant la guerre ça c'est du vrai comme
ça pendant les gardes
on est dans une guerre complètement d'un
nouveau type sur lequel on on se trouve
encore désemparé bon mais malgré des
succès il faut vaincre militairement à
l'extérieur policièrement judiciairement
à l'intérieur mais faut pas non plus
offrir la victoire intellectuelle morale
aux terroristes qui n'ont pas d'autre
but que de porter chez nous la guerre de
religion qu'ils ont créée au levant et
nous devons surtout pas tomber dans les
pièges de fracturation de la société
française autrement même en le mans par
led la victoire physique nous assurait
malgré tout une défaite intellectuelle
voulez vous voulez réagir à nantes je
voulais juste dire que 37 milliards et
des poussières c'est le budget de la
défense
et c'est exactement le montant des
intérêts de la dette de ce qu'on
rembourse chaque année
donc quand on va faire un peu d'économie
on pourra moins remboursés et investir
un peu plus dans nos forces de sécurité
et dans d'autres secteurs et je crois
que ça va être dur car les sujets de
l'orthodoxie un peu racheté mal est-ce
que vous aussi et bien cela vous
inquiète ce contexte international et la
question du retour des des djihadistes
en france je crois que ça inquiète tout
le monde parce qu'il ya eu aussi cette
année près de faim
puis quelques mois près de soixante dix
attentats déjoués oui donc il faut
saluer effectivement le travail au
quotidien des forces de sécurité salue
également et le président a bien fait
hier de l'occasion du 11 novembre dont
il ya 2 jours 7 7 7 ce lieu de pour la
mémoire des soldats sur les opérations
extérieures parce que y mène une guerre
pour nous et terre pour l'europe
aussi on pourrait se poser la question
comment on pourrait retirer une partie
des des dépenses de la défense des trois
pour cent puisque d'air ça quand on est
en mission extérieure c'est aussi pour
le compte de l'europe
on a reparlé de l'otan et c'est à dire
qu'il ya des enjeux aussi là dessus et
effectivement cirque e et mon collègue
la raison le dire c'est une nouvelle
type de 2de guerre cirque il n'ya pas
effectivement d'état contre et a donc
c'est un travail totalement il faut
travailler notre doctrine moyens
financiers et doctrines pour faire en
sorte avec toujours une foule en tête
nous ce qu'est notre talisman ce que
n'autorise on sait l'état de droit ne
jamais perdre cela de vue parce que ce
qu'ils souhaitent en face c'est con à
bonn au talent droit pour dire oui ce
n'est celle ci n'est plus en état de
droit ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut avoir en tête aussi
dans notre démarche est bien sûr c'est
sur ce talisman à l'état de droit que se
terminera pas mauvais sujets exactement
se terminera ce débat mars à tous les
cadres d'avoir participé à cette
discussion au genre gravier arnaud
françois grosdidier
nathalie goulet racheter mal merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ceux des
bri l'actualité parlementaire continue
sur public sénat tout de suite retour
aux discussions autour du budget de la
sécurité sociale discussions sous
tension car les sénateurs ont après que
la ministre agnès buzyn devait faire des
annonces en faveur de l'hôpital mais
qu'elles ne sont pas présentés bien dans
le plfss à laon le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dont
ils sont en train de parler retour aux
discussion dans l'hémicycle
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2010 9 dont nous
entamions l'examen il ya exactement un
an et sa promesse de retour à
l'équilibré des comptes sociaux aura
donc vécu moins de deux semaines le
temps que les mesures d'urgence gilet
jaune ne mette à mal et l' équilibre de
sécurité sociale et le sérieux du
gouvernement en matière de finances
publiques
avant même ces événements nous alertions
sur les limites de la politique du en
même temps pouvait ton en même temps
baisser les recettes tenir l'équilibré
résorber la dette nous occupions et
l'expérience nous a montré qu'il
s'agissait d'une équation pour le moins
difficile le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2020 nous propose une expérience plus
original encore que celle de 2019
puisqu'il ne s'agit plus cette fois d'un
texte à la date de péremption rapprocher
mais d'une caducité d'emblée nous avons
appris ce dimanche dans la presse que le
niveau de l'ondam hospitaliers seraient
augmentées afin de financer notamment
des mesures d'activité pour le début de
carrière des personnels hospitaliers et
que la dette des hôpitaux serait reprise
par l'état afin de faciliter le
financement des investissements pour
autant pour l'instant pas d'amendements
du gouvernement ni en pf ni en lfss on
nous annonce des présidents le 20
novembre au lendemain du vote solennel
au sénat
il est permis de s'interroger sur la
conformité d'un tel texte à la loi
organique relative aux lois de
financement des sociétés sociale et au
delà des questions juridiques sur la
considération portée à la représentation
nationale
la commission des affaires sociales
avait pris à titre conservatoire la
décision de ne pas adopter un ondam
provisoire nous confirmerons donc cette
position je mets simplement en garde
à trop vouloir se passer du parlement et
des corps intermédiaires
le gouvernement va se trouver bien seuls
face aux mouvements sociaux en cours ou
à venir
un face-à-face dangereux on risque des
mouvements de la rue qui peut conduire à
la paralysie et à l'abandon des réformes
mais peut-être pire encore or des
réformes notre pays en a besoin dans
l'intérêt même de notre protection
sociale
nous devons la faire évoluer dans ses
différentes composantes
un système de santé tout à la fois de
pointe et solidaire des retraites
décentes et une politique de soutien aux
familles la protection sociale
appartient à l'identité même de notre
pays laisser filer les déficits
c'est la mettre en péril ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
c'est le produit d'une absence de
réformes structurelles à passer le
budget des hôpitaux sous la toise à
grand renfort de mesures de régulation
pour tenir l'ondam tout le système
craque et il est déjà me semble-t-il
trop tard le temps que les mesures
d'organisation portent leurs fruits
il faut réarmer l'hôpital le
gouvernement n'a pas d'autre choix des
choix pourtant il faudra en faire en
matière de santé
si nous voulons maintenir un système
solidaire faire de la place à
l'innovation et assumer les charges
liées au vieillissement et aux
pathologies chroniques sur les retraites
il faut agir sans attendre une réforme
très ambitieuse qui peut-être ne viendra
pas au motif de l'injustice des régimes
spéciaux le gouvernement s'est lancé
dans une vaste entreprise qui pourrait
conduire à réformer tout le reste
en laissant de côté dans le système
universel
peut-être qu'un jour qui n'ont les
rennais s'est même régime qui ne
rentreraient peut-être qu'un jour mais
pas tout de suite
or nous sommes tout proches des années
les plus difficiles en matière de
financement de retraite rené paul savary
en a parlé nous pouvons attendre
quarante ans les fruits du néo d'une
hypothétique réforme
la convention de la commission invite
une mission d'affaires social invite le
sénat à prendre ses responsabilités sans
tarder et invite le gouvernement à en
faire autant
nous avons alerté sur la question de la
dette de la sécurité sociale par la
partie transférée dans le mécanisme
d'amortissement à la cades s
l'extinction est programmé pour le reste
évalué par notre rapporteur général à
près de 50 milliards d'euros en fin de
période couverte par le présent texte
rien n'est moins sûr nous avons du mal à
comprendre ce choix clairement assumé
par le gouvernement de laisser perdurer
cette dette est elle un aiguillon pour
inciter à la vertu budgétaire
c'est la logique même de la sécurité
sociale qui se trouve ainsi mises à mal
le sens même des cotisations sociales et
derrière le sens ne se trouve pas très
loin le consentement à les payer
le rapporteur général a évoqué sysiphe
les références mythologiques sont riches
est pour les français le ce trou de la
sécurité sociale pourrait évoquer le
tonneau des danaïdes
la vocation de la sécurité sociale et la
redistribution des biens portants vers
les malades des actifs vers les
personnes âgées des célibataires vers
les familles la redistribution passe par
les prestations et non par les
prélèvements en d'autres termes l'objet
d'un sécurité sociale n'est pas de
financer des mesures de pouvoir d'achat
et a été beaucoup question dans nos
débats de la non compensation des
mesures gilet jaune quel était
l'objectif de la loi veil c'était de
garantie
au moment où s'amorce et une
diversification des recettes de la
sécurité sociale que le remplacement des
cotisations serait bien pérenne et que
la baisse des cotisations ne se
traduirait pas tout simplement par des
déficits
la tentation est grande nous l'observons
chaque année deux mythes et ses recettes
pour les minis pour les ministères les
allégements de cotisations sont un outil
commode en période de disette sur les
crédits s'ils peuvent être laissées à la
charge de la sécurité sociale à
l'assemblée nationale un amendement de
jean pierre door a opportunément
remédier à une première tentative dans
ce sens ce qui contrevenait même au
principe du rapport charpy du pastre sur
lequel le gouvernement s'appuie pour
justifier la non compensation la non
compensation ne change rien à l'échelle
des finances publiques
elle est juste un moyen de loger un bout
de déficits en dehors du budget de
l'état il faut évidemment corriger cette
anomalie
et puisque le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui semble provisoire il reste
une opportunité à saisir pour le
gouvernement
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler que la
commission est asocial donc de votre
assemblée à examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2020 lors de sa séance du 6 novembre
malgré le travail important des
rapporteurs
elle n'a pu se prononcer de façon
éclairée sur ce texte
en effet d'importantes incertitudes
entourent le niveau réel des moyens
financiers que le gouvernement entend
consacrer à la santé et plus
particulièrement au secteur hospitalier
ainsi alors que s'ouvre
l'examen du plfss du sénat le
gouvernement n'a déposé aucun amendement
ni transmis à notre assemblée aucun
élément d'information tendant à modifier
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie ondam inscrit donc à
l'article 59 de ce texte
pourtant et beaucoup d'orateurs et on
fait allusion emad al-alami sera
également
et pourtant un journal un grand journal
a annoncé avant-hier donc que madame le
ministre avait remporté d'importants
arbitrages budgétaires de nature à
améliorer de manière significative la
situation financière des hôpitaux et la
rémunération des personnels et si cela
est vrai tant mieux bien évidemment
cette situation pour le parlement n'est
quand même pas très acceptable
elle compromet la sincérité de
l'ensemble des bas elle contrevient
clairement à l'esprit voire à la lettre
de l'article 111 tiré 3 du code de
situer de social aux termes duquel la
loi finance mans dans sa quatrième
partie fixe l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance palette de
l'ensemble des régimes obligatoires de
base ainsi que c'est ce jeu effectif
c'est pourquoi la commission proposera
le rejet de l'artiste 59 de ce texte en
l'état on proposera et il vaut mieux
d'ailleurs comme qu'on ne vote pas pour
pouvoir le laisser ouvert à foin de de
pouvoir mieux travailler dans le cadre
d'une nouvelle lecture proposée par un
ministre par ailleurs c'est également
comme pour également pourquoi la
commission propose au sénat de lui
renvoyer le texte
le brouillard entourant l'ondam étant
susceptible de fausser l'ensemble de la
discussion
y compris au niveau des recettes
adéquate des régimes de sécurité sociale
cela permettra à la commission de
demander au gouvernement de lui indiquer
donc enfin avec précision ses intentions
pourrait viser le niveau dont âme et
répondre à la crise hospitalière dans le
cadre de cette lecture si et non pas
dans le cadre d'une nouvelle lecture
puisqu'il semble quand même que nous
ayons suffisamment d'éléments pour
pouvoir travailler et discuter
valablement sur ce sujet donc madame la
présidente je souhaite la commission
affaires sociales plutôt souhaite que
cette motion de tendance de temps dans
son renvoi en commission soient votées
par notre assemblée
merci quelqu'un souhaitait prendre la
parole contre la motion je n'en vois pas
par conséquent je vais consulter les
ministres
pardon madame cohen ah oui
ensuite oui oui d'abord il me faut
demander consulter l'avis du
gouvernement on va faire deux dans
l'ordre
la quel est l'avis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre mr merci à madame
la présidente
le gouvernement vous l'imaginez ne
peut-être favorable à une motion de
renvoi en commission mme de la ministre
a indiqué il ya un instant que le plfss
a fait l'objet d' échanges nombreux
qu'ils apportent des réponses à des
sujets de préoccupation du sénat
puisqu'il cgt de proposition sénatoriale
mais qui font écho en réalité aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
par ailleurs et au risque de paraître
enfermé dans une procédure que ni les
uns ni les autres n'avons véritablement
défini
nous avons toutes et tous en tête le
fait que la loi organique prévoit
qu'entre la transmission du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale au sénat et son adoption il doit
s'écouler 15 jours et qu'à défaut passer
ces quinze jours le texte tel qu'il est
est renvoyé à l'assemblée nationale avec
le cas échéant simplement les
amendements qui aurait le temps d'être
adopté j'ai dit dans mon propos
liminaire que le gouvernement forme le
voeu tout en respectant évidemment les
décisions prendre à votre assemblée
forme le voeu que la discussion sur le
plfss puisse s'engager et se continuer
dans les heures et dans les jours qui
viennent
nous avons des points de débat qui sont
importants nous aurons effectivement
dans les jours les semaines qui viennent
dans les temps qui viennent à répondre à
un certain nombre de problématiques que
madame la ministre a évoqué nous
veillerons à associer les parlementaires
nous veillerons à ce que les engagements
pris soient traduits de la manière la
plus opérationnel possible mais vous
imaginez évident évidemment aisément que
tant que les décisions ne sont pas
totalement prise est difficile d'en
donner une traduction législative ou
même comptable si vous me permettez
cette expression donc pour toutes les
raisons l'avis est défavorable à cette
notion de romans comme si monsieur le
ministre pour votre parfaite information
pour les explications de vote elles ne
sont accordé qu'un seul représentant par
groupe politique et pour une durée de 2
minutes 30
madame cohen
merci madame la présidente ne je veux
dire que avec mon groupe nous allons
voter cette cette motion je regrette que
l'ensemble du sénat n'est pas voter
notre motion d'irrecevabilité
constitutionnel parce que comme gelée
soulignait je pense que là la
non-compensation massive d exonération
porte un coup terrible à notre système
de sécurité sociale est certes monsieur
le ministre
ça n'est pas c'est déjà arrivé par le
passé mais pas avec cette ampleur
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas le groupe
communistes républicains citoyens
écologistes qui le dénoncent
il ya d'autres collègues des autres
banques ils l'ont dit mais c'est aussi
les magistrats qui siègent à la cour des
comptes qui ont montré l'ampleur de ces
exonérations et donc là il ya vraiment
une rupture importante
alors nous allons voter effectivement
cette motion de rejet
d'abord parce que les problèmes qui sont
exprimés madame madame la ministre
affirme un certain nombre de choses moi
je ne doute pas du fait qu'elle veut
régler un certain nombre de questions
qui ont trait à l'hôpital
sauf qu'on est dans un brouillard je
dirais artistique mais artistique ça a
une connotation assez sympathique
on est dans un bon dans un brouillard
qui est à couper au couteau et à dire on
ne sait rien on est on ne sait pas vous
nous dit tout à l'heure madame la
ministre que vous allez sans doute
augmenter l'ondam et on peut le lire
dans la presse
mais est-ce que vous allez augmenter
l'ondam à 4 5%
comme tous les professionnels le
demander les fédérations hospitalières
est ce que si vous augmentez l'andam de
cette façon là vous allez enfin
débloquer d'autres financements et à
changer votre politique qui est celle
d'une exonération massive
tout ça nous n'avons pas nous n'avons
pas de réponse
donc oui on va voter cette motion de
rejet j'dirais pour marquer le coup
parce que je trouvais nous trouvons avec
l'ensemble de notre groupe que c'est
quand même une mascarade notamment par
rapport à la à la représentation
parlementaire mais
mes chers collègues vous qui présente et
qui est majoritaire à la commission je
regrette vraiment que ce soit quelque
part un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau
parce que ça va coincer à retarder notre
notre notre débat de combien de quelques
heures mais moi j'aimerais à ce moment
là qu'on se retrouve mes chers collègues
après le 20 novembre
quand madame la la la la ministre or
encore enfin daigné nous donnait
vraiment la réalité du budget qu'elle
porte
merci la parole est à madame meunier
pour 2 minutes 30
la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
depuis le début de cet après midi vous
entendez notre attachement viscéral au
financement de la sécurité sociale et
vous entendez aussi son attachement
viscéral de mon groupe à sa pérennité
hélas ce qui concerne maintenant ce sont
pas de crainte d'insécurité des recettes
de la sécurité sociale de l'assurance
maladie mais ce sont nos craintes de vos
réponses madame la ministre qui nous
anime le plfss donc a été présenté fin
septembre ces orientations ont été
soumises au débat public il y a deux
mois déjà
vous disiez votre ambition de répondre à
l'urgence économique et social l'urgence
au singulier
quant aux urgences les services
d'urgences hospitalières alors qu'ils
étaient déjà en grève vous aviez prévu
un pacte pour leur refondation
doté de 750 millions d'euros sur quatre
ans et 600 millions dans ce plfss
pourtant pourtant madame la ministre
la mobilisation des soignantes et des
soignants de l'hôpital ne faiblit pas et
vous voilà un peu sommée de revoir votre
copie
le collectif intérieur chances que la
commission des affaires sociales a reçu
ici nous a éclairés sur ce que dissimule
votre volonté de modération de la
dépense
ce sont des patients vulnérables
personnes âgées personnes handicapées
qui sont en danger et ce sont des
effectifs qui sont en sursis
alors vous vous dites dans le jdd
puisque sont pas des annonces mais ce
sont des intentions que
vous allez éventuellement augmenter
l'ondam que vous allez éventuellement
augmenter les primes les investissements
et leur valorisation
mais nous sommes prêts madame la
ministre ici et c'est notre rôle de
parlementaire et c'est notre agenda
puisque c'est cette semaine que nous
examinons le projet de loi de finances
de sécurité sociale et socialistes
d'ailleurs propose l'augmentation de
l'ondam un plan d'investissement est un
véritable une véritable programmation de
l'hôpital public
sur les cinq ans à venir alors quelle
est la vraie copie de ce gouvernement
concernant le plfss faut-il attendre la
journée de jeudi prochain
ou pensez-vous que la date du 20 mai on
vienne vous écoutez madame la ministre
ce n'est pas forcément maintenant la
bonne date
donc pour toutes ces raisons
d'incertitude
nous pensons que les bonnes bases de la
discussion ne sont pas posées concernant
l'hôpital et nous soutiendrons et la
motion de renvoi en commission présentée
par monsieur milon merci la parole est à
monsieur amiel pour 2 minutes 30
oui bien sûr ma voix sera minoritaire
par rapport à ce renvoi
cette motion tu en as au renvoi en
commission que nous ne voterons pas je
peux comprendre un mouvement d'humeur
tel que celui porté par monsieur me
l'ont effectivement certaines
incertitudes
nous aurions tous préféré qu'elle soit
levée faut-il pour autant remettre en
question tout un texte et un certain
nombre de mesures comme cela a été dit
je ne le crois pas et en tout état de
cause c'est moins une question de forme
que de fond
oui madame la ministre bien entendu
comme tout les parlementaires nous
attendons les mesures fortes qui semble
annoncer la semaine prochaine sans pour
autant que cela doit vous remettre en
question le vote et plus exactement le
débat qui doit avoir lieu dans les
heures et les jours qui suivent
concernant le plfss
il n'y a plus de demandes de
l'explication de vote
non je vais à présent consulter le sénat
sur la motion de renvoi à la commission
déposée par monsieur alain milon ono de
la commission des affaires sociales qui
est pour son adoption
qui est contre qui s'abstient elle est
adoptée et en conséquence le renvoi du
projet de loi la commission est ordonnée
merci monsieur le président cet article
et le point que nous contestons le plus
dans ce plfss et je pense d'ailleurs que
ça va être un article va nous permettre
à un échange assez approfondis puisque
cet article en fête repose sur la non
compensation des exonérations et que
nous l'avons déjà dit lors de la de la
discussion générale en en faisant en ne
compensant pas ces exonérations et bien
le gouvernement tourne le dos à la loi
veil du 25 juillet 1994
et même si c'est déjà ça a déjà eu lieu
par le passé
l'ampleur des exonérations qui ne sont
pas compensées sont énormes
alors vous allez me dire que finalement
d'un point de vue comptable
finalement il n'ya pas tant de problèmes
que ça puisque que ça passe d'une caisse
ou d'une autre est ce que les françaises
et les français y voient un vrai
inconvénient bien en tout cas d'un point
de vue de la justice sociale de la
solidarité
il en va tout autrement parce que je
dois rappeler ici que le budget de
l'état est financé en grande partie par
l'impôt sur le revenu alors que le
budget de la sécurité sociale est
financé par les cotisations sur le
travail et le transfert du déficit d'un
budget sur l'autre fait peser le
financement des exonérations sur le
travail est là c'est donc pas du tout
des mesures qui conviennent et qui sont
juste par rapport à notre système de
solidarité le système de la sécurité
sociale et les sommes qui sont en jeu on
l'a vu atteignent plusieurs milliards
donc c'est pourquoi nous nous élevons
donc contre cet article et que nous
pensons que le gouvernement en
s'entêtant sur cette logique c'est peser
un lourd tribut aux assurés sociaux et
fait peser aussi un lourd tribut à la
fois sur notre système de protection
sociale mais aussi sur notre économie et
puis la deuxième injustice c'est de
faire porter sur le régime de la
sécurité sociale des mesures d'urgence
qui ont été arrachés par des mois de
lutte par les gilet jaune et qui ne
devraient pas incomber non plus à la un
autre système de sécurité sociale donc
pour toutes ces raisons nous allons
effectivement à la fois continuer à
mener la discussion sur l'article est
présenté un certain nombre d'amendements
qui vont j'espère être votée par
l'ensemble de nos collègues quand
j'entends leurs interventions lors de
l'intervention de lors de la discussion
générale je vous remercie
merci prise de parole sur un flic
monsieur yves daudigny
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chaque la glaire de la politique et
peut-être comme la pédagogie la
répétition il y a un an
le gouvernement a annoncé après 18 ans
de déficits que la sécurité sociale
dégagerait un excédent en 2019
nous y sommes le déficit cumulé du
régime général et du fonds solidarité
vieillesse pour 2019 sera de 5 4
milliards d'euros et pour 2020 le
déficit prévisionnel est à peine réduit
à 5 1 milliards d'euros
alors certes la masse salariale est
moins favorable que prévu
certes les dépenses des branches maladie
et vieillesse sont plus élevés
qu'attendu mais surtout les mesures
adoptées dans le cas de la loi mesures
d'urgence en décembre dernier pèse pour
près de 2 7 milliards d'euros
elles ne sont pas compensés par le
budget de l'état en refusant de
compenser par les crédits du budget de
l'état les conséquences de ses propres
choix fiscaux le gouvernement déroge à
la loi veil de 1994 qui avait instauré
une sorte de règle d'or et cela a été
bien exprimé après midi par le président
la commission des affaires sociales
selon laquelle toute mesure
d'exonération totale ou partielle de
cotisation sécurité sociale d'un lieu à
compensation intégrale aux régimes
concernés par le budget de l'état
vous organisez ce leterme a déjà été
utilisé une sorte de pillage de
l'édifice social issu des ordonnances de
1945 qui n'est non pas d'un mode ancien
mais qui est un édifice de valeurs la
solidarité la justice dont découlent
l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale un
lob du retour à l'équilibré la cité
sociale
bercy c'est comme ça qu'on s'exprime
fait peu de cas de l'autonomie
d'intégrer social accroît son emprise et
prépare la captation des excédents
potentiel des années suivantes
comment ne pas percevoir l'orchestration
politique de ce déficit pour le déplorer
et poursuivre peut-être une politique
d'austérité
quelle sera la prochaine étape pour j'ai
milité total du budget de l'assurance
maladie dans celui de l'état
hier il nous a été dit que cette
perspective n'était pas réel nous on
l'espère et je vous remercie
merci donc prise de parole sur article
monsieur rené paul savary ou emerson
seul président c'est quand même une
situation assez particulière
on sait les difficultés que l'on peut
rencontrer avec les les hôpitaux on sait
les difficultés qu'on va rencontrer avec
la réforme de la retraite et par rapport
à cela on a appel est fait c'est ce
qu'on a qu'on découvre de jour en jour
et de plus en plus complexe avec un
déficit organisée et une absolue une
obsolescence programmée déficit organisé
puisque vous ne comprenez pas ce qui
devrait être le devrait être compensée
sur le budget de la sécurité sociale
salle mais en déséquilibre et sa force à
prendre un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont pas forcément d'une redoutable
cohérence et obsolescence programmée
puisque madame la ministre vous même ne
savait pas encore comment allait régler
problème des hôpitaux c'est en tout cas
ce que vous venez de nous dire nous
pensions que les décisions avaient été
déjà prises qu' il y avoir une réponse
construite par rapport aux difficultés
des hôpitaux et on apprend que rien
n'est encore fait or déficit cus
l'argent complémentaire qu'il faudra
mettre pour les hôpitaux plus le raid et
semant les mesures paramétrique qui ne
sont pas prises sur la branche
vieillesse pour préparer la réforme
véritablement il ya un certain nombre
d'inconnues qui sont graves par rapport
à l'examen que nous faisons de ce plfss
cette année merci donc on va passer aux
amendements
deux amendements identiques 526
rectifier
madame marie pierre monnier merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le grand bain de
l'article 231 du code général des impôts
dispose notamment que les employeurs
redevables de la taxe sur les salaires
mentionnées à l'article 1679 à peuvent
bénéficier d'un crédit d'impôt assis sur
les rémunérations qu'ils versent à leurs
salariés au cours de l'année civile
l'article 3 de ce plfss 2020 propose
quant à lui que ce crédit d'impôt ne
fasse pas l'objet d'une compensation à
la sécurité sociale
or les compensations de pertes de
recettes ou de transferts de charges
entre l'état et la sécurité sociale sont
régies par le principe de compensation
intégrale définie à l'article l 131 tirs
et 7 du code de la sécurité sociale
de plus cette politique d'exonération de
cotisations sociales a des conséquences
directes sur le financement de notre
système de protection sociale basée sur
la solidarité et la collectivité par
ailleurs la cour des comptes relève dans
son dernier rapport un déséquilibre des
comptes de la sécurité sociale qui
explique avant tout par la politique
d'exonération qui s'explique par don
avant tout par la politique
d'exonération des cotisations sociales
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
proposer la suppression de cet article
merci donc amendements identiques de 570
ce même un pourceau poli merci monsieur
le président nous proposons donc par cet
amendement la suppression de cet article
par cette disposition vous vous apprêtez
à prendre une décision grave pour notre
système de sécurité sociale vous amputez
son budget de plus de 3 milliards
d'euros alors que vous ne cessez de
mettre en avant un déficit de 5
milliards pour justifier de coupes
budgétaires pour les hôpitaux
faut-il encore rappeler que la
compensation de l'état par l'état de
mesures d'exonérations sociales et bien
le principe de la non une exception
d'exception au principe c'est ce que
vous êtes en train d' actes et en
prévoyant la non compensation par l'état
des mesures dites j'ai les jeunes qui
coûte plus de 3 milliards d'euros à la
sécurité sociale 3 milliards sur 5
milliards d'euros 5 milliards de déficit
c'est une attaque sans précédent contre
l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale
quelles vont être les conséquences pour
nos concitoyens des coupes budgétaires
sur les hôpitaux avec fermetures
d'établissements publics de services de
lee des ehpad de sinistrés quel signal
envoyé vous à l'ensemble de la
population
les faibles primes qui sont accordées à
quelques-uns ne suffiront pas à
compenser la facture de la casse du
service public de la santé
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis des commissions sur
ces amendements
oui monsieur le président donc cet
amendement propose de supprimer
l'article 3 et ça sera un avis
défavorable car au-delà de la question
des mesures de non compensations sur
lequel effectivement je me suis exprimé
de façon favorable
cet article contient aussi des
dispositions utiles notamment concernant
la répartition des recettes entre les
branches
il me semble il faut conserver pour
pouvoir effectivement continuer à avoir
un plfss et qu'il y ait donc c'est un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre l'avis du
gouvernement merci à monsieur le
président les orateurs me pardonneront
la brièveté de la vie il est défavorable
pour les raisons évoquées par le
rapporteur
le gouvernement n'est favorable ni à la
suppression totale ni la suppression
partielle de l'arctique mais il y à
d'autres amendements qui viendront après
sur une suppression partielle de
l'article nous permettront de développer
sur les questions de compensation dans
défavorable merci je mets aux voix ces
amendements identiques avec deux avis
défavorables de la commission et les
gouvernements qui est pour et qui est
contre
abstention donc ils ne sont pas adoptées
en discussion commune donc que plusieurs
amendements le 527 rectifié manas marty
et la wii avec l'article 3 3 a déjà été
dit le gouvernement acte la non
compensation à la sécurité sociale des
décisions qu'il prend les compensations
de pertes de recettes ou de transferts
de charges entre l'état et la sécurité
sociale sont pourtant régie par le
principe de compensation intégrale
définie à l'article l 131 7 du code de
la sécurité sociale
ce principe a été respectée pendant le
principe d'un quinquennat
depuis 2007 des entorse à cette règle
ont été observés comme par exemple le
crédit d'impôts de taxes sur les
salaires qui n'a pas fait l'objet d'une
compensation à la sécurité sociale en
2018 pour 2020 c'est non compensation la
sécurité sociale célèbre et un montant
estimé à 3,5 milliards d'euros 1,2
milliards d'exonérations de cotisations
sociales sur les heures supplémentaires
1,5 milliards de baisse de la csg pour
les retraités gagnant moins de 2000
euros par mois ainsi qu'une diminution
de 800 millions d'euros sur le forfait
social
par conséquent l'article 3 prive la
sécurité sociale de 3,5 milliards
d'euros de ressources qui devait lui
revenir
c'est pourquoi le pressent le présent
amendement vise à supprimer les alinéas
de l'article qui concerne cette non
compensation merci ensuite le monde ment
du gouvernement la mle 943 monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'un amendement de coordination pour
réparer une erreur matérielle sur les
ressources de la scène et ça donc c'est
la pure coordination
merci l'amendement 168 de monsieur
jean-marie vanlerenberghe pour la
commission alors cet amendement monsieur
le président on envisage de supprimer
que les années les alinéas partons 9 à
c'est à dire ceux qui suppriment les
mesures de non compensations qui sont
proposés dans cet article est donc on
limite parfaitement la suppression à ces
mesures et j'ai pas en dire plus je
crois que nous en avons suffisamment dit
précédemment le 274 rectifié de deere
madame nathalie delattre
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues pour venir en complément
du rapporteur général bien sûr que au
rds nous donnons sont pour partie cette
dérogation qui fait et qui a assumé par
le gouvernement de la loi veil
le fait que ces mesures gilet jaune ne
correspondent pas à une politique de
sécurité sociale mais à une rebelle
revalorisation du pouvoir d'achat mais
pour venir en complément
je souhaite dire que les efforts qu'ont
fait les professionnels pour tenter
d'enrayer ce trou de la sécurité sociale
ne sont pas récompensés c'est à dire que
nous ne verrons pas leurs efforts dans
ce budget puisqu'ils sont masqués par
cette non compensation et pour eux nous
souhaitons effectivement la suppression
de ces alinéas 9 à 12
merci merci l'amendement 572 de madame
grès um
merci monsieur président comme monsieur
le rapporteur et ma collègue cet
amendement propose la suppression des
amis néo de 9 à 12
c'est un raid mandement a obtenu un
large consensus dans son les bancs de
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat en
commission des affaires sociales le
gouvernement doit entendre que la
compensation par l'état de mesures
d'exonérations sociales et bien le
principe et non l'exception
il n'a pas financé les choix politiques
de l'état par l'argent des assurés
sociaux
il ressort de la responsabilité de
l'état de financer ses propres
politiques
par ailleurs c'est un non sens absolu
que de demander aux assurés sociaux de
financer eux-mêmes l'augmentation de
leur pouvoir d'achat
et que dire des travailleurs et
travailleuses qui n'ont pas bénéficié
des mesures d'urgence économique et
social ils et elles les paye il est vrai
d'une mesure qui ne les concernait pas
en effet la prime est facultative la loi
n'oblige que les oblige pas les
entreprises à verser cette prime à leurs
salariés
il s'agit seulement d'une incitation
l'objet de cet amendement n'est pas de
revenir sur la nature des mesures qui
ont été prises mais sur les conséquences
budgétaires de ces dernières merci donc
le 806 rectifié monsieur yves daudigny
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues même si
c'est répétitif petite foule at il
encore souligné que les mesures qui
amènent donc cet article 3 sur
l'exonération de cotisations sociales
des heures supplémentaires avancée et
les pertes de recettes liées à la
création d'un taux de csg intermédiaire
à 6 6% celui également l'exonération
forfait social pour les entreprises de
moins de 250 salariés versant
d'intéressement ou de participation
mesures décidées dans le cadre de la loi
pacte est ce qu'ils ont et qui engendre
une perte de recettes de 500 millions
alors monsieur le ministre
même si depuis le vote de la loi veil
il ya eu d'autres exemples de mesures
qui n'ont pas été compensées 1,6 sociale
la différence avec le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est que vous vous en
batterie c'est une doctrine c'est un non
seulement un nouveau paradigme non
seulement un nouvel usage ce n'est pas
une mesure technique c'est une doctrine
avec laquelle nous ne pouvons pas être
d'accord du tout parce qu'elle considère
qu'il ya une fragilité et entre le
budget de l'état et le budget la cité
sociale
c'est la fin de l'autonomie de la
protection sociale dans notre pays
merci de 528 rectifié madame gisèle
jourda
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement visait à supprimer les
alinéas 10 et 12 la non compensation par
l'état la sécurité sociale des mesures
d'urgence votées lors de la loi portant
mesures d'urgence économique et social
en décembre 2018 représente près de 2
millions 2,2 milliards 800 millions de
manque à gagner pour les comptes sociaux
elle s'oppose au principe vous posé par
la loi veil à 1994
selon lequel toute mesure d'exonération
totale ou partielle de cotisations de
sécurité sociale donne lieu à
compensation intégrale aux régimes
concernés par le budget de l'état
elle interroge sur les marges de
manoeuvre réel dont nous disposons alors
que deux échéances cruciales sont encore
devant nous le grand chantier de la
dépendance
nécessitera un besoin de financements
publics supplémentaires de l'ordre de 6
milliards de en 2024 et 2,9 milliards de
d'ici 2030
c'était tout l'objet des propositions du
rapport grand âge et autonomie porté par
dominique libault ancien directeur de la
sécurité sociale est actuellement
président du haut-conseil au financement
de la protection sociale face aux défis
majeurs du vieillissement de la
population il apporter des réponses
claires et ambitieuse en réponse aux
inquiétudes des français sur
l'accompagnement de leurs vieux jours
alors que le retour aux excédents de la
sécurité sociale et durablement reportée
il est quasi certain que la dynamique
qu'il impulse et ne soit fragilisée par
les incertitudes autour du financement
de la perte d'autonomie la santé
financière des retraites
interroge également alors que le
gouvernement a lancé en réforme
d'ampleur de notre système de retraite
il est craint en particulier que la
rupture avec le principe de non
compensations ne conduisent le
gouvernement à faire supporter par la
sécurité sociale
le financement des régimes de retraite
de la fonction publique qui sont
aujourd'hui il ressort de l'état cet
amendement vise donc à revenir sur la
non compensation des mesures décidées
lors du projet de loi portant mesures
d'urgence économique et social à savoir
la baisse de csg pour les retraités avec
la création d'un taux intermédiaire et
l'avancement de l'exonération pour les
heures supplémentaires
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
apparu 527 rectifier oui monsieur le
président chers collègues
cet amendement propose donc de supprimer
non seulement la non-compensation les
non compensation plus tôt mais aussi des
mesures rectificatives de répartition de
recettes entre branches
c'est un avis défavorable car ces
corrections de répartition sont utiles
et il faudrait les conserver donc vous
avez ensuite sur l'article 943
un avis favorable c'est
l'amendement du gouvernement ensuite
c'est mon amendement l'amendement de la
commission donc est évidemment que est
évident que nous sommes favorables
l'amendement ensuite de madame delattre
est identique
c'est donc favorable l'amendement de
madame cohen est identique
c'est donc favorable favorable aussi
pour celui de monsieur dowd signé du
groupe socialiste et nous arrivons à
celui de monsieur antiste qui prévoit
d'une non compensation
donc des baisses de recettes dues à la
loi muette mais que cet amendement ne va
pas aussi loin que l'amendement de la
commission et donc qui propose notamment
un certain nombre de revenir sur un
certain nombre de l'absence de
compensation de plusieurs mesures votées
en pdf ss 2019
donc nous sommes défavorables où on
demande le retrait toute façon il
tomberait si notre amendement
l'amendement de la commission passait et
puis nous avons ensuite la mort et où
c'est tout c'est tout oui oui c'est en
discussion communautaire est aux 528
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement merci monsieur le président
le gouvernement est évidemment favorable
à l'amendement qui a déposé le 943 pour
les autres amendements l'avis est
défavorable concernant le 527,2 me
scientiste l'avis défavorable pour des
raisons en tout cas partie les raisons
évoquées par monsieur le rapporteur pour
l'amendement 528 deux motions autistes
nous rejoignons l'avis défavorable pour
des raisons un peu différente et pour la
série d'amendements identiques dont
celui présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur général quelques mots que
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de prononcer
tout à l'heure pour dire d'abord mais ce
jeudi pour la clarté des débats que
l'état compense très largement les
exonérations que support de la sécurité
sociale je pense notamment aux
allégements généraux financé par une
affectation d'une fraction de tva à
hauteur de 51 milliards d'euros et nous
assumons bien évidemment le fait de
demander à la sécurité sociale de
financer les mesures d'urgence
économique et sociale relative à la fois
à la question de la csg et aux heures
supplémentaires
il s'agit de deux milliards 8 je
n'accepte pas vous ne pardonnez la
brutalité du propos mais je n'accepte
pas que l'on parle de déficits organisée
il y un déficit constaté à 5 milliards 4
sur l'année 2019 les mesures dont nous
souhaitons que la sécurité sociale les
finances s'élève à 2 milliards 8 et cela
démontre par ce simple chiffre qu'avec
ou sans ces mesures d'urgence économique
et sociale la sécurité sociale aurait
connu un déficit et par ailleurs nous
veillons pour 2020 est ce que le déficit
retrouve un niveau inférieur à celui
maintenir et retrouver cette trajectoire
de retour à l'équilibré de la sécurité
sociale il y a et monsieur daudigny a eu
l'honnêteté de le rappeler il vient à
l'instant il est un principe qui a
déposé par la loi veil qui n'a pas été
respecté de manière assez régulière
j'ai dénombré une vingtaine de cas dans
lesquels ça n'avait pas été respectée
parfois sur des compensations
extrêmement peu importante à l'échelle
du budget de la sécurité sociale
je pensais à une exonération de 2014 à
hauteur de 25 millions d'euros
parfois sur des chiffres beaucoup plus
importante beaucoup plus important et je
pense notamment à l'exonération de
cotisations minimales maladie pour les
travailleurs indépendants voter en 2013
et qui représente aujourd'hui 1 milliard
d'euros non compensés par l'état à la
sécurité sociale
c'était déjà une somme importante et je
crois que ça nous rappelle les uns et
les autres au fait que ce principe n'a
pas toujours été respectée
nous avons la conviction que l'effort
qui est fait non pas par l'état non pas
par la sécurité sociale mais par
l'intégralité de celles et ceux qui
peuvent actionner la dépense publique
pour répondre à la crise sociale qu'a
traversée notre pays à porter des
débouchés aux grands débats d'un effort
important à hauteur de 17 milliards
d'euros dont 14 sont portés par l'état
états dont le déficit de manière
structurelle s'est accrue alors que dans
le même temps le déficit de la sécurité
sociale
et c'est heureux se réduisent et donc ça
ne va nous paraît équilibré soutenable
ça ne remet pas en cause le retour à
l'équipe de la sécurité sociale et ça ça
ne se traduit pas par une augmentation
de la dette de la sécurité sociale
puisque j'ai eu l'occasion de dire avant
l'interruption que nous avons un effort
de désendettement et d'apurement de la
dette sociale qui est trois fois
supérieur au déficit constaté en 2019 ce
qui démontre bien que nous avons fait du
désendettement et de l'apurement de la
dette sociale une priorité que ces
mesures ne remettent pas en cause donc
l'ensemble de ces raisons l'avis est
défavorable à ces amendements de
suppression partielle et aux amendements
527 et 158 me scientiste merci monsieur
le ministre donc le mettre aux voix ses
différents amendements
527 rectifier avec deux avis
défavorables de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour et qui est
contre
abstention il n'est pas adopté le 943 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui et pour qui et contre
abstentions il est adopté ensuite
l'amendement de la commission et les
trois amendements identiques qui sont
déposés avec bien sûr un avis favorable
de la commission et un avis défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour et contre
abstention donc ils sont adoptés et
enfin le 528 rectifier avec deux avis
ils tombent pardon c'est vrai elles sont
j'avais deux avis défavorables
l'amendement suivant
le 571 madame laurence cohen oui merci
monsieur le président le rapport 2010 9
de la cour des comptes montrent que la
dette de la sécurité sociale se creuse
nous l'avons dit notamment du fait de la
multiplication des exonérations de
cotisations sociales qui met en péril
notre système collectif de protection
sociale les magistrats de la cour des
comptes qu'on ne peut qualifier de
révolutionnaire vous en conviendrez mes
chers collègues ajoute je cite que la
place aujourd'hui acquise par les
allègements généraux de cotisations qui
bénéficie à l'ensemble des employeurs de
salariés
interroge la définition même de la norme
de référence en fonction de laquelle des
règles particulières sont qualifiés de
dérogatoire pour notre part la priorité
pour financer la sécurité sociale doit
être de supprimer les exonérations de
cotisations de rétablir les cotisations
à l'ensemble des branches à sécurité
sociale de lutter contre la fraude
patronale mettra à contribution les
revenus financiers les industriels
pharmaceutiques qui profite très
largement de notre système de protection
sociale
une fois ces mesures adoptées nous
pouvons moderniser le principe
fondamental selon lequel chacun
contribue en fonction de ses moyens et
reçoit en fonction de ses besoins et
suivre l'évolution des écarts de
salaires des dernières décennies où les
écarts se sont creusés fortement entre
les plus favorisés et les autres les
plus fragiles d'après l'observatoire des
inégalités en 2016
les 10% des salariés les moins bien
rémunérés touche au mieux 1200 euros par
mois quand le club des 1 % des plus
hauts salaires gagne plus de 8600 euros
pour ces raisons nous proposons avec cet
amendement de relever les cotisations
sociales sur les plus hauts salaires
en effet aujourd'hui les hauts salaires
cotisent au même niveau que les salaires
les plus bas
la solidarité nationale est la base de
notre contrat social
elle doit être rétabli les personnes
donc aux revenus les plus élevés doivent
y contribuer c'est une question de
justice sociale
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
[Musique]
non monsieur le président l'avis de la
commission est défavorable à cet
amendement qui propose d'augmenter de
15% donc la csg dès lors que les revenus
d'activité ou de patrimoine dépasse un
certain seuil
l'efficacité de la csg je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure en commission mme adam cohen
c'est d'apporter des ressources à la
sécurité sociale qui tient qui tiennent
à sa simplicité à son assiette large à
son ton relativement modéré
plus il y aura de niche et d'être de
complexité
plus il y aura effectivement de risque
de niche qui viennent me tais l'assiette
et crée un sentiment d'injustice
donc il me paraît préférable de rester
au système actuel
donc c'est un avis défavorable monsieur
le ministre la vie du gouvernement
merci à monsieur le président j'ajoute
deux arguments à l'avis défavorable le
premier pour dire que nous considérons
qu'un amendement présenté par madame
cohen contre bien emprunt contrevient
pardon au principe d'égalité devant
l'impôt dans la mesure où vous
déterminer un taux de cotisation en
fonction de la nature d'un revenu et non
pas de la capacité contributive du foyer
fiscal
la deuxième remarque de forme que je
voulais faire c'est pour souligner que
la csg relèvent de la catégorie des
impositions de toutes natures et que
pour les impositions de toute nature il
est impératif que la loi fixe tant les
taux que l'assiette en l'amendement vous
proposez ne fixe pas ne définit pas le
montant de revenu considéré comme un
revenu élevé puisque vous le renvoyer à
un décret en conseil d'état ce qui est
contradictoire avec le principe d
imposition toute nature ont des savoirs
merci explications de vote de non je me
vois avec deux avis défavorables de la
commission et les gouvernements qui est
pour et qui est contre
abstention donc l'amendement n'est pas
adopté donc le suivant le 573 même cathy
apourceau poly
merci monsieur le président donc comme
nous avons eu l'occasion de le dire dans
notre motion d'irrecevabilité
constitutionnel et dans notre prise de
parole la multiplication des exo
les rations de cotisations sociales met
en péril notre système de protection
solidaire alors que le niveau des
exonérations et allègements de
cotisations a dépassé les recettes de la
pente la branche famille nous proposons
avec cet amendement de redéfinir les
relations entre l'état et la sécurité
sociale
selon nous la seule doctrine qui vaille
c'est de dire stop aux exonérations de
cotisations sociales
le point de non retour a été franchi
c'est l'ensemble de l'édifice qui
s'apprête à ses coups roulés à force de
réduire le pilier des cotisations
patronales et de leur non compensation
par l'état
pour ces raisons nous proposons un
mécanisme démocratique pour verrouiller
la prolifération des exonérations de
cotisations sociales
en effet la sécurité sociale appartient
aux assurés sociaux et leurs
représentants et leurs représentants que
gère de manière paritaire
syndicats et patronat il est donc
inadmissible que les décisions qui ont
des conséquences aussi graves que la non
compensation des exonérations par l'état
entraîne un déficit et donc réduisent
les prestations des assurés sociaux
pour toutes ces raisons nous proposons
que toute nouvelle dérogation au
principe de non compensations instituée
par la loi veil de 1994 fasse l'objet
d'un vote de la part des caisses de la
sécurité sociale
merci merci monsieur en apportant l'avis
de la commission le président un jeu
précise à madame approche au poly que
les caisses s'exprime déjà sur le plfss
sur l'ensemble du plfss sur pour les
caisses spécialisé sur le budget qui
leur incombe et on a et on participe et
un certain nombre d'entre nous participe
à la commission des comptes de la
sécurité sociale ils ont largement la
possibilité de s'exprimer de dire et
n'ont pas manqué de le faire sur les
dernières mesures de non de non
compensations
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est un
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre et du gouvernement
c'est le même avis que monsieur
rapporteur c'est le président l'article
203 du code de sécurité sociale prévu
déjà la saisine pour avis des conseils
l'amendement qui est proposé et évoque
l'idée d'un vote sans dire si un vote
favorable ou défavorable entraînerait
telles ou telles conséquences
défavorables car satisfait ou inopérants
donc je mets au mois l'amendement 573
avec deux avis défavorables de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour une sur l'amendement je l'avais sur
l'article suivant devance les deux très
bien ils viennent d'accord donc j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public du
groupe crc sur l'amendement 573 avec un
avis défavorable de la commission un
avis défavorable du gouvernement
il va être plus un procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 60 56 du règlement le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert voici le résultat
du scrutin numéro 36 d'amendements 573
contenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordés par les sénateurs au
groupe politique est notifié la
présidence nombre de votants 328 nombre
de suffrages exprimés
328 pour l'adoption 87 contre 241 le
sénat n'a pas adopté
donc je vais m
on voit l'article 3 il n'y a pas de
demande d'explications de vote je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe s'est resserré
donc il va être procédé au scrutin et le
scrutin est ouvert
donc voici les résultats du scrutin
numéro 31 sur l'article 3 conduit
l'ensemble délégation de vote accordés
par les sénateurs ou politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 341 nombre de suffrages exprimés
341 pour l'adoption 301 contre 40 donc
le sénat a adopté l'article 3
voilà pour le début de l'examen du
budget de la sécurité sociale dans
l'hémicycle un examen de textes sous
tension vous l'avez vue essentiellement
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu agnès
buzyn a annoncé des mesures en faveur de
l'hôpital mais qu'elles ne sont pas
contenues dans le texte les sénateurs
jugent donc que le texte est déjà caduc
deuxième sujet de friction l'article 3
de ce projet de loi sur la non
compensation des mesures d'urgence qui
ont été décidées pour faire face à la
crise des gilet jaune
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]